YEAH. NOT CALL TO ORDER THIS
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY 12 WE ARE MEETING
HERE IN ROOM 2200. UM THE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME UM THE HEARING
TODAY, ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THOSE OF YOU ON ZOOM AND,
UH, MY COLLEAGUE UH, SENATOR
MENJIVAR. TODAY WE'LL BE HEARING
ON REFORMING CHILDREN'S CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. RECENT MANDATES
AND INNOVATIONS WILL BE FOCUSED
ON THE RECENT CHANGES IN OUR
WELFARE SYSTEM, HOW THEY ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED. CHALLENGES
THAT REMAIN AND HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT CHILDREN IN
OUR SYSTEM. DURING THIS DURING
TODAY'S HEARING, WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM FROM ADVOCATES
COUNTIES, UM AND YOUTH WHO HAVE
LIVED EXPERIENCES AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE TESTIMONY
OF THAT LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
TESTIMONY AND HEARING HOW
CALIFORNIA IS DOING TO SERVE THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND WHAT
WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT THEM. I DO
WANT TO ENTER INTO THE RECORD
BRIEF BACKGROUND HERE. OK? RIGHT
BE READING FROM OUR, UM, OUR
BACKGROUND. UH, PAPER, UH,
CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES SYSTEM IS AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THE STATE'S SAFETY.
NET SOCIAL WORKERS IN EACH
COUNTY RECEIVED REPORTS OF ABUSE
OR NEGLECT, THEN THESE ARE
INVESTIGATED AND RESOLVED IN
THESE REPORTS. WHEN A CASE IS
SUBSTANTIATED, A FAMILY IS
EITHER PROVIDED WITH SERVICES TO
ENSURE A CHILD'S WELL-BEING AND
AVOID COURT INVOLVEMENT OR A
CHILD IS REMOVED AND PLACED INTO
FOSTER CARE IN 2023, THE STATE
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES RECEIVED
435,000 THREE 102 REPORTS OF
ABUSE OR NEGLECT. BETWEEN
OCTOBER 22ND BETWEEN OCTOBER
2022 AND SEPTEMBER 2023 48,295
REPORTS CONTAINED ALLEGATIONS
THAT WERE SUBSTANTIATED. AND
18,297 CHILDREN WERE REMOVED
FROM THEIR HOMES AND PLACED INTO
FOSTER CARE THROUGH THE èC W S¼
SYSTEM. AS OF OCTOBER, 1ST OF
2023. THERE ARE 45,044 CHILDREN
IN THE SYSTEM LIVING WITH THEIR
PARENTS. OR IN OUT OF HOME
ARRANGEMENTS. IN CALIFORNIA. THE
èC W S¼ IS STATE SUPERVISED AND
COUNTY ADMINISTERED. THE 58
COUNTIES EACH MAINTAIN A COUNTY
WELFARE AGENCY THAT HAS A 24
HOUR RESPONSE SYSTEM. THE SYSTEM
RECEIVES AN INVESTIGATES REPORTS
OF SUSPECTED NEGLECT OR CHILD
ABUSE. THE CWS IS CALIFORNIA'S
PRIMARY STATEWIDE INTERVENTIONS
PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN WHO HAVE
BEEN ABUSED, NEGLECTED OR
EXPLOITED. THE GOAL OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN THROUGH AN INTEGRATED
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND TO
PROVIDE PREVENTION AND INTENSIVE
SERVICES TO FAMILIES TO ENSURE
THAT ENOUGH CHILD SAFETY
PERMANENCY AND WELL-BEING TO
ALLOW FAMILIES TO STAY TOGETHER
IN THEIR OWN HOMES EXIST. IF A
CHILD IS DEEMED TO BE AT RISK BY
A COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER WITH
OVERSIGHT BY THE LOCAL JUVENILE
COURT, A TEMPORARY OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT IS ARRANGED WITH THE
GOAL OF REUNIFYING THE FAMILY
ONCE IT IS SAFE FOR THE CHILD.
IF FAMILY REUNIFICATION IS NOT
POSSIBLE. A PERMANENT PLACEMENT
IN THE SAFEST AND LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT IS
ARRANGED AND MONITORED BY COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES SERVES THE STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSIGHT OF THE
CW S¼ PROGRAM AND COLLABORATION
WITH OUR COUNTY, FEDERAL AND
TRIBAL PARTNERS. THE CWS PROGRAM
PROVIDES SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
, PROVIDING SERVICES THROUGH
FOUR VARIOUS COMPONENTS.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. FAMILY
MAINTENANCE. FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND PLACEMENT AND
PERMANENT PLACEMENT. WE ARE ALSO
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THE MOST
RECENT REFORM THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT IN 2018
CONGRESS PASSED AND THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED THE BIPARTISAN
BUDGET ACT OF 2018, WHICH
INCLUDES THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT. THIS
ACT INCLUDES TWO MAJOR REFORMS
OF HOW FEDERAL TITLE FOR FUNDS
CAN BE USED. FIRST IT REFORMED
THE WAY THAT CHILD WELFARE
FINANCING WORKED, ALLOWING
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO BE USED FOR
PREVENTION SERVICES, RATHER THAN
ONLY FOR A CHILD WHO HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILY. AND
PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE. SECOND
IT LIMITED FEDERAL FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND TEENS
IN GROUP CARE, AND UNDER THIS
ACT, PLACEMENTS AND SETTINGS
WITH MORE THAN SIX CHILDREN FOR
MORE THAN TWO WEEKS WERE
GENERALLY NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING. THE COMBINATION
OF THESE CHANGES IMPACTS BOTH
HOW SERVICES ARE DELIVERED AND
HOW THEY ARE REIMBURSED WITH
CONTINUED FOCUS ON THE BENEFITS
OF CHILDREN REMAINING IN THEIR
HOME OR IN THE CARE OF FAMILY
MEMBERS. WE WILL ALSO BE LOOKING
FORWARD IN THIS HEARING. IN THE
PAST DECADE, WE'VE SEEN A SERIES
OF SWEEPING REFORMS IN CHILD
WELFARE SPACE. THESE REFORMS
HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THE POOR
OUTCOMES THAT OCCUR WHEN PLACING
CHILDREN OUT OF HOME OR AWAY
FROM FAMILY AND WORK TO FOCUS ON
KEEPING CHILDREN EITHER WITH
THEIR PARENTS. OR IN THE CARE OF
FAMILY MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA HAS A
COMMITMENT AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK DILIGENTLY TO THE
REFORMS SET FORTH IN THE
FAMILY'S FIRST ACT AND BEGUN THE
PROCESS OF THESE IMPLEMENTATION.
AS WITH ALL SWEEPING REFORM
PROGRAMS, CHALLENGES WILL ARISE
AND OFFER OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATION TO
FULFILL THE VISION OF THIS ACT.
THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S
HEARING. WE HAVE A VERY FULL
AGENDA WITH WONDERFUL SPEAKERS
AND IN ORDER FOR US TO ALLOW
EVERYONE TO HAVE ADEQUATE TIME
TO PRESENT. I'M ASKING THAT WE
KEEP OUR REMARKS FROM 5 TO 7
MINUTES TO ALLOW FOR QUESTIONS.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. I'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR
DIRECTOR KI¾M JOHNSON OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO THE TABLE AS WELL AS
DANIEL WEBSTER FROM CHILD
CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE
INDICATORS PROJECT. THESE TWO
WITNESSES WILL BE PRESENTING ON
HOW THE STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS
HAVE CHANGED TO FOCUS ON FAMILY
BASED SYSTEMS OF CARE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY, PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS, KI¾M
JOHNSON, DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, AND APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THE COMMITTEE'S FOCUS. UH,
THIS MORNING ON THIS CRITICAL
TOPIC, AND AS YOU REFERENCED IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS, MADAM
CHAIR, CHILD WELFARE IN
CALIFORNIA, UH, IS COUNTY
ADMINISTERED WITH STATE
OVERSIGHT, THE PRIMARY GOAL OF
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IS
REUNIFICATION, AND WHEN
REUNIFICATION CANNOT HAPPEN,
IT'S TO ENSURE THAT CHILDREN THE
CHILDREN ARE IN A PERMANENT AND
LOVING FAMILY. CALIFORNIA TOOK
ON WHAT WE REFERENCE AS THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM OR CCR.
WE ACTUALLY BEGAN IMPLEMENTING
èC R IN 2017, AND THEN AGAIN
WAS FOUNDED UPON THE COLLECTIVE
BELIEF THAT ALL CHILDREN SERVED
BY THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM NEED
DESERVE AND HAVE AN ABILITY TO
BE PART OF A LOVING FAMILY AND
NOT TO GROW UP IN A CONGREGATE
SETTING. IN ADDITION, I WANT TO
NOTE THAT IT'S CRITICAL THAT TO
NOTE THAT THE DISPARITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONALITY, PARTICULARLY
OF BLACK, AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
NATIVE AMERICAN CHILDREN, HAVE
WHICH HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
OVERREPRESENTED IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THAT THAT INEQUITY
IS ALSO PARTLY DRIVING OUR
POLICY AND THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY. OUR MAJOR ELEMENTS
OF THE CONTINUUM CARE REFORM
INCLUDED THE BROAD EXPANSION OF
THE USE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMING, WHICH INSURES THAT
SERVICES DELIVERED TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN THE CONTEXT OF A
SINGLE INTEGRATED SYSTEM. THE
INTEGRATED CORE PRACTICE MODEL,
WHICH SERVES AS A FRAMEWORK THAT
SETS THAT CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM
AS THE PRIMARY VEHICLE FOR THE
TEAM. BA, UH, BASED PROCESS AND
IMPLEMENTING FOUR PHASES,
INCLUDING ENGAGEMENT, SERVICE,
PLANNING, MONITORING AND
ADAPTING AND TRANSITION. AND THE
CREATION OF AN EMERGENCY
CAREGIVER PROGRAM, WHICH ALLOWS
YOU TO BE IMMEDIATELY PLACED
WITH A RELATIVE OR FAMILY MEMBER
BEFORE THAT INDIVIDUAL IS
APPROVED AS A RESOURCE FAMILY.
ALSO èC èC R INCLUDED
ESTABLISHING RATE EQUITY FOR
CHILDREN PLACED IN RELATIVE
HOMES TO ENSURE FUNDING PROVIDED
IS COMMENSURATE WITH NEEDS AND
TO PROMOTE CHILDREN STAYING
WITHIN THEIR OWN FAMILY, EVEN IF
HIGHER LEVELS OF FUNDING AND
SERVICES ARE REQUIRED AND
ESTABLISHING A NEW HOME BASED
FAMILY CARE RATE STRUCTURE THAT
IS TIED TO THE CHILD'S ASSESSED
LEVEL OF CARE NEEDS SO THAT
CHILDREN DO NOT TO MOVE PLACES
TO GET ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
SUPPORT. EXPANSION OF THE
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT YOUTH WITH
COMPLEX OR HIGHER LEVELS OF
NEEDS IN HOME BASED SETTINGS,
FUNDING TO SUPPORT BEST PRACTICE
AND INNOVATIONS AND FAMILY
FINDING AND FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT AND SUPPORT AND
FINALLY NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
CONGREGATE CARE PROVIDERS AIMED
AT ENSURING THAT THOSE SETTINGS
ARE PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY AND
THERAPEUTIC SUPPORTS TO MEET
INDIVIDUAL TREATMENT TREATMENT
TREATMENT NEEDS AND TO ENSURE
THAT YOUTH ARE TRANSITIONED TO A
LESS RESTRICTIVE SETTING AS SOON
AS THEY NÓ LONGER HAVE A NEED
FOR THAT THERAPEUTIC OR HIGHER.
LEVEL SETTING. OUTCOMES OF CðC,
èC, R AND RELA RELATED RECENT
REFORMS IN RECENT YEARS INCLUDE
THAT YOUTH PLACEMENT INTO
CONGREGATE CARE HAS DECREASED BY
ALMOST 60% WHILE PLACEMENTS INTO
HOME BASED SETTINGS. THE
ULTIMATE GOAL FOR FOSTER YOUTH
HAS INCREASED FOSTER YOUTH
SUPERVISED BY COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE DEPARTMENTS. THERE'S
BEEN A 24% INCREASE IN YOUTH
THAT HAVE A FIRST PLACEMENT WITH
A RELATIVE OR EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBER AND A 7% INCREASE WITH
YOUTH WHOSE PREDOMINANT
PLACEMENT IS WITH A RELATIVE OR
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER.
PLACEMENT STABILITY INDICATORS
FOR CHILDREN REMAINING IN THEIR
FIRST PLACEMENT HAVE ALSO
CONTINUED TO GROW 75% OF YOUTH
THAT HAD THEIR FIRST PLACEMENT
WITH A RELATIVE ARE AND ARE
STILL IN CARE AT 12 MONTHS ARE
STILL WITH THAT SAME RELATIVE.
THE NUMBER OF RESOURCE FAMILY
HOMES APPROVED EACH QUARTER, ONE
OF THE MOST CRITICAL ELEMENTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM HAS STEADILY INCREASED.
AND MORE THAN 87% PERCENT OF
YOUTH IN THE SHORT TERM,
THERAPEUTIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS RECEIVE
CRITICAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES. THIS IS A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN YOUTH
RECEIVING THESE SUPPORTS DUE TO
THE FOCUS REFORMS UNDER CCR. UM
SO JUST A FEW OF THE OUTCOMES I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. I ALSO WANT
TO JUST NOTE, UH, OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS. WE'VE ALSO
TOGETHER. GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY HAVE PUT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS LIKE THE
CENTER FOR FAMILY FINDING
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT. UM AND
THAT AGAIN IS FOCUSED INVESTMENT
TO ENSURE THAT COUNTIES BOTH
HAVE THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO
REALLY LOOK DO THE FAMILY
FINDING OBLIGATIONS, BUT ALSO
THAT WE'RE LIFTING AT THE BEST
PRACTICES IN THE SPACE. AS YOU
MENTIONED CHAIR AS CALIFORNIA
WAS LEADING THE WAY WITH CðC èC
R THAT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES
ACT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN 2018
SIMILAR GOALS IN TERMS OF
REDUCTION AND REDUCING ENTRIES
INTO CONGREGATE CARE. UM AND
AGAIN, IT ALSO HAD SOME
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO HAVING AN ASSESSMENT BY A
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL TO
DETERMINE HOW A CHILD'S NEEDS
CAN BE MET IN A HOME BASE
SETTING. UH, THERE WAS ALSO
REQUIREMENTS FOR DISCHARGE,
PLANNING AND FAMILY BASED
AFTERCARE SUPPORTS TO MAKE SURE
THOSE TRANSITIONS WERE
SUCCESSFUL. IT REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTATION OF
CHILD WELFARE AND PROBATION CASE
PLANS, AND IT ALSO REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL COURT OVERSIGHT OF
PLACEMENTS INTO SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
. THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE'RE
REFERENCING AS PART FOUR OF THE
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES
ACT. IT ALSO HAD SOMETHING
CALLED PART ONE, WHICH IS THE
PREVENTATIVE, UH, COMPONENT OF
FAMILY FIRST, UH AND THAT WAS
AGAIN TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
UTILIZING THOSE SPECIFIC
EVIDENCE BASED MENTAL HEALTH,
SUBSTANCE USE AND IN HOME
PARENTING, SKILL BASED SERVICES,
PREVENTING YOUTHS ENTRY INTO
FOSTER CARE. SERVICES PROVIDED
TO CHILDREN AT IMMINENT RISK OF
INJURY. THEIR PARENTS CAN
CAREGIVERS PREGNANT OR PARENTING
YOUTH. UH AND ALSO, UH, UH,
LARGER POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
. WE HAVE OUR FIVE YEAR
PREVENTION PLAN THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN APRIL OF LAST YEAR
. IN ADDITION AGAIN, WE HAD
INVESTED A LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR, UH, IN A 224,000,001
TIME, UH, BLOCK GRANT RELATED TO
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTION
SERVICES. TO DATE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS REVIEWED AND APPROVED 50.
ONE OF THOSE PLANS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL, AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PARTNERS THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
TO AGAIN. LIFT UP BEST PRACTICE
HAVE THE ABILITY FOR PEER TO
PEER SUPPORT AS WELL AS MAPPING
OUT THE COMMUNITY-BASED PATHWAYS
THAT ARE PREVENTATIVE GOING
FORWARD, SO A LOT GOING ON IN
THAT SPACE AS WELL AND ALWAYS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT WE
ARE ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE YOUTH
WE ARE SUPPORTING CURRENTLY, BUT
ALSO DOING THAT PREVENTION WORK
AHEAD. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
WE ALSO ARE BEING VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT FOCUSING ON
THE DISPARITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONALITY SO JUST
INTERNAL TO THE DEPARTMENT. I
WANTED TO LIFT UP A COUPLE OF
THINGS. WE Dð S¼ S¼ HAVE CRE
CREATED HIGHER LEVEL LEADERSHIP
AND ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF EQUITY
AND INCLUSION TO REALLY ADVISE
AND ASSIST EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP
IN THE FORMATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND EVALUATION OF
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS, PROMOTING
EQUITY AND ADDRESSING THESE
DISPARITIES. WE'VE ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED OUR
OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS AND
THEIR FOCUS IS LOOKING AT
COMPLIANCE WITH THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT, WHICH IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON, UM, LOOKING AT
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES AGAIN, UH,
HOPEFULLY PREVENTING THOSE
HIGHER LEVELS OF INTERVENTION,
UH, LOOKING AT THE WHOLE FAMILY
AND THEIR CULTURAL CONTEXT, UM,
AND HAVING ACTIVE, ACTIVE
EFFORTS THAT GO BEYOND THE
PROVISION OF REASONABLE SERVICES
BY REQUIRING PROVIDERS TO
CONNECT THE FAMILY DIRECTLY TO
SERVICE AND SUPPORT RATHER THAN
REFERRALS. CALIFORNIA HAS
ADOPTED MANY LAWS THAT GO BEYOND
THE FEDERAL INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
ACT. BUT WE'VE ALSO AGAIN
INVESTED IN TRIBES AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
AGAIN, THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE DID THE ONE OF ITS
FIRST IN THE NATION, UH,
INVESTMENT IN THE TRIBAL
DEPENDENCY REPRESENTATION
PROGRAM, WHICH IS SUPPORTING
TRIBES TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE REPRESENTATION IN THEIR
DEPENDENCY, YOUTH PROCEEDINGS.
WE'VE ALSO INVESTED IN THE
TRIBALLY APPROVED HOMES, WHICH
IS FUNDING TO ELIGIBLE INDIAN
TRIBES TO ASSIST IN FUNDING THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH RECRUITING
AND APPROVING HOMES FOR THEY
SPENT OF AN INDIAN CHILD. AS WE
TURN FORWARD AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT'S NEXT. WE CERTAINLY HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO TO ADDRESS
INEQUITIES AND ENSURING THAT WE
ARE FULFILLING THE PROMISE AND
OBJECTIVES OF CðC R. WE ALSO
HAVE TO DO MORE TO APPROPRIATELY
SERVE CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER USE
WITH A HIGHER LEVELS OF NEEDS OF
CARE THAT ARE GOING UNMET. AS WE
ADDRESS THESE GAPS, IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THE INVESTMENT
SUPPORT THE ROBUST CONTINUUM OF
CARE TO ENSURE THAT THE
TRANSITION PATHWAYS FOR ALL
CHILDREN CAN BE AGAIN FOCUSED ON
THAT FAMILY BASED ENVIRONMENT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
PROPOSAL TO RESTRUCTURE OUR
RATES. THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAD PUT FORWARD BEFORE. SO
THERE WAS A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT BY JANUARY
1 OF 2025 THAT WE HAVE OUR NEW,
UH, RATE STRUCTURE, SO WE ARE
PROPOSING TO RESTRUCTURE OUR
RATES SO THAT THEY ARE BASED ON
THE CHILD'S LEVEL OF ASSESSED,
NEED AND STRENGTHS AND NOT BASED
ON THE PLACEMENT TYPE. THAT'S
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT,
AND IN FACT, CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
THE FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
TAKE THIS APPROACH. THIS
PROPOSAL BE ADOPTED. IT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FUTURE AND AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS MAKING
SURE THAT CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO THRIVE. THE STRUCTURE
INVEST DIRECTLY IN FAMILY BASED
FAMILY BASED PLACEMENTS TO KEEP
YOUTH CONNECTED TO THEIR
RELATIVES IN THE COMMUNITY OF
ORIGIN. IT'S BASED AGAIN ON THE
CHILD'S IDENTIFIED NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS. AS IDENTIFIED BY THE
STANDARDIZED ASSESSMENT. WE CALL
IT THE CANS ASSESSMENT TOOL AND
AGAIN NOT TIED TO PLACEMENT, AND
IT SPECIFICALLY INCLUDES
FUNDING, SUPPORT, STRENGTH
BUILDING AND TO ADDRESS CHILD'S
YOUTH, IMMEDIATE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. IT ADVANCES EQUITY AGAIN
IN A CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM BY
STRENGTHENING OUR KIN FIRST
CULTURE, KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER WHENEVER POSSIBLE AND
PUTTING, UH, SERVICES IN PLACE
BASED ON THOSE CHILD'S NEEDS,
NOT BASED ON THE PLACEMENT TYPE,
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO GIVING YOU
MORE DETAILS OF THAT PROPOSAL AS
WE GO THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCEEDINGS AND GLAD TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DIRECTOR
JOHNSON, UM, SOUNDS VERY
PROMISING. I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT PROPOSAL. UM,
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO CALIFORNIA.
UH, CHILD WELFARE INDICATORS.
PROJECT LEAD DANIEL WEBSTER AND
I UNDERSTAND YOU ALSO HAVE A
PRESENTATION. I DO, MADAM
CHAIRPERSON. I DON'T I. I WAS
KIND OF AS AN ACADEMIC. I WAS
PLANNING ON LIKE A THREE HOUR
DISCOURSE. SEVEN MINUTES. I'M
GONNA KEEP MY REMARKS BRIEF. BUT
YOU DO HAVE THE SLIDES IN FRONT
OF YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
REFERENCE, I WILL SAY ON THE DAY
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR OF A LONG
STANDING PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, THE COUNTIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS OF CALIFORNIA. I
WAS DELIGHTED TO HEAR YOUR
COMMENTS AT THE OPENING OF THE
MEETING AROUND DATA POINTS. MY
COLLEAGUE DIRECTOR JOHNSON ALSO
PUT OUT DATA POINTS. I THINK IT
UNDERSCORES THE NEED. WE NEED
GOOD DATA FOR OUR DECISION
SUPPORT AND TO EVALUATE THE
IMPACT OF OUR POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS AND TO HELP US TO GUIDE
QUESTIONS OF NEW POLICIES THAT
WE THINK WE MAY WANT TO
IMPLEMENT. AND SO AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE, THE LEADER OF
THE PARTNERSHIP AT BERKELEY,
WITH WITH OVER TWO DECADES OF
WORKING WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE UH IT'S A IT'S AN
UNPRECEDENTED PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR MISSION IS TO PROVIDE
RELIABLE, ACCURATE AND TIMELY
DATA TO DO THAT KIND OF SUPPORT.
THE SLIDES THAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU ARE ALL TAKEN FROM
A PUBLIC WEBSITE THAT THE URL IS
ON THE FRONT PAGE. I WAS UNABLE
TO CALL IT UP HERE BECAUSE OF
FIREWALL ISSUES, BUT YOU CAN GO
THERE. IT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
IT HAS BEEN FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES. MANY OF THE DATA POINTS
THAT YOU REFERENCED AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUE KI¾M JOHNSON
REFERENCED ARE TAKEN FROM THERE.
AND I REALLY I CAN'T UNDERSCORE
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND BY HAVING THOSE DATA
AVAILABLE, WHICH TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S CREDIT IT HAS DONE
AND IT'S A IT'S A MODEL FOR
OTHER STATES AND, UH, WITHOUT
BEING GRANDIOSE IT. IT REALLY
WILL OUT HERE. I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY OTHER STATE IN THE IN
THE NATION THAT HAS AS MUCH
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA TO GUIDE
US AS AS WHAT'S ON ON THE
BERKELEY WEBSITE II. I HAVE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SLIDES. I
COULD SHOW YOU THE RATES THAT
HAVE BEEN DECLINING OVER PAST
YEARS. THE AND YET WHEN YOU
BREAK APART THE ANY GIVEN RATE
ANY TIME YOU LOOK AT A DATA
POINT, A SUMMARY FOR EXAMPLE,
THE DECLINING RATES OF ALL
CHILDREN WHO ARE THE SUBJECT OF
ALLEGATIONS SUBSTANTIATIONS
ENTRIES TO CARE ANYTIME YOU
SUMMARIZE DATA. IMPORTANT DETAIL
IS LOST. AND SO YOU NEED TO BE
ABLE TO STRATIFY DISAGGREGATE
BREAK APART. DIFFERENT DATA
POINTS TO LOOK AT SUBPOPULATIONS
IN ORDER TO TARGET YOUR
RESOURCES. AND SO I CAN SHOW YOU
THIS GREAT PICTURE OF DECLINING
RATES OF SYSTEM PERFORMANCE. BUT
WHEN I BREAK ANY GIVEN RATE
APART, FOR EXAMPLE, THIS IS
ENTRIES TO CARE RATE DECLINING A
LITTLE BIT LOWER THAN IT IS
NATIONALLY THAN OUR THAN OUR
COUNTERPARTS NATIONALLY. BUT
WHEN YOU BREAK IT APART BY
ETHNIC GROUP, FOR EXAMPLE, AS
DIRECTOR JOHNSON MENTIONED WE
HAVE RACIAL DISPARITIES, AND
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT THIS
GRAPH SHOWS US SHOWING THE
DIFFERENT CONTACT POINTS AND THE
AND THE RACIAL DISPARITIES, UH,
AT THE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
SYSTEM CONTACT. EVEN WHEN YOU
CONTROL FOR POVERTY, WE SEE
PERSISTENT DISPARITIES AND AS AS
AS DIRECTOR JOHNSON MENTIONED,
THE STATE AND OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS ARE WORKING HARD TO
MAKE INROADS ON THAT. WE TALKED
ABOUT THE DECLINE WITH THE
DECLINING ENTRIES, BUT LARGER
PROPORTION PLACED WITH RELATIVES
, SMALLER PROPORTION PLACED WITH
CONG CARE. THAT'S A GOOD THING.
I WON'T THERE ARE FEDERAL
MEASURES ALL GREAT MEASURES OF
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE AGAIN. THESE
ARE THESE ARE STATEWIDE
PERFORMANCE. I WON'T, UH, YOU
KNOW, UH, DILATE ON ON ON OUR
PERFORMANCE ON ANY OF THEM. I'LL
JUST SKIP TO THE TO THE BOTTOM
TO THE BOTTOM LINE, WHICH I
WOULD SAY IS NÓ OUTCOME MEASURE
IN ISOLATION. IS ENOUGH TO TELL
YOU HOW A SYSTEM IS PERFORMING.
WE HAVE ALL THE MEASURES THAT I
PROVIDED FOR YOU AND THAT ARE ON
OUR WEBSITE ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. THEY'RE NECESSARY, BUT
THEY'RE NOT SUFFICIENT. WE NEED
TO. UM THANK YOU. UH WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO ASK GOOD RESEARCH
QUESTIONS. WE NEED TO HAVE THESE
DATA AVAILABLE NOT ONLY FOR OUR
PRACTITIONERS, BUT ALSO FOR OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. I WAS I'M VERY
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT WE HAVE, UH,
PRACTITIONERS AND FOLKS WITH
LIVE EXPERIENCE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE AGAIN, NOT ONLY DOES NOT
ONE DATA POINT TELL YOU THE
WHOLE STORY, BUT YOU NEED TO
KNOW THE STORY BEHIND THE
NUMBERS. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES THAT CAN
ENGAGE IN A CONVERSATION ON WHAT
THE DATA MEAN AND HOW WE CAN USE
THEM TO IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM. AND
I'M AND I THINK WE'VE MOVED IN
THAT DIRECTION AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT LEVELS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND SO NÓ SINGLE MEASURE
TELLS US THE WHOLE STORY. WE
NEED TO MAKE GOOD RESEARCH
QUESTIONS, AND WE NEED TO HAVE
MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES TO HELP
INFORM THE CONVERSATION. FINALLY
I'LL SAY CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
DATA BY ITSELF IS NOT ENOUGH, I
THINK, AND WE'VE I KNOW THAT
THAT, UH, THE STATE HAS BEEN
DOING A LOT OF DATA LINKAGES,
AND I THINK THAT IN ORDER TO GET
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE, WE
NEED TO MOVE TOWARDS DATA
LINKAGES SO THAT WE CAN SEE
CROSS SYSTEM IMPACT. UH, THAT
AFFECTS THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
. LINKAGES WITH EDUCATION
LINKAGES WITH EMPLOYMENT
LINKAGES WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
OTHER SYSTEMS LIKE THAT. SO I
THINK BY THE MORE DATA WE CAN
BRING TO BEAR, THE MORE THE MORE
N AND DETAILED QUESTIONS WE CAN
ANSWER THAT CAN HELP US TARGET
OUR RESOURCES TO THE POPULATIONS
THAT THAT NEED OUR HELP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UM I'M ALSO A DATA
HUNG HUNGRY PERSON. SO I. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND MAKING THOSE
KEY TRENDS AND CONSIDERATIONS AT
THE FOREFRONT. I WANT TO OPEN IT
UP TO QUESTIONS, SENATOR
MENJIVAR. UM I WILL GIVE YOU THE
SPACE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
UM I MEAN, I LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO GET
ANOTHER HEARING OUT OF SUB
THREE. ON TOP OF THIS. THIS IS
SO GREAT. I'M DIRECTOR JOHNSON.
UM, FIRST TIME HEARING SOME
PRELIMINARY INFORMATION ON THE
FOSTER RATE REFORM. LOOKING
FORWARD TO DIVING MORE INTO THAT
AS THE YOU MENTIONED THE BUDGET
PROCEEDS, BUT YOU ENDED YOUR
COMMENTS ON ON A AAA TOPIC THAT
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
YOU SAID IMPORTANT THAT THE
INVESTMENTS MEETS AND THEN I
FORGOT THE REST. BUT THAT PART
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK WE'RE WE'RE MEETING
THAT INVESTMENT. I THINK, UM, TO
QUOTE CAL MATTERS LAST YEAR ON
THIS TOPIC WAS NÓ BUDGET
SHORTFALL, LACK OF POLITICAL
WILL OR MIXED UP PRIORITIES
SHOULD FURTHER DELAY SUPPORT.
THEY NEED TO THRIVE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT OUR FOSTER YOUTH, AND WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS FOSTER
SYSTEM TO HOMELESS PIPELINE.
THINK WE REALLY REGARDLESS OF
WHAT IS GOING ON, REALLY DIVE
IN, SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF
THINGS IN YOU SHARED IN THE
FOSTER RATE REFORM SOME THINGS
THAT MAYBE ARE GONNA REPLACE
SOME OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN AWAY FROM IT, BUT I'M
JUST STILL VERY WORRIED ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE THERE TO
SUPPORT OUR OUR PLACEMENTS. THE
PROGRAMS ARE THERE TO SUPPORT
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE ARE BEING
PULLED AWAY AND HOW WE'RE SEEING
. WE'RE GONNA SUPPLEMENT THAT
LACK OF INVESTMENT, ENSURING
THAT THE FOSTER KIDS ARE
THRIVING. SO IT'S A VERY BIG,
VAGUE QUESTION, YOU KNOW? JUST
ANYTHING YOU CAN ADDRESS FURTHER
ADDRESS ON THAT. APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH SENATOR AND ABSOLUTELY
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
DISCUSSION RELATED TO THE RATE
REFORM PROPOSAL. AND YES, THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS IN THE
BUDGET, UH, ONE OF WHICH IS
RELATED TO THE SUPERVISOR,
INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAM.
THERE WAS ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENT
THAT WAS PROPOSED THAT IS
PROPOSED TO BE REMOVED AND SO
COMPLETELY APPRECIATE THE POINT
OF THEN HOW ARE WE LOOKING
HOLISTICALLY AT ENSURING THAT,
UH, YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND ESPECIALLY
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH HAVE THE
SUPPORTS. THEY NEED TO THRIVE
AND I THINK THAT'S AGAIN WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. UH,
THE RATE REFORM PROPOSAL.
CERTAINLY IT'S A IT'S A THREE
TIER WITH AAA THE THIRD TIER
HAVING AN A AND B COMPONENT
STRUCTURE, BUT AGAIN HAVING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO REALLY
SUPPORT AND MEET THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS OF YOUTH AND A STRENGTH
BUILDING WAY, RIGHT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. HOW DO WE NOT ONLY
INVEST IN SUPPORTING THE
STRENGTHS OF YOUTH, BUT ALSO,
UM, HOW HOW ARE THOSE THINGS
CRITICAL TO MAINTAINING THAT
STABILITY AND SUPPORT GOING
FORWARD? SO, UH, COMPLETELY THAT
WE HAVE TO BE DOING ALL OF THOSE
THINGS TOGETHER IN,
ADDITIONALLY, AS IT RELATES TO
HAVING FUNDING THAT FOLLOWS THAT
THE NEEDS OF THE YOUTH THAT
THERE IS ADDITIONAL CAPACITY
BUILDING WORK THAT WILL HAVE TO
DO AS A STATE IN WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS AND OUR
TRIBAL PARTNERS, UH, TO REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE ROBUST
SUPPORTS ARE AVAILABLE AND AGAIN
AVAILABLE. WHETHER THE YOUTH IS
IN A CONGREGATE SETTING OR THE
YOUTH IS IN A FAMILY BASED
SETTING, SO THERE'S SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK WE'LL NEED TO DO
ON BUILDING OUT THE CONTINUUM AS
WELL. THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
PREDICATED ON THIS NEW REFORM
STRUCTURE AND PROPOSAL THAT
WE'RE GOING FORWARD, BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT WE HAVE TO
BE THINKING ABOUT THE FULL KIND
OF AGE SPAN AND EXPERIENCE OF
YOUTH AND AS THEY ARE GETTING
TO, UH, OLDER AGES. WHAT ARE THE
SUPPORTS THAT WE CAN PUT IN
PLACE TO KEEP THEM CONNECTED
WAYS IN WHICH THEY'RE CONNECTED
TO THE REST OF THE SAFETY NET
SERVICES LIKE CAL FRESH SUPPORTS
AND OTHER MAYBE HOUSING SUPPORTS
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WE
ALSO THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE HAVE SUPPORTED IN A
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT THAT'S
FOCUSED ON FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AS ONE OF THE PRIMARY
POPULATIONS, SO WE NEED TO TAKE
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE, UH, IN APPLYING IT
AS WE'RE GOING FORWARD, SO JUST
APPRECIATE THAT. IT'S NOT ONLY
AGAIN, UH, JUST ABOUT THE TIME
EXPERIENCE IN FOSTER CARE, BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING POST AND HOW
ARE WE GETTING THAT NAVIGATION
AND SUPPORT CONNECTIONS PRIOR TO
EXIT OF THE SYSTEM? YOU I AGREE
WITH YOU? YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
DOING A TOUR OF OUR JUVENILE
HALLS AND JUST VARIOUS FIRE
CANS. MAJORITY OF THESE KIDS,
THEY TELL ME I WAS IN THE FOSTER
SYSTEM. THERE'S ALSO THAT
PIPELINE INTO JS. UM, COULD YOU
SHARE A LITTLE BIT? HOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS ANTICIPATING
REPLICATING OR SUPPLEMENTING THE
SERVICES THAT FIRST PROVIDED THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM IF
THAT PROGRAM GOES AWAY, WHAT
OTHER PROGRAM DOES THE
DEPARTMENT SEE AS YOU GIVING
THOSE SERVICES THAT WERE NEEDED
TO FAMILIES? THANK YOU, SENATOR
FOR THE QUESTION. SO YES, THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY. 10 ALSO
PROPOSED. REDUCTION AND
ELIMINATION OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM. THIS IS AGAIN
UH UH, AS IT AS ITS TITLED AN
ABILITY TO HELP CONNECT FAMILIES
TO THIS TO THE SUPPORTS. THEY
NEED AT THE TIME. THEY NEED THEM
KIND OF THE 24 7 AVAILABILITY
AND THEN CONNECTING TO OTHER
RESOURCES SHOULD THEY NEED THEM
BEYOND THAT, THAT PHONE CALL AND
THAT CONVERSATION SO WHAT I
WOULD SAY TO THAT PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL, AND WHAT ELSE IS IN
PLACE IS CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE HAVE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT AND UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENT INVESTMENT IN
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. UH AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF RESOURCES THAT HAVE
BEEN STOOD UP AND THAT ARE IN
THE PIPELINE TO BE STOOD UP IN
CONNECTION TO THAT. IT'S ABOUT
AGAIN, MAKING SURE YOU HAVE
DIRECT CONNECTION TO THE
RESOURCES SHOULD THEY NEED THEM,
WHETHER THAT'S A COUNSELOR OR A
CASE MANAGER BUT ALSO FOR
FAMILIES IN IN DIFFERENT
RESPECTS THAT WE HAVE. IT IS NOT
THE SAME. EXACTLY THE SAME. UH
BUT AGAIN, UH, WE WOULD EXPECT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE MAKING
INTENTIONAL BRIDGES TO SOME OF
THOSE SUPPORTS. SHOULD THAT
PROPOSAL GO FORWARD AS A AS A
REDUCTION AS IT'S PROPOSED?
SURE. CAN I SQUEEZE IN ONE MORE
QUESTION IN HERE? UM LET'S LET'S
SWITCH OVER TO. WE TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING KIDS
IN THE FAMILIES AND IN THE
FAILURE TO PROTECT TOPIC HAS
BEEN IN THE NEWS FOR THE PAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS. UM AND YOU
KNOW, THERE'S IT'S SPLIT DOWN
THE MIDDLE BETWEEN A IT OF WE
SHOULD KEEP THEM IN THERE. POST
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALL BECAUSE
IT CAUSES MORE HARM TO REMOVE
THEM. OTHERS SAY, NÓ. WE NEED TO
TAKE HIM OUT. WHAT, IF ANY, IS
THE DEPARTMENT IN COALITION
BUILDING DOING AROUND THIS TOPIC
TO FIND A BETTER APPROACH TO
WHAT I THINK. IT'S NOT WORKING
SO WELL, YEAH. JUST AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION, SENATOR
AND UNDERSCORE THE TRAUMA
ASSOCIATED WITH BEING REMOVED
FROM YOUR FAMILY JUST TO
COMPLETELY UNDERSCORE. UH UH,
THE, UH YOU CAN'T. YOU CAN'T
CAN'T EMPHASIZE THAT ENOUGH. SO
SOME THAT SAY, LIKEN IT TO YOU
KNOW, OPEN HEART SURGERY. IT'S A
HUGE, SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FOR
CHILDREN IN THAT EXPERIENCE AND
CERTAINLY WANT, UH, YOU KNOW,
REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE HOW
WE'RE TAKING IT AS SUCH, IN
TERMS OF THE TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACHES THAT WE'RE HAVING,
UM, I WILL SAY THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR SPACE THERE'S A FEW
DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS AND, UM,
UH, TABLE SET TO EXPLORE THIS
ONE OF WHICH IS, UM WHAT WE'RE
REFERENCING AS MOVING FROM
MANDATED REPORTING TO COMMUNITY
SUPPORTING, AND THAT'S A TASK
FORCE AND EFFORT. THAT'S PART OF
THE SUBCOMITTEE OF THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL. THAT'S LOOKING
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT, UH, ENTRY
INTO CARE TO YOUR TO YOUR
QUESTION AND POINT AND HOW ARE
WE? WHEN WE CAN CONNECTING TO
THE SUPPORTS. THEY NEED AS
OPPOSED TO THAT REFERRAL THAT
MAY END UP WITH THE REMOVAL. HOW
ARE WE LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE
PROCESSES IN THE IN PLACE AND
AGAIN BEING VERY MINDFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THAT DECISION
POINT, RIGHT? AND WE SAY,
KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER
WHENEVER POSSIBLE, RECOGNIZING
IN SOME CASES, IT'S NOT. UM, SO
THAT IS ONE SPACE. WE ALSO HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE TO PARTNER,
UM WITH PHILANTHROPY TO LOOK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HOW WE'RE
SUPPORTING, UH, SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND ABUSE. AND
IN THAT REPORT WHICH WILL BE OUT
LIKELY, UH, IN THE COMING WEEKS,
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP, UH,
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND SHARE
THAT, UH, HAS A BIT ABOUT
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS SPACE
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING, UM, ON
HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THE SURVIVOR NEEDS. HOW THE
CONNECTION FOR THEIR CHILDREN?
WHAT DO WHAT DO WE NEED TO LOOK
AT IN A POLICY LENS IN THAT
SPACE? SO IT'S ESSENTIALLY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT, UH, THROUGH
FOCUS GROUPS OF BOTH SURVIVORS,
UH, A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS, COUNTIES AS WELL
AS STATE STAFF, SO WE WILL.
WE'RE GLAD TO AGAIN SHARE THAT
WITH THE COMMITTEE COMING
FORWARD. SO AGAIN, I THINK TO
YOUR POINT, UH, THINKING ABOUT
HOW SERIOUS THAT DECISION IS,
AND WHAT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE YOUTH AND FAMILY HAS TO
LEAD THAT. AND THEN AGAIN, HOW
IF A, UH YOUTH IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO STAY WITH THE PARENT,
THE SURVIVING PARENT? WHAT ARE
THE VERSUS THAT IMMEDIATELY NEED
TO BE PUT IN PLACE TO CONNECT
THEM. WE'VE DONE A LOT OF POLICY
CHANGE TOGETHER. UH, THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
IN THIS SPACE SO THAT THINGS
LIKE SELF ATTESTATION, AS
OPPOSED TO PROVING YOU DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO INCOME OF THE
PARTNER. WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
ABILITY TO CONNECT TO THE SAFETY
NET IS IMMEDIATE, AND IT MAKES
ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD
OF THE ABILITY FOR THE SURVIVOR
TO BE STABLE AND CONNECTED AS
THEY AS THEY'RE HEALING. SO UM,
I, I WOULD EXPECT THAT WE'LL
HAVE MORE CONVERSATION IN THIS
SPACE TO COME. BUT AGAIN, WE
HAVE TWO KIND OF FOCUSED
CONVERSATIONS INTENTIONALLY
THERE THAT WE'RE GLAD TO BRING
FORWARD IN TERMS OF NEXT STEPS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON POLICY
DEVELOPMENT. CAN I JUST
INTERJECT SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT
THE DIRECTOR JOHNSON WAS SAYING
AROUND, FOR EXAMPLE, THE TASK
FORCE SHIFTING FROM MANDATED
REPORTED COMMUNITY SUPPORTING
THE NEED FOR DATA TO HELP US TO
GUIDE THAT THAT ENTERPRISE RIGHT
SO LIKE THE WE SHOWED THE
NUMBERS OF CHILDREN WHO WERE
REFERRED AND GIVEN YOUR YOU
MENTION IT. IT'S OVER 400,000
EVERY YEAR. A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
EVALUATED OUT RIGHT AND THAT IS
THE POPULATION THAT WE ARE
HOPING TO HELP SO THAT THEY
DON'T COME BACK TO THE
ATTENTION. THE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE WITH EVERY SUBSEQUENT
REPORT, THE RISK LEVEL GOES UP,
AND SO WE WANT TO TRY TO MAP OUT
THE NEEDS OF THAT ORIGINAL
POPULATION THAT COMES TO OUR
ATTENTION. SUBS SHE MENTIONED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER, MENTAL HEALTH, THESE
KINDS OF THINGS WE HAVE THE
DATA. RESOURCES WE NEED TO BRING
THEM TO BEAR TO FIND THOSE
TARGET POPULATIONS AND THEN TO
MAP OUT THE NEEDS AND THE
SERVICES AVAILABLE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN TRY TO
GET THOSE FOLKS TO HELP THAT
THEY NEED SO THAT THEY DON'T
COME BACK TO THE ATTENTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT. AND SO THAT'S A
THAT'S JUST ONE PLACE. WHERE
WHERE WHERE I'M HOPING AND I'M
CONFIDENT AND THE DATA IS GOING
TO HELP US TO GUIDE AND EVALUATE
THIS POLICY. IT'S IMPORTANT THIS
THIS CHANGE I. I FULLY SUPPORT
IT, BUT WE WANT TO BE MINDFUL.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TRACKING SAFETY ACROSS THE BOARD
. SO DOCTOR WEBSTER, WHAT IS IT
GONNA TAKE FOR US TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE ADEQUATE DATA? UM I
THINK THAT WE NEED THE
COMMITMENT. FIRST OF ALL, AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THAT FROM
OUR OUR COLLEAGUES THAT WE HAVE
THE COMMITMENT TO DO THAT. I
THINK WHERE THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME SOME, UH, SOME FIGURING OUT
TO DO, FOR EXAMPLE OF MAPPING
THE COMMUNITY PATHWAY, FOR
EXAMPLE, UH, WE WANT THE THERE'S
A THERE'S A, UH, THE POPULATIONS
OF FOLKS THAT ARE THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT COMING
TO THE ATTENTION OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. THEY GET
EVALUATED OUT. THEY MAY NOT BE
THAT WILLING TO CONNECT WITH
SOME OTHER THING IF THEY FEEL
SOME OTHER SOME OTHER UH UH,
SYSTEM IF THEY FEEL IT'S A FORM
OF SURVEILLANCE, AND SO WE HAVE
TO BE. WE HAVE TO RESPECT THAT.
BUT SO BUILDING THAT COMMUNITY
PATHWAY MAPPING OUT THE
RESOURCES MAPPING OUT THE NEEDS
OF OUR TARGET POPULATIONS. I
THINK WE THE DATA OUT THERE. WE
JUST NEED TO BRING THE MINDS TO
BEAR. WE HAVE THE COMMITMENT AND
WE NEED TO BRING THE MIND TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT IN A
PLANFUL WAY THAT IS THAT
SUPPORTS OUR OUR FAMILIES AND
BRINGS THEM IN, UH AND ASSURES
THEM THAT THIS IS NOT
SURVEILLANCE. WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO HELP YOU. SO I I'M ASKING THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT DATA BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES WE'RE ASKED TO MAKE
DECISIONS AROUND POLICY WITHOUT
HAVING THE DATA IN FRONT OF US.
WE KNOW THE STORIES. WE KNOW
WHAT WE EXPERIENCE WITHIN OUR
CONSTITUENT CIRCLES, BUT WE'VE
STRUGGLED AND IN ONE OF THOSE
AREAS HAS BEEN, UH, SERVICES. UM
AND POLICY FOR L, GB Tð Q, A
PLUS YOUTH AND EVEN LOOKING AT
TODAY'S PRESENTATION. IT'S NOT A
DATA SET THAT WE'RE ABLE TO PUT
OUR PUT OUR THUMBS ON. BUT I DO
THINK HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
SEEING THOSE TRENDS OF A SUBSET
OF YOUTH, PARTICULARLY OUR L. GB
Tð Q. UH A PLUS YOUTH THAT WE'RE
SEEING DIFFERENT TRENDS AND
INDICATORS. WHAT COULD YOU SAY
IN THAT ASPECT? NÓ. THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT. SENATOR AND I
WE NEED THE DATA TO TRACK THAT
POPULATION. I WILL. WE HAVE
INTRODUCED SOME FIELDS INTO OUR
OUR STATEWIDE AUTOMATED TRACKING
SYSTEM IN THE PAST YEAR OR TWO
TO DO THAT, BUT UPTAKE ON SUCH
THINGS TAKES TIME LIKE NOT
EVERYONE IS AWARE OF IT. I DON'T
KNOW THAT THEY'RE MANDATED
FIELDS. IF THE IF THE WORK AND
OUR WORKFORCE IS, YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE MANY THINGS TO DO, AND SO
ENTERING DATA IS NOT LIKE NOT
OFTEN TIMES, NOT AT THE TOP OF
THEIR, UH TO DO LIST. BUT I WILL
SAY THE DATA THE CAPACITY. IS IN
THERE. I THINK WE NEED TO KEEP
TRAINING OUR WORKFORCE AND HOW
TO ENGAGE WITH THE POPULATIONS
TO EVEN FIND FOR THEM TO
DISCLOSE IF, DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEY FALL ON THAT CONTINUUM, AND
THEN WE NEED TO BUILD IN. I
MENTIONED RACIAL DISPARITIES WE
NEED TO BUILD IN DISPARITIES FOR
THOSE KINDS OF L GB Tð Q
POPULATION, THE DISABLED
POPULATION THAT IS NOT STRICTLY
JUST THE RACE AND A RACE EQUITY.
WE HAVE EQUITY ISSUES FOR OTHER
POPULATIONS OF NEED, SUCH AS L
GB Tð Q. AND I THINK WE'VE GOT
THE DATA CAPACITY TO TRACK IT.
WE JUST NEED TO DO BETTER. UH, A
JOB ON THE UPTAKE. I WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT BECAUSE I THINK ALSO
THE DISABILITY POPULATION AS
WELL AS ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE POPULATION. UM ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I LOVE
CALIFORNIA IS THE DIVERSITY WHEN
I LOOK AT PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE SECTOR AND
CERTAINLY POLICY DECISIONS THAT
COME IN FRONT OF THIS BODY, THAT
IS WHAT I'M MISSING IN TERMS OF
OUR EQUITY LENS BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE IN ONE SIZE FITS ALL
PROGRAMMING. AND WHEN I HEAR
ABOUT, UM, PLACEMENTS THAT UM,
THAT GO AWRY OR THAT DON'T WORK
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT THAT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE CULTURAL
CONNECTION THE LANGUAGE. UM THE
SOCIAL CONNECTION. THE THESE ARE
MORE TRAUMATIC EVENTS FOR OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. AND AT TIMES, UM,
ELIMINATE THOSE CAREGIVERS FROM
BEING PART OF THE CYCLE OF CARE
FOR OUR KIDDOS. UM SO THAT DATA
FOR ME IS MISSING AND IN TERMS
OF HOW WE MAKE OUR DECISIONS TO
DR WEBSTER'S POINT, HOW WE MAKE
OUR DECISIONS AROUND PLACEMENT
AROUND SERVICES. AROUND FUNDING.
WE ARE IN THE DAY OF AGE THAT WE
SHOULD BE COLLECTING THAT
INFORMATION AND MAKING DECISIONS
FOR OUR YOUTH BASED ON WHAT IS
BETTER FOR THEM. AND YOU KNOW,
DR JOHNSON, I, UM OR MS JOHNSON,
I DID HEAR YOU AS WELL. I I
LOVED THE SHIFT FROM MANDATED
REPORTING TO COMMUNITY
SUPPORTING. I THINK THAT IS
PHENOMENAL. I THINK YOU KNOW,
TAKING AWAY THE KIND OF PUNITIVE
ASPECT OF ASKING FOR HELP AND TO
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT A SYSTEM
NEEDS EXTRA SUPPORT, AND THAT WE
HAVE THOSE SERVICES AVAILABLE, I
THINK HELPS US NOT ONLY TO BUILD
COMMUNITY BUT TO HELP BUILD THAT
FOUNDATION FOR THAT FAMILY
SUCCESS. UM SO I'M EXCITED TO
HEAR ABOUT THAT. UM, I DID WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ONE OTHER ASPECT
IN MY QUESTIONS. SO DOCTOR
JOHNSON, YOU'VE BEEN WITH US,
UM, IN YOUR CURRENT ROLE SINCE
JULY OF 2019 I COMING FROM THE
EDUCATION SECTOR. I KNOW THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAD A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OUR KIDS. PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS AND THE FAMILY AS A
WHOLE. WE SAW FAMILIES AND KIDS
BEING AT HOME OUT OF THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
. AND WITH THAT, UM, SOCIAL,
EMOTIONAL BEHAVIORS,
DEFICIENCIES AND THAT LACK OF
STABILITY OF HAVING A SAFE PLACE
TO GO FOR FOOD. FOR STRUCTURE,
LEARNING POSITIVE. MENTORS AND
THE ADULT WORLD. CAN YOU SAY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW YOU'VE SEEN
THE SHIFT IN WHAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS AND ARE YOU SEEING
ADEQUATE ATTENTION IN TERMS OF
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO THAT SHIFT? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR FOR THAT
QUESTION AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE POINT ABOUT TIMING AND
PANDEMIC. AND CERTAINLY WHILE
MANY OF US WERE TRYING TO
NAVIGATE STAYING HOME AND WHAT
THAT MEANT, WE WERE ALSO BEING
INTENTIONAL TO THINK ABOUT WHEN
HOME WASN'T A SAFE PLACE TO BE.
AND SO WE HAD A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENTS THAT AGAIN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
PUT FORWARD IN THAT TIME TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE RESOURCE
FAMILIES HAD ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS
THAT THE FAMILY WHO WAS
CONNECTING TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES THAT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GET TO THEM HAD THE
WEDGE FOR THE INFANTS THAT
ALLOWED THEM TO DO WORK ON THEIR
MOTOR SKILLS, THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS, SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
INTENTIONAL INVESTMENT IN THE
PANDEMIC THINKING THROUGH, UH,
THE FAMILIES WHO WOULD NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THAT THAT
EVEN MANAGING THE IDEA OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO CONNECT WITH
EDUCATION AND YOU KNOW, IT WAS A
GREATER BURDEN. WE HAD A LOT OF,
UM UH, KIND OF FOCUS GROUPS AND
CONVERSATION WITH FAMILIES TO
GET DIRECT ACCESS TO SAY, WHAT
DO YOU NEED? WHAT IS IT THAT YOU
NEED RIGHT NOW, UH, IN TERMS OF
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT, AND, UM,
CERTAINLY HAVE DONE A LOT IN
THAT SPACE. AND I THINK, UH, TO
SOME OF THE DATA THAT, UH DOCTOR
WEBSTER PRESENTED. WE ALSO, OF
COURSE, SAW REFERRALS DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC, AND THAT'S A LOT
RELATED TO MANDATED REPORTING
EDUCATION BEING ONE OF THE
PRIMARY. REPORTERS GOING FORWARD
, SO I THINK AGAIN BEING VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
MAKING SINCE THEN. AND HOW DO
THEY SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF YOUTH AND FOSTER CARE
HAS BEEN THE LENS BY WHICH WE'VE
DONE THAT, WHETHER WE'RE LOOKING
AT INVESTMENTS ON THE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SIDE IN CAL A OR B
HÌ CONNECT, IT'S AGAIN. HOW ARE
WE THINKING THROUGH? UM HOW
THESE NEW OPPORTUNITIES AND
RESOURCES ARE GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE? UM SO A LOT OF WORK HAS
BEEN DONE IN THAT SPACE AGAIN. I
MENTIONED VERY, VERY BRIEFLY. WE
DO ALSO RECOGNIZE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S MORE
WORK TO DO AND SOME GAPS FOR
YOUTH WITH HIGHER NEEDS. UH AND
SO THE WORK THROUGH WHAT WAS
REFERENCED AS ASSEMBLY BILL 2080
THREE, OUR SYSTEM OF CARE WORK,
WHICH BRINGS TOGETHER THOSE
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAMS OF THE
EDUCATION PARTNERS,
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES, HEALTH
CARE SOCIAL SERVICES AT THE
STATE LEVEL, BUT ALSO AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THEY'RE
COMING TOGETHER AROUND THE TABLE
, SAYING, THIS IS WHAT THIS
YOUTH NEEDS. HOW WHAT CAN I
BRING TO BEAR? IS A BIG PIECE OF
OUR WORK OF THE SYSTEM, NOT
SYSTEMS, A SYSTEM OF CARE FOR
YOUTH AND REALLY ENSURING THAT
WE'RE HAVING CONSISTENCY IN THE
TRAUMA, INFORMED OR HEALING,
INFORMED PRINCIPLES AND
PRACTICES THAT WERE TAKING ON SO
WE HAVE, UH, PUT FORWARD A
NUMBER OF DELIVERABLES IN THAT
SPACE TO IDENTIFY STRATEGIES
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE, UH, TO
AGAIN ADDRESS GAPS FOR YOUTH
THAT HAVE GREATER AND HIGHER
NEEDS. IT'S AGAIN MULTI PRONGED
TO SAY WE WANT TO PREVENT MORE
YOUTH FROM HèA FROM WHAT ARE WE
LEARNING ABOUT THE WITH HARRY
NEEDS. WHAT CAN WE DO TO PREVENT
THAT NEED FOR MORE INTENSIVE
SERVICES? WHAT INNOVATIVE MODELS
OF CARE CAN WE CREATE AND JUST
REALLY WANT TO APPRECIATE SOME
OF YOUR OTHER PANELISTS WHO WILL
TALK ABOUT IT FROM A PROVIDER
PERSPECTIVE OF BEING ABLE TO, UM
YOU KNOW, REALLY ADAPT THEIR
SERVICES TO THE NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH, AS OPPOSED TO HAVING A
MODEL THAT THE YOUTH HAS TO FIT
INTO RIGHT. IT'S ABOUT MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE YOUTH, SO A LOT
OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE ON
PILOTING AND INNOVATIVE MODELS
OF CARE. UM, WE'VE DONE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT. THAT'S
CHILD SPECIFIC, SO COUNTIES CAN
SAY THIS YOUTH IS GOING TAKE
MORE INVESTMENT AND WE'VE PUT
MORE RESOURCES FORWARD TO SAY OK
, HERE'S HERE'S A WAY TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS AND MEET THOSE NEEDS
AND WE'VE ALSO INVESTED. AND A
AND LOOKING AT THAT CONTINUUM
AGAIN. SO EACH COUNTY, RIGHT? UH
UH, HAS ITS OWN LANDSCAPE AND
SET OF SERVICES. HOW ARE WE
AGAIN LOOKING AT THAT
HOLISTICALLY SO THAT AGAIN
WHOMEVER SHOWS UP TODAY, THERE'S
A PLACE IN A WAY IN WHICH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED ARE
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. THAT'S ANOTHER
INVESTMENT THAT WE PUT TOGETHER
A LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO LOOK AT THAT. SO WE DO HAVE
THINGS BOTH OPERATIONALIZED AND
THINGS THAT ARE LIKE THE PILOTS
THAT ARE STILL STANDING UP. BUT
AGAIN, I THINK TO YOUR POINT. WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE INTENTIONAL
AND FOCUSED ON THIS POPULATION.
NÓ MATTER WHAT THE INVESTMENT
IS, BECAUSE AGAIN, UH, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT FAMILIES AND
YOUTH DON'T COME IN THE SILOS
THAT WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT
FOCUS, AND ESPECIALLY FOR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE. I DO A FOLLOW UP
MANAGER? YES. FOLLOW UP QUESTION
. HOW CAN THAT BE INCORPORATED
IN THE I Dð Dð POPULATION. SO
THEY SO THEY THEY ARE SO WE HAVE
A FEW THINGS. UM, THERE WE HAVE,
UM, OUR MOST RECENT REPORT,
WHICH I'M AGAIN GLAD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS A
COPY OF ACTUALLY LOOKS AT, UM
THIS DATA LOOKS AT HèA, UM,
YOUTH WHO ARE PART OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM BUT ALSO PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM,
AND THEY HAVE A COUR ISSUES AND
THEN SO HOW ARE THEY GETTING
THEIR THEIR THE CONCERNS AND
THOUGHTS ABOUT THE NEEDS THAT
THEY HAVE AND LOOKING AT
PLACEMENT OPTIONS, RIGHT? HOW
ARE WE? POTENTIALLY THINKING
ABOUT THAT POPULATION. WHAT IS
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS MIGHT
HAVE THAT MAYBE IS NOT AVAILABLE
HERE. SO WE HAVE A REPORT. THAT
KIND OF LOOKS AT THE NUMBERS OF
YOUTH THAT HAVE THOSE CO
OCCURRING NEEDS BUT ALSO IN
TERMS OF WHAT I'M REFERENCING
THE SYSTEM OF CARE PARTNERS.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE PARTNERS
SITTING AT THE TABLE, UH, TO
AGAIN BRING RESOURCES TO BEAR.
WHERE WHERE NEEDED, AND, UM I
THINK THERE'S MORE WORK WE WANT
TO DO THERE. ALSO IN LOOKING AT
BLENDING AND BRAIDING FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S NOT AN
OBSTACLE, BUT AGAIN THEY ARE.
THEY ARE PART OF OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CALLS FOR THE YOUTH
THAT HAVE CASE FIGHTING, SO IT'S
AGAIN. IT'S ABOUT HAVING THOSE
PARTNERS AT THE TABLE AND
EVERYONE BRINGING THEIR SUPPORTS
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE YOUTH
IN FRONT OF THEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO WRAP
UP. UM WITH SOME LOOKING
FORWARD, UH, QUESTIONS FOR
THOUGHT, UM, BEEN A. BEING A
OUTCOME OF OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. I THINK IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US NOT ONLY TO THE
CONTINUE OF CARE, BUT ALSO TO
SEE THE IMPACT OF THE SERVICES
AS OUR YOUNG PEOPLE GROW INTO
ADULTS. UM I'M ALSO CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW WE ARE MEASURING AND
TRACKING SUICIDE RATES. UM I
KNOW THAT WE'RE TRACKING
INCARCERATION AND LOOKING AT THE
DISPARITIES THERE AS WELL. BUT I
WANT TO SEE THOSE STORIES. THOSE
OUTCOMES OF THE INVESTMENT THAT
WE'RE MAKING IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IN OUR YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
AND HOW IS THAT IMPACTING OVER
THE LONG TERM, UM OF THE
FAMILY'S LIFE. SO UM, THAT'S THE
DATA UM, AND ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP SUPPORT THAT
CONTINUUM OF STUDY OF DATA SETS
TO HELP, UH, UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PROGRAMS. SO
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
UH, WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE REPORT. UM AND, UM I KNOW
THAT MY COLLEAGUE, OUR, UH,
CHAIR OF OUR, UH. THREE IS ALSO
LOOKING AT WAYS OF HOW WE ARE
GOING TO ADDRESS THIS BUDGET
DEFICIT THIS YEAR. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OK, UM, NEXT, I'D
LIKE TO CALL OUR SECOND PANEL UP
, UH, WILL BE LOOKING AT ISSUES
OF CONCERN AND PROMISING
PRACTICES. AND I UNDERSTAND, UM
LAUREN MENDEZ, A CHILD AND
FAMILY POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA, OUR YOUTH ENGAGEMENT
PROJECT LEADER AND WE DO HAVE A
TIME CRUNCH. SO I WANNA MAKE
SURE I'M SORRY. OH, I'M SORRY.
UH JENNIFER RODRIGUEZ, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF YOUTH LAW CENTER. WE
HAVE A TIME CRUNCH, SO I'M GOING
TO INVITE YOU TO PRESENT FIRST,
AND WE'LL ADDRESS QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE GO INTO OUR OTHER
SPEAKERS. OK? THANK YOU SO MUCH.
UM, GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. UH, MY NAME IS JENNIFER
RODRIGUEZ. AND I'M, THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE YOUTH
LAW CENTER. WE ARE A NATIONAL
LEGAL ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
WE'RE BASED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE A MISSION OF
PROTECTING AND ADVANCING THE
CIVIL RIGHTS OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE SO THAT
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THRIVE AND TO HAVE THE LIVES
THAT THEY DESERVE. UM IN
ADDITION TO SYSTEM CHANGE
ADVOCACY, USING LITIGATION,
POLICY REFORM AND MOVEMENT
LAWYERING TO SUPPORT YOU.
ADVOCATES WE ALSO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH èC, Dð, S¼,
S¼ AND èC W Dð A AS PART OF OUR
QUALITY PARENTING INITIATIVE. WE
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THOSE
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE LEADERSHIP
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS IN THOSE COUNTIES
WHO ARE RESOURCE PARENTS, BIRTH
PARENTS, YOUTH AND THE LINE
STAFF, WHO ARE WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH THOSE FAMILIES AND YOUTH IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY AND TO MAKE
THE CHANGES NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
THE GOAL OF REALIGNING FOSTER
CARE TOWARDS THE MOST IMPORTANT
GOAL. IS THAT EVERY CHILD AND
YOUTH LIVES IN A FAMILY AND
RECEIVES EXCELLENT PARENTING AND
CHANGING LOCAL POLICY AND
PRACTICE TO MEET THAT GOAL. UM,
I'LL SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT SHORTLY AND YOU'LL
HEAR FROM TWO OF THE AMAZING
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE LEADERS WHO
WE DO THIS WORK WITH SHORTLY. UM
BUT I'LL SAY NOW THAT I BEGAN MY
ADVOCACY AS A YOUTH MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
MANY MANY YEARS AGO AFTER
SPENDING MY OWN CHILDHOOD IN
FOSTER CARE INSTITUTIONS AND
BEING DUMPED ON THE STREETS AT
18 WITHOUT A FAMILY WITHOUT A
HOME. OR WITHOUT ANY WAY TO
SUPPORT MYSELF, AND I'VE NOW
BEEN A LAWYER AT THE YOUTH LAW
CENTER FOR THE PAST 16 YEARS,
AND WITH ALL OF THOSE
EXPERIENCES COMBINED, I CAN SAY
THAT I SEE THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING TOGETHER WITH THE COUNTIES
AND THE STATE AND THE QUALITY
PARENTING INITIATIVE AS THE
ABSOLUTE MOST IMPORTANT PRIORITY
IF WE EVER WANT TO REALIZE THE
GOAL OF A FAMILY BASED FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THAT CAN HEAL RATHER
THAN HARM, UM, IF IN THE EVENT
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO SEPARATE A
CHILD FROM THEIR NATURAL FAMILY
AND EVERY SINGLE THING WE DO
FROM THE TIME A CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY FIRST TOUCHES A CHILD OR
YOUTH IN THEIR FAMILY TO THE
MOMENT THAT THEY'RE LEAVING
FOSTER CARE CAN EITHER PROTECT
AND NURTURE AND EXPAND, UM,
THEIR STRENGTH AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS OR IT CAN FRAGMENT
AND DESTROY THOSE RELATIONSHIPS.
AND WHEN WE FRAGMENT AND DESTROY
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS, THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR YOUTH FOR
FAMILIES, UM, WHO LOVE THEM AND
WHO TRY TO CARE FOR THEM, AND
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
ENORMOUS. YOU NEED ONLY TALK.
ANY YOUNG PERSON WHO HAS BEEN
LABELED AS HAVING NEEDS THAT ARE
TOO COMPLEX FOR FOSTER CARE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MEET OR TO THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING,
HOW TO FIGURE OUT PLANS TO CARE
FOR THOSE YOUTH AND YOU'LL HEAR
STORIES OF DOZENS, SOMETIMES
HUNDREDS, UNFORTUNATELY OF
DISRUPTED RELATIONSHIPS,
RELATIONSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISRUPTED WITH THEIR FAMILIES
WITH THEIR SIBLINGS WITH
TEACHERS WITH FRIENDS WITH
NEIGHBORS, THEIR COMMUNITY. UM
CHILDREN NEED RELATIONSHIPS TO
SURVIVE. THEY'RE LIKE OR FOOD OR
WATER FOR THEIR SURVIVAL AND WE
THROUGH MANY OF OUR ACCEPTED
CHILD WELFARE PRACTICES,
DISREGARD AND SEVER THOSE
RELATIONS CASUALLY AS IF THEY
DON'T MATTER. WE FAIL TO DO THE
WORK TO FIND RELATIVES AND
SUPPORT THEM FULLY SO THAT THEY
CAN CARE FOR THEIR KIN. WE KEEP
BIRTH AND RESOURCE PARENTS
APART, PREVENTING THEIR ABILITY
TO LOVE AND CO PARENT YOUTH. AT
THE SAME TIME, WE FAIL TO
SUPPORT RESOURCE FAMILIES TO
KEEP SIBLINGS TOGETHER OR TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAINTAIN
SIBLINGS. RELATIONSHIPS. WE
DON'T SUPPORT YOUTH AND FAMILIES
TO DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS THROUGH
THE BEHAVIORAL, HEALTH AND
INFANT AND D¯ÚI MENTAL HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE KNOW WORK.
WE BRUTALLY DISRUPT YOUTH
RELATIONSHIPS WITH RESOURCE
FAMILIES, SIBLINGS IN THE HOME,
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY WHEN WE
ABRUPTLY MOVE THEM WITHOUT A
PLANNED STRUCTURE TO MAINTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS EVEN WHEN THAT
MOVE IS GOOD, AND THEY'RE GOING
TO FAMILY OR THEY'RE REUNIFYING.
WE DON'T PRIORITIZE, MAKING SURE
THERE IS A FAMILY INVOLVED WHEN
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
IS NEEDED. WE FREQUENTLY MAKE
THAT TREATMENT ENTIRELY. INF FOR
YOUTH BY FAILING TO DO THAT, UM,
I COULD GO ON AND ON WITH A
MILLION EXAMPLES, AND THESE ARE
ONLY THE COMMON EXAMPLES OF
PRACTICES WE SEE FOR YOUTH AND
CHILDREN WHO ARE ALREADY IN
FOSTER CARE. UM I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR ON THE LATER PANEL
ABOUT HOW THIS IMPACTS CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES WHO HAVE COME TO
THE SYSTEM'S ATTENTION BECAUSE
THEY'RE STRUGGLING, BUT WE'RE A
REMOVAL HAS NOT YET HAPPENED. UM
WE HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO DO IN
THIS AREA. UM BUT LUCKILY, THERE
ARE WONDERFUL CHILD WELFARE
LEADERS IN COUNTIES LIKE SANYA
AND DAVID. WHO HAVE COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT HARD WORK WITH US
THROUGH THE QUALITY PARENTING
INITIATIVE AND WHO GIVE ME HOPE
THAT CHILDREN WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE THAN WHAT I
HAD AND WILL NOT FEEL ALONE IN
THE WORLD OR LACK THE FAMILY AND
SUPPORT SYSTEM TO RAISE THEIR
OWN CHILDREN AS I DID, UM, AND
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE SUICIDE
RATE WITH YOUNG PEOPLE IS RIGHT
ON AND WHERE THAT IS DRIVEN FROM
IS FROM YOUNG PEOPLE FEELING
LIKE NOBODY CARES WHETHER
THEY'RE ALIVE OR DEAD IN THE
WORLD. AND I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GRACE TODAY AND
ACCOMMODATING MY RIDICULOUS
SCHEDULE AND THE FACT THAT I TO
JUMP IN AND JUMP OUT TO TESTIFY.
THIS HEARING CONFLICTS WITH A
CONVENING THAT WE'RE HOSTING
JUST DOWN THE STREET AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT ON A NEW
REPORT THAT WE SPENT THE LAST
TWO YEARS WORKING WITH WITH
HUNDREDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FOSTER CARE AND FUTURISTS FROM
THE INSTITUTE FOR THE FUTURE,
FOCUS ON HOW TO REALLY REIMAGINE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE THE CARE
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
BETWEEN 18 AND 21 YEARS OF AGE
TO PREPARE THEM FOR A DECADE
THAT IS COMING THAT IS LIKELY TO
BE MARKED BY FORCE. WE NEVER
COULD HAVE IMAGINED WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE FIRST CREATED THE
OPTION TO USE FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDS TO EXTEND FOSTER CARE TO
THE AGE OF 21 AT THAT TIME, 2010
THE CONCEPTS THAT YOUTH LIVES
WOULD BE IMPACTED BY A REGULAR
NEED TO RELOCATE, UM DUE TO
CLIMATE DISASTERS, FIRES FLOODS
BY THE PANDEMIC BY AN EXTREMELY
VOLATILE ECONOMIC SITUATION BY A
LACK OF HOUSING BY THE PROSPECT
OF HAVING AN ALGORITHM FOR YOUR
FIRST BOSS OR WORKING VIRTUALLY
SO YOU ONLY KNOW YOUR COWORKERS
AS ZOOM SQUARES. UM YOU KNOW, OR
WHAT? WHAT JOBS ARE EVEN
AVAILABLE AS FIRST JOBS. THOSE
THINGS WERE ALL UNIMAGINABLE IN
2010. BUT YET HERE WE ARE, UM,
OUR REPORT IS THE FIRST STEP IN
IMAGINING THE EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE THAT WE NEED TO CREATE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR YOUTH CAN BOTH
SURVIVE AND THRIVE OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. I HOPE THAT YOU'LL READ
THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY AND
REPORT. I BROUGHT SOME OF THOSE
FOR YOU GUYS HERE TODAY. UM BUT
I WANT TO JUST, UH, LEAVE YOU
WITH THIS HIGHLIGHT. UM IN THIS
IN THIS PROCESS, WHICH WE SPENT
ALMOST TWO YEARS ON WHEN YOUTH
WERE ASKED, UM, WHAT WAS NEEDED
TO THRIVE IN THIS NEW WORLD. WE
ARE IN ONE OF THEIR NUMBER. ONE
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS THAT BY 2035
RELATIONAL PERMANENCY OR THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEY HAVE
THAT ARE LIFELONG AND ENDURING
WOULD BE THE MOST IMPORTANT GOAL
OF EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND THAT
ALL OF OUR EFFORTS WOULD SHIFT
FROM PREPARING YOU FOR
INDEPENDENCE AND INSTEAD CREATE
N. FAMILY TIES AND DEEP SOCIAL
CONNECTIONS THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE A LIFE OF HEALTHY
INTERDEPENDENCE. THAT IS REALLY
GOING TO BE THE ONLY WAY THAT
YOUTH CAN WEATHER THIS NEW
FUTURE. THAT WORK TO PRIORITIZE
RELATIONSHIPS. IT ACTUALLY CAN'T
START AT 18 OR 19 OR 20. WHILE
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE IN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE. IT HAS TO START THE
MOMENT A CHILD OR YOUTH COMES TO
OUR ATTENTION. WHETHER THAT
CHILD IS A DAY OLD OR 17 YEARS
OLD. UM, AS I SAID EARLIER. IT'S
THE HARDEST, BUT IT'S THE
ABSOLUTE MOST IMPORTANT WORK
THAT WE CAN DO AS A CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. DO YOU HAVE TIME
FOR A FEW MORE QUESTIONS? YES, I
DO. OK I DO HAVE THE EXECUTIVE
SUMMARY IN FRONT OF ME AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE THRESHOLD
OF CHANGE IS THE REPORT THAT
YOU'RE CELEBRATING TODAY? AND I
JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU AS
YOU LAUNCH THAT TODAY TO MAKE
THAT AVAILABLE NOT ONLY TO THIS
COMMITTEE BUT TO OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE GOING TO BE MAKING SOME
TOUGH DECISIONS AROUND THE
BUDGET DEFICIT THIS YEAR, THE
SIMPLICITY AROUND PRIORITIZING
RELATIONSHIPS IS SUCH A
FASCINATING THEORY. UH, UM AND
YET YOU KNOW, WE ARE IN THE
SOCIAL DIGITAL AGE WHERE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE ARTIFICIAL
THROUGH. UM YOU KNOW, UH,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR
SOCIAL MEDIA THROUGH CREATING,
UM, PERSONAS ONLINE, SO I WORRY
ABOUT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. AND I
WORRY ABOUT THE DIRECTION THAT
WE'RE HEADED. UM BOTH IN AS I
SEE THE RATES OF SUICIDE
INCREASE, AS I SEE THE COST OF
HOUSING AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECOME MORE
AND MORE UNATTAINABLE. AND TO
USE YOUR WORD. WE'RE IN A STATE
WHERE WE ARE IN AN UNIMAGINABLE,
UH, STATE OF AFFAIRS. UM AND SO
I ALWAYS LOOK AT HOW ARE WE
DOING WITH OUR CHILDREN? HOW ARE
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THRIVING. UM
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE THIS COMMITTEE HAS REALLY
TAKEN A STRONG HOLD IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE POLICY DECISIONS THAT
WE ARE MAKING ARE HELPING TO
SERVE THE FUTURE OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN A WAY THAT IS
PREVENTATIVE BUT ALSO INTERVENE
FOR WHAT WE SEE IS COMING DOWN.
THE PIPELINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING A LEADER IN THAT, UM,
ONE QUESTION I DID HAVE FOR YOU
IS, UM, WHAT IS, UH, OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU'VE LEARNED OF
THE REPORT? UM, AND CERTAINLY
WHAT YOU'VE POINTED OUT IN THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY. WHAT IS THAT?
WHAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT YOU NEED FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA FAMILY BASED SYSTEMS
ARE THRIVING AT THIS TIME? YEAH
ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN, I'LL SPEAK
BOTH FROM WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
FROM THE REPORT, BUT ALSO WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED WORKING IN FRESNO
AND VENTURA COUNTY AND OTHER
COUNTIES WITH THE QUALITY
PARENTING INITIATIVE, AND I
THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS, UM
ANY POLICY PROPOSAL OR BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT COMES BEFORE YOU
THINKING ABOUT HOW THAT PROPOSAL
EITHER STRENGTHENS OR SUPPORTS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH RELATIONSHIPS
OR IF IT INTERFERES, YOU KNOW
WHETHER THERE'S AN ALTERNATE
SOLUTION THAT CAN GET YOU TO THE
SAME GOAL. UM, AS I SAID, IT'S
PEOPLE OFTEN WANT TO KNOW
THROUGH OUR QP. I WORK LIKE WHAT
ARE THE FIVE MAGIC THINGS THAT A
SYSTEM CAN DO? AND I THINK THAT
SONIA AND DAVID CAN BOTH TELL
YOU IT'S ACTUALLY, EVERY SINGLE
THING THAT YOU DO IN YOUR SYSTEM
, AND SO IT'S A LENS THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE ON. UM AND SO IF
THEY'RE DURING THIS NEXT CYCLE,
AND I THINK IT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT WHEN SYSTEMS ARE IN
CRISIS, AND WHEN TIMES GET TOUGH
, IT'S EASY TO LET GO OF YOUR
NORTH STAR AND START REVERTING
TO CRISIS MODE AND KIND OF
TRYING TO KEEP THE MINIMUM
REGULATIONS. BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT TIME THAT WE
HAVE TO REALLY FOCUS ON. AS YOU
SAID, WHAT MATTERS MOST TO YOUNG
PEOPLE, WHICH IS WHO LOVES THEM
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S NOT
EVEN WHO TO CARE FOR THEM. BUT
WHO LOVES THEM? WHO ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
HAVE AT THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION THERE IN THE DELIVERY
ROOM WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR FIRST
CHILD, WALK THEM DOWN THE AISLE
WHEN THEY GET MARRIED. WHEN OUR
YOUNG PERSON FEELS LIKE THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS, I DON'T KNOW.
AS I SAID, THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
DISASTROUS, AND OUR SYSTEMS ARE
ALREADY UNDER SO MUCH STRAIN.
THAT'S JUST AN AREA THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO RECOVER FROM.
UM AND THEN I WOULD ALSO SAY,
REALLY LISTEN TO THE COUNTY, THE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE FAMILIES
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING ON BOTH
IDENTIFYING SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS DEVELOPING SOLUTIONS,
UM TO THOSE BARRIERS AND THEN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESOURCE AND
SCALE. UM SOME OF THOSE
SOLUTIONS OUT I. I WOULD SAY
THAT MUCH OF OUR WORK IN THE
QUALITY PARENTING INITIATIVE IS
LIKE, NOT US COMING IN WITH
SOLUTIONS. IN FACT, I THINK NONE
OF IT REALLY IS. IT'S GOING INTO
THE COUNTER AND LISTENING TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THE WORK
OR WHO ARE LIVING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT WORK AND
SAYING, WHAT IDEAS DO YOU HAVE
ON HOW TO FIX THIS? AND THEN
BETA TESTING IT IN THE COUNTY
AND NOW COUNTIES HAVE SOME VERY
CLEAR IDEAS AROUND THE THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY WORK TOWARDS
GETTING US TO A FAMILY BASED
SYSTEM AND I CAN GIVE YOU UM,
I'LL I'LL SAY LOTS OF THEM DO IN
FACT WORK. UM AND I CAN GIVE YOU
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES. YEARS AGO,
FAMILIES AND YOUTH IDENTIFIED
THAT EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
WERE ACTUALLY UM, ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT SUPPORTS THAT
WE'RE MISSING TO HELP YOUTH AND
FAMILIES. IT WAS SORT OF THE YOU
KNOW, SCHOOL AGED AND ADOLESCENT
EQUIVALENT OF CHILD CARE FOR
FAMILIES, AND IT GAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE A HEALTHY OUTLET TO DEAL
WITH ALL OF THE TRAUMA AND LOSS
THAT THEY HAD EXPERIENCED, UM
AND PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
UNSTRUCTURED LIKE OUT OF SCHOOL
AFTER SCHOOL SUMMERTIME, BUT
THEY'RE SO EXPENSIVE AND SO
COMPLICATED FOR OUR FAMILIES,
PARTICULARLY KIN TO RESOURCE. UM
SO COUNTIES AND I KNOW, UM
FRESNO COUNTY HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE DONE THAT
WHO HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIPS AND
FUND THOSE KIND OF
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES. THEY
CAN TELL YOU THEY WORK. UM, BUT
WE HAVE YET TO SEE DEDICATED
DOLLARS GOING TO FUNDING THOSE,
UM, YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE COUNTIES
LIKE VENTURA COUNTY, UM,
RESOURCE TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE
AND SUPPORTING EXPERIENCE. PEER
MENTORS IN THEIR COUNTY WHO ARE
DEPLOYED WHEN THERE IS A PROBLEM
THAT IS GOING ON BETWEEN A
FAMILY AND A YOUTH. UM THOSE
PEER MENTORS THAT THE COUNTY ON
THEIR OWN RESOURCED AND SORT OF
BUILT UP, THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN STABILIZING ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE SITUATION, AND I THINK SO
SUCCESSFUL THAT SOME OF THOSE
PEER MENTORS ACTUALLY WENT. THE
BUSINESS OF MATCHMAKING BETWEEN
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE IN
INSTITUTIONAL CARE AND FAMILIES,
RESOURCE FAMILIES IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
CARE FOR THEM. UM SO YOU KNOW,
AND I THINK A LOT OF THE WORK
WITH QP. I HAS BEEN FIGURING OUT
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY LISTEN TO
FAMILIES AND ALL OF THE FAMILIES
AND ALL OF THE YOUTH BECAUSE WE
OFTEN GET A PANEL OR AN ADVISORY
GROUP OR A COUPLE OF FAMILIES,
BUT BOTH VENTURA AND FRESNO HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH US AND
SOMETHING THAT WE CALL QUALITY
PARENTING OUTREACH WHERE WE'VE
BEEN UTILIZING. TEXTING TO
SURVEY EVERY SINGLE FAMILY IN
THAT COUNTY'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM TO SAY, WHAT DO YOU NEED?
UM OUR POLICIES BEING
IMPLEMENTED AND AN AGGREGATE
LEVEL THAT'S HELPING LEADERS
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE TO
PUT THEIR TIME AND RESOURCES AND
AT AN INDIVIDUAL LEVEL, UM, THAT
FOLLOW UP BACK TO FAMILIES TO
SAY LIKE I'LL GET YOU WHAT YOU
NEED, I THINK HAS BEEN CRITICAL
IN HELPING FAMILIES FEEL LIKE
ACTUALLY COUNTIES ARE HERE FOR
THEM, AND IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING WHEN STAFF
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED AND YOU
KNOW MANY COUNTIES HAVE
VACANCIES AND, YOU KNOW, HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO REALLY HIRE, UM
OR GET SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
WHO ARE EXPERIENCED TO SORT OF
HAVE THE FAMILIES TELLING YOU.
HERE'S WHAT I NEED FOR YOU TO BE
HELPING ME. MOUNTAIN CAN I ASK
BEFORE YOU LEAVE? IF I MAY, UM,
ANY AND I WOULD LOVE TO ASK YOU
THIS AFTER BUT YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON, UM, FEEDBACK ON FAMILY,
FAMILY KINSHIP, FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENTS AND SO FORTH AND THE
BARRIERS THAT FAMILIES ARE STILL
EXPERIENCING ANYTHING ON THAT. I
THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
BARRIERS. UM AND YOU KNOW, THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE BARRIERS ARE
PRACTICE BARRIERS, BUT IT IS IT
IS AN EASY CONCEPT TO DO FAMILY
FINDING TO REALLY WORK CLOSELY
WITH KEN, BUT IT IS HARD IN
PRACTICE. I THINK MOST OF THE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL HAVE NEEDED TO
UTILIZE OUTSIDE STAFFING TO
REALLY BUILD UP THEIR FAMILY
FINDING AND ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS.
INITIALLY YOU KNOW, SOME
COUNTIES HAVE BROUGHT BACK
RETIRED ANNUITANTS, LIKE OTHER
COUNTIES HAVE ACTUALLY USED
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS TO DO THAT
VERY INTENSIVE, VERY, UM,
DETAILED WORK WITH FAMILIES. BUT
THEN ALL THE WAY ALONG. THESE
ARE FAMILIES WHO DIDN'T PLAN UM
TO AND YOU KNOW THEIR LIFE
CARING FOR CHILDREN, AND SO THEY
NEED ALL EVERY SUPPORT UNDER THE
SUN, SO THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED, UM THINGS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT THAN THE ARRAY OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT YOU
HEAR ALL RESOURCE PARENTS NEED,
BUT THEY NEED THEM MORE
INTENSIVELY AND MORE IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ON A
JOURNEY OF PLANNING FOR THIS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR LIFE
SITUATED. SO THERE ARE
DEFINITELY WHEN YOU LOOK AT SORT
OF FIRST RATE OF PLACEMENT WITH
KIN ACROSS THE STATE. YOU CAN
SEE HUGE DISPARITIES IN NUMBER.
SOME COUNTIES HAVE THE MAJORITY
OF CHILDREN WHO ARE FIRST PLACE
WITH KEN. OTHERS HAVE A VERY
SMALL NUMBER IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW, UH, MADAM CHAIR MENTIONED.
YOU KNOW THE NEW REALITY WE LIVE
IN WHERE LIFE IS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. LIKE MANY OF PARTICULAR
OUR GRANDPARENTS WHO ARE CARING
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE, THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS AND SO THEY NEED
A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM FROM THE
AGENCY FROM STAFF AND SORT OF
NAVIGATING EVERYTHING THAT IS
INVOLVED WITH PARENTING. UM, A
CHILD OR A YOUTH AT THIS TIME.
WHERE THE WORLD IS SO DIFFERENT,
SO WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO ON
THIS, BUT WE HAVE THE BLUEPRINT
FOR ACTUALLY HOW TO DO IT AND
HOW TO DO IT WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UM AGAIN.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR EVENT
TODAY. UM WE ARE GONNA BE MOVING
TO OUR OUR ZOOM. UM WITNESS. MS
LAUREN MENDES IS ONE OF OUR
LIVED EXPERTS WHO IS COMING FROM
THE CHILD AND FAMILY POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA. UH AND
WE AND AS PART OF THE YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT PROJECT, SO LAURA AND
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ARE ONLINE AND READY. YES, I
AM GREAT. WELL, WELCOME. OK?
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME SO MY NAME IS LAUREN MENDEZ.
AND I'M A PART OF UM THE CHILD
AND FAMILY POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT PROJECT. UM I'VE BEEN
A PART OF THIS ORGANIZATION FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND FOSTER
CARE FOR, UM, OVER 10 YEARS I
WAS IN FOSTER CARE FROM AGE 15
UNTIL I AGED OUT AT 21 I. I
UNFORTUNATELY WAS NOT ABLE TO BE
PLACED WITH FAMILY AND KIN CARE
WHILE I WAS IN FOSTER CARE AS A
MINOR. I SPENT MAJORITY OF MY
TIME IN FOSTER CARE IN
CONGREGATE CARE SO POEMS THREE
TO BE EXACT, AND I WAS IN FIVE
DIFFERENT FOSTER HOMES. WHEN I
WENT INTO FOSTER CARE, MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS AND EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS RECEIVED A LETTER
LETTING THEM KNOW THAT I WAS IN
FOSTER CARE WITH THE HOPES OF
SOMEONE COMING FORWARD TO TAKE
PLACEMENT OF ME. SENDING A
LETTER TO FAMILY MEMBERS IS A
BOX CHECKED BY THE COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM DUE TO NÓ FOLLOW
UP TO MY FAMILY MEMBERS. AFTER
RECEIVING THIS LETTER, NÓ ONE
CAME FORWARD TO TAKE PLACEMENT
OF ME. THE LETTER SENT OUT ONLY
CREATED CONFUSION AND THEY DID
NOT UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WERE
RECEIVING THIS LETTER. IF MY
FAMILY MEMBERS WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
A PHONE CALL FROM THE COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM, EXPLAINING
WHAT WAS NEEDED AND WHAT
SUPPORTS THE COUNTY COULD OFFER
THEM WITH THIS TRANSITION. UM I
WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN BOUNCED
AROUND, UM, IN A VICTIM OF THE
CHILD, WEL SYSTEM. I WAS ABLE TO
MOVE IN WITH MY GRANDPARENTS
AFTER I TURNED 18 DURING MY TIME
IN A B 12 EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
WHILE I AWAITED A TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLACEMENT. THE SUPPORT I
RECEIVED FROM MY GRANDPARENTS
WAS ASTRONOMICAL. THEY HELPED ME
GET MY DRIVER'S LICENSE AND A
CAR SO THAT I COULD GET MYSELF
TO AND FROM SCHOOL. MY
GRANDFATHER SUPPORTED ME AND
FURTHERING MY EDUCATION BY GOING
TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
HE TOOK ME TO THE CAMPUS TO MAKE
SURE I WAS PREPARED FOR MY FIRST
DAY OF CLASSES. DURING THE TIME
I STAYED WITH MY GRANDPARENTS. I
WAS ABLE TO HAVE FAMILY CENTERED
MEALS AT DINNER TIME, WHICH I
WAS NOT ABLE TO GET BEING IN
GROUP HOMES. MY MENTAL HEALTH
WAS THRIVING BECAUSE I FELT
LOVED AND SUPPORTED WHERE I WAS
LIVING AT BEING ABLE TO STAY
WITH MY GRANDPARENTS. I FELT
CLOSER TO MY FAMILY TO WHO I WAS
BEFORE I WAS PUT INTO FOSTER
CARE. BACK TO SOME OF MY
PREVIOUS STATEMENTS I MADE ABOUT
WHAT WOULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF BEING
PLACED WITH FAMILY COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE REACHING OUT TO FAMILY
MEMBERS VIA PHONE OR IN PERSON.
IF I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
PLACED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS, IT
WOULD HAVE PRESERVED MY MENTAL
HEALTH IN TERMS OF TRAUMA NOT
BEING PLACED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
ALLOWED FOR MORE TRAUMA. UM. I
WAS ACTUALLY EXPLOITED IN
TRAFFICKED IN A GROUP HOME. UM
THE FEELINGS OF BEING UNWANTED,
UNLOVED AND JUST ANOTHER
PAYCHECK FOR A BUSINESS. IF I
WOULD HAVE BEEN PLACED BEEN ABLE
TO BE PLACED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
. I WOULD HAVE HAD THE SUPPORT
NEEDED TO STAY IN MY SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN INSTEAD OF GOING TO FIVE
DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOLS IN THREE
YEARS. IF I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO BE PLACED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
, I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PRESERVE MY FAMILY CULTURE INTO
TRADITIONS AND NOT EAT
THANKSGIVING DINNER IN THE
GARAGE ON THE FLOOR WITH WITH
TOTES AS TABLES IF I WOULD HAVE
BEEN PLACED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS,
MY RELATIONSHIPS WITH MY FAMILY
WOULD HAVE BEEN MAINTAINED,
INCLUDING MY SIBLINGS. IF I
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
PLACED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS, THE
FOCUS WOULD HAVE BEEN ON ME AND
MY INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND SUPPORTS
SO THAT I COULD THRIVE IN THE
MOST IMPORTANT TIME IN MY LIFE.
UM BE BECAUSE I WAS BECAUSE I
WAS ABLE TO BE PLACED IN MY
GRANDPARENTS AT 18. I'M THE
PERSON WHO I AM TODAY. UM I'M
THE WISE I'M A WIFE, A MOTHER OF
THREE CHILDREN AND A BONUS MOM
WITH TWO CHILDREN, AND I WOULD
HAVE NOT BEEN WHERE I AM TODAY
WITHOUT MY GRANDPARENTS AND
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO BE PLACED,
UM WITH FAMILY MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, LAUREN FOR YOUR
EXTREMELY POWERFUL STORY AND FOR
TRUSTING US WITH YOUR LIFE
JOURNEY TO HELP EDUCATE US ON
WHAT'S GOING WELL AND WHAT WE
CAN DO BETTER. I WANT TO OPEN UP
TO QUESTIONS, SENATOR MENGI BAR.
NÓ. I THINK THAT'S SO GREAT. UM
I, I APPRECIATE YOUR BRAVERY TO
COME AND SHARE YOUR STORY WITH
US. UM, I THINK IT'S A NEEDED
REMINDER FOR WHAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN WE DON'T STEP IN AND TAKE
CARE OF THE CHILDREN THAT ARE
UNDER OUR OUR OUR STATE.
COUNTIES CARE. UM YOU KNOW, I
THINK YOU POINTED OUT SOMETHING
THAT I BROUGHT OUT REGARDING
FOSTER KINSHIP AND I WROTE DOWN
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE
SAME CASE FOR EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY, WHERE THE PRACTICE IS TO
SIMPLY SEND A LETTER THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE LOST IN THE MAIL.
UM I YOU KNOW, I, I JOT IT DOWN
THAT WHAT IS THIS? FOLLOW UP TO
THAT, BUT WE ALL KNOW WE'RE
WORKPLACE ISSUES. I MEAN,
WORKFORCE ISSUES ARE STRONG IN
ALL OUR COUNTY. YOU KNOW, THE
FOLLOW UP IS DIFFICULT THE
SUSTAINABILITY TO CARE AND
FOLLOW EACH CASE. UM THROUGHOUT
THE TRAJECTORY OF THAT CHILD,
UM, IS REALLY DIFFICULT FOR US
TO, UM, ACCOMPLISH I. I DON'T
KNOW. OUTSIDE OF HER HAVING A
200,000 HIRING, UM, APPROACH FOR
COUNTIES HOW ELSE WE CAN
IMPLEMENT SOME KIND OF TOUCH
POINTS TO ENSURE THAT A LOT OF
OUR KIDS DON'T GET LOST HERE. I
DON'T KNOW, MADAM. SURE. IF I
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR NOT, I
THINK IT WAS JUST INFORMATION
THAT I HEARD BEFORE. ALSO JUST A
REMINDER OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO HELP OUT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING FROM TWO OF
OUR COUNTIES AROUND WHAT HAS
BEEN WORKING AND WHAT HAS
CHANGED AS WELL BEING THAT WE
HAVE 58 COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE, UM,
HOW DIFFERENT LIVED EXPERIENCES
ARE IMPACTING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
UM BOTH IN IN STORIES OF
REUNIFICATION, AND ALSO STORIES
THAT WE COULD HAVE DONE BETTER
TO HELP CONNECT THIS YOUTH. UM
ONE THING FOR ME, I. I DO
REPRESENT STANISLAUS COUNTY,
WHICH IS THE COUNTY UM LAUREN,
THAT THAT I SEE I'M FROM AND I
JUST I. I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS
WORKING IN OUR COUNTY, UM,
APPROACH TO, UH TO THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND TO HELPING OUR
YOUTH, UM, IS THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU KNOW, ONE
SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL AND THAT
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE VERY RURAL
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO HAVE URBAN
CENTERS. AND WITH THAT COMES AN
ARRAY OF SOCIAL INDICATORS THAT
WE THAT IMPACT THE WAY THAT WE
MAKE. DECISIONS LAURA, I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR SHARING YOUR STORY WITH
US. UM I ALSO AM AM IT IS NOT
LOST IN ME THAT YOU'RE CONTINUED
TO DO THE GREAT WORK TO IMPACT
OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE. UM, IN, UM
THAT ARE EITHER IN THE SYSTEM OR
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY A FAMILY
MEMBER. SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALSO FOR CONTINUING TO GIVE BACK
IN THAT WAY, AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO ONE DAY MEETING YOU. OK
GREAT. OK WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON,
UM TO MR DAVID SWANSON,
HOLLINGER, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES, HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY AND VENTURA
COUNTY. UM AND M. UH, SANJA BGA.
IS THAT CORRECT? SANDRA B,
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FROM NÓ COUNTY. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR MENDAR
, AND IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH TO
FOLLOW BOTH OF THOSE SPEAKERS.
BUT I'M GOING TO TRY AND I'M
REALLY HERE TO BUILD ON ON WHAT
WAS INTRODUCED BY BOTH SPEAKERS
ABOUT THE VALUE OF FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT OF DEVELOPING A
CULTURE AND A LENS OF KIN. AND
AS AS JENNIFER INDICATED, WE ARE
A PROUD QP I COUNTY AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE MANY PIECES THAT THAT
HAS HELPED US TO SHIFT AND WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF SHIFTING
OUR L. TO AKIN CULTURE IN
VENTURA IN OUR COUNTY. WE'VE GOT
ABOUT 700 CHILDREN WITH OPEN
CASES CURRENTLY IN ABOUT 500 OF
THOSE ARE IN OUT OF HOME CARE.
THE REST ARE LIVING WITH THEIR
FAMILY OF ORIGIN, AND WE'VE SEEN
MANY COUNTIES A REDUCTION ABOUT
A 30% REDUCTION IN OVERALL CASE
LOAD OF CHILDREN COMING IN IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS, AND LIKE
MANY JURISDICTIONS AS IT WAS
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER, WE DO HAVE
CHALLENGES WITH
DISPROPORTIONALITY AND
DISPARITIES IN OUR COUNTY. IT IS
A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
LATINO FAMILIES COMING IN
PRIMARILY FAMILIES WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN. COMING IN FROM A
CERTAIN GEOGRAPHIC AREA IN THE
OXNARD COMMUNITY IN IN OUR
COUNTY, AND WE'RE DOING SOME
TARGETED WORK TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
DISPARITIES TO REDUCE THOSE
TRENDS. AS I INDICATED. WE IN
OUR COUNTY HAVE EMBRACED AN
OVERALL CULTURE THAT FOCUSES ON
THE VALUE AND THE VOICES OF
THOSE WE SERVED AND INVITING,
INVITING IN THOSE NATURAL
SUPPORTS OF PARENTS, CHILDREN
AND THEIR YOUTH. SO FOR US KIN
CULTURE IS NOT JUST ABOUT
PLACEMENT AND KIN DOES NOT JUST
MEAN RELATIVES. IT'S THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IMPORTANT
IN THE LIVES OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. WE SERVE AS WE HAVE
HEARD EARLIER, AND IT'S THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WILL BE THERE ONCE
WE'RE GONE OUT OF OUT OF THESE
FAMILIES LIVES. ENGAGEMENT OF
CHILDREN. YOUTH PARENTS. THEIR
NATURAL SUPPORTS HAS BEEN
FOUNDATIONAL TO OUR PRACTICE,
AND WE'VE DONE A BROAD ARRAY OF
TRAINING TO HELP SHIFT THAT LENS
AND THAT PRACTICE MODEL BRINGING
IN IN NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
EXPERTS IN THIS WORK OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS, AND IT HAS
BEEN A CORE PART OF OUR WORK
AROUND DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. IT PUTS POWER SHARING
WITH FAMILIES AT THE CENTER OF
OUR WORK, AND IT'S ABOUT
HONORING AND SUPPORTING THAT
CULTURAL RESILIENCY AND STRENGTH
OF FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
WE SERVE, ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
HELPING THEIR CASE PLANS AND
SOLUTIONS THAT WORK BEST FOR
THEM. IT ALSO DRIVES OUTCOMES.
AS WE'VE HEARD, WE KNOW THAT WE
AND I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SOME SPECIFIC DATA, BUT WE KNOW
WE SEE BETTER CHILD WELFARE
OUTCOMES. WE ALSO KNOW THERE'S A
GREAT BODY OF RESEARCH OUT THERE
THAT SHOWS THAT CHILDREN WHO ARE
WITH KIN ARE ABLE TO STAY WITH
KIN OR WITH THEIR PARENTS HAVE
BETTER LIFE OUTCOMES ALONG THAT
TRAJECTORY OF LIFE. THERE'S ALSO
A LINK TO PREVENTION. THIS IS,
AS I SAID, IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
PLACEMENT. WE FOUND THAT IF WE
CAN SUPPORT FAMILIES TO BUILD
THAT NETWORK, THE LARGER NETWORK
OF NATURAL SUPPORTS AROUND
FAMILIES WE CAN OFTEN AVOID
HAVING TO SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM
THEIR PARENTS, AND IT'S BEEN A
KEY PART OF OUR WORK TO REDUCE
THE ENTRIES INTO OUR SYSTEM.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MANDATED REPORTING AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORTING. I'M ALSO VERY
INVOLVED IN THAT AS CO CHAIR OF
THE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION COMMITTEE OF THE
CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL, SO IT'S
AN AREA THAT'S NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART. LIVED EXPERTISE IS
ALSO CRITICAL IN BRINGING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS INTO INTO SERVICES
AS JENNIFER TALKED ABOUT, BUT
ALSO PLANNING AND PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT AS WE MOVE NEW WORK
FORWARD NEW INITIATIVES FORWARD
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
LENS OF THOSE THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED OUR SYSTEM TO HELP
GUIDE THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING,
AND IT CAN'T BE DONE IN
ISOLATION WITHIN CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IS AS DIRECTOR JOHNSON
TALKED ABOUT. IT'S ABOUT
LEVERAGING THOSE CROSSY
OPPORTUNITIES WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
2083 AND MOVE TOWARDS AN
INTEGRATED CHILD YOUTH AND
FAMILY WELLNESS SYSTEM, WHICH
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. COUNTY THAT
FOCUSES ON THE FULL CONTINUUM OF
SUPPORTS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. AND OF COURSE, IT'S
ALSO ABOUT WHEN WE HAVE TO
SEPARATE FAMILIES, ENSURING
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO PLACE THOSE CHILDREN WITH
KIN. QUICK SNAPSHOT. WE ARE A
COUNTY THAT HAS DONE RELATIVELY
WELL IN KINSHIP PLACEMENT. WE
PLACE MORE THAN HALF OUR
CHILDREN WITH KIN AT INITIAL
SEPARATION FROM THEIR PARENTS,
AND WE HAVE WE'VE BEEN TRENDING
IN THE SIX LOW 60% OVERALL FOR
KIN PLACEMENT. WE'RE PROUD OF
THAT, AND WE'RE NOWHERE NEAR
WHERE WE WANNA BE. WE'VE ALSO
SEEN THE IMPACT ON OUTCOMES IN
REUNIFICATION OR ADOPTION.
GUARDIANSHIP THERE'S MULTIPLE
PERMANENCY OUTCOMES THAT WE LOOK
AT. BUT WE TEND WE FIND THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE PLACED WITH KIN
TEND TO DO 20 TO 30% POINTS
BETTER THAN CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT
PLACED WITH KIN IN THEIR
PERMANENCY OUTCOMES. SO IT JUST
IT JUST UNDERSCORES HOW CRITICAL
THAT IS. WE ALSO SEE MUCH HIGHER
PLACEMENT, STABILITY AND LEVELS
OF PLACEMENT WITH ALL SIBLINGS
IN THE SAME HOME WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO PLACE WITH KIN. I KNOW
THAT OUR COUNTY IS NOT UNIQUE IN
IN MEMBERS. SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN,
UH, TAKEN ON IN OUR COUNTY TO
SUPPORT KIN, CULTURE AND KIN
PLACEMENT. WE'VE ADAPTED SOME OF
THE LEARNINGS AND SOME OF THE
GREAT WORK THAT'S HAPPENED IN L,
A COUNTY TO DO SOME WHAT THEY
CALL UPFRONT FAMILY FINDING AND
ENGAGEMENT AND PUT SOME SPECIFIC
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES IN
PLACE. SO IT'S MORE THAN JUST
SENDING A LETTER. IT'S
INTENTIONAL ENGAGEMENT AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF OUR WORK WITH
FAMILIES TO SUPPORT THEM, AND
WE'VE HAD STAFF THAT ARE HAVE
HISTORICALLY WORKED IN
SUPPORTING PARENT CHILD
VISITATION AS WELL AS
IDENTIFYING PLACEMENTS TO TAKE
ON THAT WORK AS PART OF THE
REGULAR DUTIES. THEY'RE ALREADY
IN THERE, WORKING WITH FAMILIES.
WE'RE ALSO WANTING GOING TO BE
BUILDING ON THOSE STRATEGIES
THROUGH THE CREATION OF A
DEDICATED FRONT END FAMILY
FINDING UNIT AND WE'LL BE USING
THE EXCELLENCE IN FAMILY FINDING
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT PROGRAM
FUNDS. THESE OF COURSE, ARE LIKE
THE NUMBER OF FUNDING STREAMS
OUT THERE. THESE ARE TIME
LIMITED AND RIGHT NOW THEY'LL BE
ENDING IN AT THE END OF JUNE IN
2027, SO WE'RE HOPING THESE WILL
BECOME AN ONGOING FUNDING STREAM
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT WORK.
WE'VE ALSO PARTNERED WITH THE
DAVE THOMAS FOUNDATION'S WENDY
WAS WONDERFUL KIDS PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE PART OF A DEDICATED UNIT
OF SOCIAL WORKERS THAT WE HAVE
CALLED THE FAMILY SEARCH AND
ENGAGEMENT. UH, UNIT AND THEY
WORK TO FIND BOTH LEGAL AND
RELATIONAL PERMANENCY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO
RETURN HOME IN THIS ABSOLUTELY
CONTINUING THROUGH OUR WORK WITH
YOUNG ADULTS INTO EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE THAT RELATIONAL
PERMANENCY PIECE IS SO CRITICAL
WE YOU KNOW, I HAVE A TEENAGER
AND TWO CHILDREN AND I WANT THEM
TO BE INDEPENDENT, AND I ALSO
WANT THEM. A PLACE TO COME BACK
TO WHEN THEY'RE STRUGGLING. ALSO
DEVELOPING SOME SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES IN THAT AREA WITH
CASEY FAMILY PROGRAMS. AND THEN
LASTLY, I WANNA TAP IN AND TALK
A BIT ABOUT THOSE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WITH WITH THE MOST
CHALLENGING NEEDS, EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE HAD SOME GREAT SUCCESSES
WITH KI¾M PLACEMENT AND SHIFT IN
OUR CULTURE, AND WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED OUR USE OF
CONGRUENT CARE. WE ALSO ARE
CHALLENGED WITH MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THOSE THAT HAVE HAD
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA IN THEIR
LIVES, AS MANY COUNTIES HAVE,
AND QUITE WELL FOR JURISDICTIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THE COUNTRY
THIS IS A RELATIVELY SMALL
POPULATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE. BUT
THE NEEDS ARE ACUTE AND VERY
EXPENSIVE AND DEFINITELY REQUIRE
ALL SYSTEM PARTNERS OF BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS TO
DEVELOP SOLUTIONS. SUPPORT TO
KIN CAREGIVERS HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR OVERALL
CONTINUUM. VERY OFTEN, IT IS
THOSE KIN CAREGIVERS THAT ARE
MOST WILLING TO WORK WITH AND
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT. THE WELL
BEING, AS LAUREN TALKED ABOUT OF
THOSE YOUTH THAT THAT HAVE
CHALLENGES IF WE PUT THE
SUPPORTS IN PLACE TO SUPPORT
THOSE CAREGIVERS. AND AS PART OF
THAT LARGER CONTINUUM, SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS, INTENSIVE SERVICES,
FOSTER CARE THE INNOVATIVE
MODELS OF CARE WRAP AROUND THOSE
OTHER SUPPORTS THAT WE THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE AND NEED TO BE
ABLE TO WRAP AROUND CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE ESPECIALLY
WHEN CHILDREN ARE IN OUT OF HOME
CARE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO BE
LOCAL, IF AT ALL POSSIBLE SO
THAT THOSE EXTENDED CONNECTIONS
CAN BE MAINTAINED. A COUPLE OF
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
TAPPED AND LEVERAGED WITHIN OUR
COUNTY TO SUPPORT THIS WORK.
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM. IT HAS BEEN A PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN VERY VALUABLE TO US
AND OUR COUNTY. SUPPORTING ALL
PLACEMENTS. CHILDREN IN
PLACEMENT, INCLUDING KIN CARES
AS WELL AS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES.
ONCE CHILDREN HAVE RETURNED HOME
, AND I THINK WHAT STRUCK ME
I'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF STORIES
ABOUT THIS, BUT WHAT STRUCK ME
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE PROPOSED
CUTS WAS WHEN I LEARNED OF A
YOUNG PERSON A TEENAGER IN OUR
SYSTEM WHO SAW IT ON THE NEWS
THAT IT WAS PROPOSED FOR CUT
CALLED UP FOR SOCIAL WORKER AND
WAS DISTRAUGHT. SHE TALKED WITH
HER WORKER ABOUT HOW OFTEN THE
FIRST PROGRAM HAS SUPPORTED HER
TO WORK THROUGH THE CHALLENGES
THAT SHE'S FACED AND HELP GIVE
HER SOME STABILITY IN IN HER
SITUATION. THE FLEXIBLE FAMILY
SUPPORT FUNDS HAVE ALSO HELPED
AND ALLOWED US TO PROMOTE
CREATIVITY AND ENSURING SUPPORT
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
PLACEMENT, PARTICULARLY WITH KIN
. WE'RE USING THESE TO SUPPORT
CAREGIVERS WITH THINGS LIKE
MOVING EXPENSES, HOUSEHOLD
NEEDS, RESPITE CARE AND
CONNECTION TO NATURAL SUPPORTS.
THIS IS UNFORTUNATELY ANOTHER
ONE TIME FUNDING OPPORTUNITY
THAT WILL END AT THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR 2526. AND SO WE'RE
NOT SURE WHAT WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT. THE ONGOING IMPACTS WERE
DEFINITELY WATCHING THE RATES
PROPOSAL THAT WAS DISCUSSED
EARLIER TO SEE WHAT THE IMPACT
THAT WILL HAVE ON THIS AND THE
CHILD SPECIFIC COMPLEX CARE
FUNDS THAT WERE REFERENCED HAVE
ALSO BEEN BENEFICIAL TO US IN
OUR COUNTY SUPPORTING KIN
PLACEMENTS AS WELL AS AS OTHER
PLACEMENTS OF YOUNG PEOPLE. WE
ARE A COUNTY THAT HAS BEEN FULLY
EXPANDING THESE FUNDS AND ONE
SPENT. WE'RE REVERTING BACK TO
LOCAL DOLLARS, WHICH, OF COURSE
IN THE CURRENT OVERALL, STATE
AND LOCAL BUDGET SITUATION
BECOMES MORE CHALLENGING AS WE
ENTER THIS BUDGET PERIOD IN THE
PROCESS CAN SOMETIMES BE
DIFFICULT FOR SOCIAL WORKERS TO
GAIN APPROVAL FOR THAT PROGRAM.
AND WITHOUT AS AS YOU INDICATED,
WE'RE ONE OF 58 COUNTIES. YOU
KNOW, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE WORKED FOR US.
WE ARE ALWAYS WANTING TO LEARN
FROM OTHER COUNTIES AND WE KNOW
AND RECOGNIZE EVEN WITHIN A
COUNTY. IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
ADAPTING AND TAILORING THE WORK
TO THE DIFFERENT NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES. AND BUT I'M
HOPING THIS HAS BEEN HELPFUL TO
AT LEAST GIVE A SNAPSHOT OF SOME
OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE. THANK
YOU. YES THANK YOU. UM, WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH THE NEXT
PRESENTATION AND THEN PAUSE FOR
QUESTIONS. SO THANK YOU, MADAM.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SONIA BOGUE,
FRESNO COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES DIRECTOR. SO I
WANNA, UM SAY DITTO TO A NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT WERE SAID IN THE
HEARING EARLIER AND GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT FOR FRESNO
COUNTY AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE WORKED FOR US. IT
GIVES YOU A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT PROGRAM LENS, SO
FRESNO COUNTY IS 10TH LARGEST
COUNTY IN THE STATE. WE'RE IN
CENTRAL VALLEY, BUT WE HAVE
FIFTH LARGEST CHILD WELFARE
POPULATION. SO THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT. WE ARE ON. HAVE
TWICE THE POVERTY RATE OF THE
STATE, AND WHEN IT COMES TO
NUMBER OF ADULTS IN POVERTY,
IT'S ABOUT 20% BUT WHEN WE LOOK
AT OUR POPULATION, 18 AND UNDER
IT'S ABOUT 30% OF OUR KIDS THAT
LIVE BELOW FEDERAL POVERTY. SO
WHILE POVERTY AND CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT ARE TWO SEPARATE
CONCEPTS, CERTAINLY POVERTY
IMPACTS OUR FAMILIES WHEN IT
COMES TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THERE CAN WHEN IT COMES TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT AND ADDRESS THE
NEEDS IN OUR SYSTEM, SO WHEN IT
COMES TO KIN, FIRST CULTURE
REALLY PAYING ATTENTION TO
POVERTY AND THE NEEDS OF THE IS
REALLY SIGNIFICANT. SO I WANT TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT BOTH
PREVENTION AND KN PLACEMENT FROM
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PERSPECTIVE
WHEN IT COMES TO PREVENTION AND
KIDS AND FAMILIES TOUCHING OUR
SYSTEM. WE REALLY NEED TO START
WITH AN EMERGENCY RESPONSE. AND
WHEN I COMPARE OUR DATA FROM
2021 TO 2020, THREE WE HAVE
DROPPED IN THOSE TWO YEARS. 30%
REDUCTION IN ENTRIES INTO CARE
AND REALLY THE DIFFERENCE THAT
IT MADE THE KIND OF THREE THINGS
IN MY MIND TO STICK OUT AND ONE
IS WE REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
REFERRALS FOR SOCIAL WORKER IN
2021. OUR SOCIAL WORKERS HAD 25
TO 30 REFERRALS, WHICH MEANS
SOCIAL WORKER OUT THERE
INVESTIGATING 30 FAMILIES TRYING
TO CLOSE THAT IN 30 DAYS, IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE. IT'S JUST NOT
POSSIBLE TO DO GOOD SOCIAL WORK
WITH THOSE KIND OF NUMBERS TODAY
, THOSE NUMBERS ARE 13 TO 15. I
FEEL LIKE WE'VE BEEN CLAWING OUR
WAY BACK FROM FROM COVID IN
TRYING TO HIRE, BUT DURING THE
TWO COVID YEARS, OUR NUMBER OUR
TURNOVER DOUBLED ENROLLMENT IN
FRESNO STATE, OUR LOCAL
UNIVERSITY THAT SUPPORTS NON
JUST FRESNO COUNTY, BUT A NUMBER
OF OTHER COUNTIES WHEN IT COMES
TO, UM GRADUATES FROM BOTH M S¼,
W, S¼ AND SOCIAL WORKERS. THEIR
ENROLLMENT DROPPED BY 30% SO
PART OF IT WAS AVAILABILITY OF
FUNDING. PART OF IT WAS JUST
SHEER AVAILABILITY OF STAFF, AND
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO HIRE OUR
WAY BACK. I THINK IT'S FINALLY
THIS YEAR THAT WE'RE GETTING
BACK TO THOSE, UH, PRE COVID
STABILITY NUMBERS, SO IT TAKES
TIME, AND IT ALSO TAKES
RESOURCES SO PART OF WHAT MADE
DIFFERENCE TO US IN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IS LEVERAGING. UM ER
ENHANCEMENT FUNDS. THOSE ARE
TIME LIMITED. SOMEONE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THAT, BUT PART OF
IT IS BEING ABLE TO TELL A
SOCIAL WORKER YES, YOU'RE GOING
TO INVESTIGATE AND FILE COURT
REPORTS, BUT YOU'RE ALSO AN
EMERGENCY PLACEMENT WORKER. AND
WE REALLY VALUE THE FIRST
PLACEMENT BEING WITH FAMILY, WE
MORE THAN DOUBLED THE NUMBER OF
KIDS GOING WITH AS A FIRST
PLACEMENT IN THE FAMILY AND PAST
TWO YEARS, OUR OVERALL NUMBER OF
KIDS WITH FAMILIES DIDN'T
NECESSARILY CHANGE SIGNIFICANTLY
BUT DOUBLING THAT INITIAL
PLACEMENT BEING WITH FAMILY
REQUIRE THAT EMERGENCY WORKER TO
SIT DOWN WITH THE FAMILY AND IT
ISN'T JUST ABOUT FINDING THEM.
THAT PART ISN'T AS HARD. IT'S
REALLY ADDRESSING THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS OF THE FAMILY FOR THAT
PLACEMENT TO HAPPEN, AND IT
QUICKLY THE REFERRAL TO
SOMEWHERE ELSE FOR THOSE THINGS
TO BE TAKEN CARE TAKEN CARE OF
HAPPENS, RIGHT? BUT THAT TAKES
TIME FOR THAT INITIAL PLACEMENT
TO BE WITH THE FAMILY. WE NEED
TO BE ON THE SPOT BEING ABLE TO
PIVOT AND ADDRESS SOME OF THE
BASIC NEEDS AND THAT REALLY
DEPENDING ON THE FAMILY CAN VARY
FROM BASIC THINGS LIKE CRIBS AND
, UM, ALARMS AND THOSE KIND OF
TANGIBLE THINGS TO REALLY SOME
VERY SIGNIFICANT THINGS FOR
FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
FOR THEM TO BE WILLING TO
ADDRESS. NOT BEING ABLE TO
CAPABLE OF DOING IT IN THE
MOMENT WHEN AND FOR US TO SAY
YES, BUT WE CAN THAT FLEXIBLE
FAMILY SUPPORTS AN EMERGENCY
FUNDING AND GIVING PERMISSION TO
STAFF TO SAY, WHAT DOES IT TAKE
FOR US TO REALLY BE ABLE TO IN
THE MOMENT? UM, DO THAT KIND OF
A CHANGE WHEN I LOOK AT ENTRIES
INTO CARE DROPPING BY 30% OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS WERE LO UM PER
WORKER DROPPING BY NEARLY 40 TO
50% AND IN DOUBLING THE
PLACEMENT WITH KIDS. THOSE ARE
THE ON THE GROUND TO FAMILIES
AND TO THE WORKERS. THAT'S WHAT
REALLY MADE THE DIFFERENCE. THE
TIME ARE ARE HAVING AN ABILITY
TO TAKE THE TIME TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THE NEEDS AND TO DO IT
QUICKLY, SO FAMILY DOESN'T NEED
TO GO THROUGH MULTIPLE STEPS.
MULTIPLE REFERRALS IN THE FOLLOW
UP THE OTHER PIECE, UM, IN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THAT I REALLY
WANNA, UM, ADDRESS THE PEACE IS
REALLY JUST ABOUT THE FUNDING
AND CHILD WELFARE. IT IS THE
SUPPORT ACROSS THE BOARD. SO ARE
SOME OF OUR KIDS AND FAMILIES
ENDED UP REALLY GROWING IN THE
PROPORTION THAT ARE GOING TO
FAMILY MAINTENANCE OR VOLUNTARY
FAMILY MAINTENANCE, AS OPPOSED
TO ENTERING THE SYSTEM AND
HAVING OUT OF HOME CARE, EVEN IF
IT'S OUT OF HOME WITH Kò WAS
PROVIDING THAT IMMEDIATE SUPPORT
TO THE ACTUAL PARENTS, AND SOME
OF THAT IS A LOT OF THAT, QUITE
FRANKLY, IS HOUSING SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS UM EARLIER, UM, YOU
ASKED ABOUT, UM, DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND WHAT MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE AND HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES?
I ACTUALLY ACCOMPANIED A SOCIAL
WORKER A YEAR OR SO AGO JUST
WANTING TO SEE ON THE GROUND
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE FOR FAMILIES,
AND IT HAPPENS TO BE A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REFERRAL. AND PART OF
IT IS MOM WAS HURT. SO WAS ONE
OF THE KIDS. WE'RE TALKING THREE
KIDS AND BUT FROM THE PARENTS
PERSPECTIVE THAT THE ISSUE IS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, BUT IT ALSO
IS POVERTY. BECAUSE WHEN MOM IS
SAYING IS, HEY, I SELL MY BLOOD
TO, UM AND PLASMA FOR TO
OCCASIONALLY SUPPORT THE FAMILY.
THE PA MOM WASN'T WORKING, BUT
THE DAD IS THE BREADWINNER. AND
TO ASK THAT FAMILY TO SEPARATE
WITHOUT CONSIDERING HOUSING
ISN'T EASY HAVING PROGRAMS ARE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
CONNECTING THAT MOM TO SUPPORTS
ON OUR MARJORIE MASON CENTER,
BUT ALSO REALLY TANGIBLY WALKING
HER THROUGH HOW TO ACCESS CAL
WORKS HOW TO ACCESS OUR FAMILY
STABILIZATION MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE OF THAT FAMILY
STAYING TOGETHER IN A MOMENT IT
LONG TERM. IT WON'T NECESSARILY
MAKE IT LONG TERM THE FAMILY
WOULD REUNIFY, BUT STAYING AND
NOT DISRUPTING THOSE KIDS AND
MOM RELATIONSHIP, UM IN IN THOSE
KIND OF ENVIRONMENTS PROGRAMS
THAT ARE TIME LIMITED, HONESTLY
GIVE US PERMISSION TO STEP BACK
AND DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY. BUT
LONG TERM OF THESE PROGRAMS
REALLY ENSURES THAT THOSE
EFFORTS AREN'T ONE TIME ENSURES
THAT THOSE EFFORTS ARE
SUSTAINABLE. SO I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU A COUPLE OF OTHER
PROGRAMS. WE ARE A QP COUNTY AS
WELL. I'M GLAD SOMEBODY ELSE
EXPLAINED WHAT IT REALLY MEANS.
BUT WHAT IT DID FOR OUR COUNTY.
WE WERE QP I COUNTY A LONG TIME
AGO. AND AS SUPPORTS KIND OF, UH
AND I THINK COVID DISRUPTED A
WHOLE LOT OF THINGS THAT IN THE
PAST TWO YEARS WE REALLY
REINVESTED A LOT OF EFFORT INTO
STEPPING BACK FUNDING OUR
CHAMPIONS REALLY TALKING ABOUT
Kò FIRST CULTURE, BUT ALSO
SAYING, WHAT ARE THE TANGIBLE
THINGS OUR OUR WORK GROUP IS
ACTUALLY CO CHAIR WITH A FOSTER
PARENT BUT HAS WORKERS AND, UH
ARE WE ENGAGING YOUTH TO BE ON
THAT WORK GROUP TO REALLY STEP
BACK AND SAY WHAT WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE? UH, FOR US TO BE
SUCCESSFUL, NOT JUST IN THAT
INITIAL PLACEMENT BUT IN BUT
THROUGHOUT THE LIFE OF A KID
WHETHER THEY'RE IN FOSTER YEAR
AND ONCE THEY GO BACK HOME, AND
THEY SOME TANGIBLE THING, PART
OF IT IS THE APPROACH, BUT PART
OF IT IS SOME TANGIBLE SUPPORTS.
AND ONE FOR US THAN THE WORK THE
GROUP IS WORKING ON IS
TRANSITIONS. IF A KID IS GOING
TO TRANSITION BACK HOME, OR
BETWEEN PLACEMENT, WHAT DOES IT
TAKE WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH
SUPPORTS? SUPPORT TO A FOSTER
PARENT. HOW DO WE ENSURE ENOUGH
WORKER SUPPORT ENOUGH SUPPORT OF
THE KIN SO THEY CAN WALK THROUGH
THE SYSTEM, WHICH IS QUITE
FRANKLY, REALLY COMPLICATED FOR
ANY OF US TO MANAGE IT TAKES IT
TAKES SOCIAL WORKERS, BUT IT
TAKES A WHOLE A WHOLE LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE TO SUPPORT A KID IN
OUR SYSTEM. THAT IS THE KIND OF
SUPPORT OUR FAMILY SHOULD COUNT
ON. ONCE A KID GOES BACK HOME,
THE OTHER PROGRAM FOR FRESNO
COUNTY THAT REALLY HAS MADE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE AS INTENSIVE
SERVICES FOSTER CARE. AND WHILE
WE HAVE INTENSIVE SERVICES,
FOSTER CARE THROUGH OUR FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES, WE'RE ALSO A
COUNTY THAT HAS COUNTY, UM
OPERATED INTENSIVE SERVICE,
FOSTER CARE HOMES, AND WHEN I
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF OUR KIDS
THAT ARE, UM IN GROUP HOMES OR
IN SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS WE HAVE
REDUCED BY ABOUT 27% IN PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, BUT OUR NUMBER
OF KIDS THAT ARE IT'S ONLY ABOUT
13% OF OUR KIDS THAT ARE IN
INTENSIVE SERVICE FOSTER HOME SO
IN GRAND SCHE. NINE NOT A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF KIDS. AND YET
THESE ARE KIDS THAT NEED THE
MOST SUPPORT. SO WHAT INTENSIVE
SERVICE FOSTER CARE DOES FOR
THEM IS REALLY WE STEP BACK AND
LOOK AT IN THAT MOMENT FOR THAT
CHILD AND FOR THAT KIN OR A
RESOURCE PARENT. WHAT DOES IT
TAKE FOR A KID TO STAY AND NOT
JUST BE OK BUT THRIVE. AND WHEN
THOSE INTENSIVE SUPPORTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR A PROLONGED PERIOD
OF TIME, THE KIDS DO THRIVE. WE
DO SEE BETTER REUNIFICATION
RATES. WE DO SEE BETTER SCHOOL
OUTCOMES. WE DO SEE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES, AND THAT CAN BE
A TIME LIMITED THING. UM OR A
FIXED THING. IT REALLY VARIES.
UM FROM A KID TO KID. SO WHAT? I
REALLY, UH KIND OF WANNA LEAVE
YOU WITH IS SOME OF THESE ONE
TIME? UM LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS
AND PROGRAMS ARE HUGE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US, AND WE
TAKE THEM THEY MATTER. THE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
IT REALLY ALLOWS US TO THINK OF
THESE THINGS. NOT AS A ONE TIME
UM OPPORTUNITY, BUT THIS IS HOW
OUR SYSTEMS NEED TO OPERATE LONG
TERM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UM
ANY QUESTIONS? YES UM, THANK YOU
SO MUCH DAVID FOR BRINGING UP
FIRST, AND I WAS GONNA BE ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS LIKE THE NEED IN
THE COUNTY TO SEEING IT BEING
UTILIZED. SO THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THAT. CAN YOU BRIEFLY
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
FED TO PROTECT YOU SAID YOU WERE
PART UM OF THAT COALITION. BUT
COULD YOU DIVE IN A LITTLE BIT
MORE? SOME OF THE THEMES THAT
ARE COMING OUT OF THAT? SURE,
AND THIS IS THE SORRY. MY OWN.
YEAH. SORRY ABOUT THAT. YEAH
THIS IS THE TASK FORCE THAT
DIRECTOR JOHNSON TALKED ABOUT
THAT THE AMENDED REPORTING TO
COMMUNITY SUPPORTING TASK FORCE,
AND IT'S LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF THE
OVERALL MANDATED REPORTING
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE HISTORICALLY
HAD. AND SO IT'S. IT'S LOOKING
AT THE LEGAL DEFINITION OF
NEGLECT, AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME REALLY IMPORTANT CHANGES
THAT HAVE HAPPENED WITH A B AND
S¼ B Tð, UH, 2085, AND I BELIEVE
1085 AROUND DETACHING POVERTY
AND NEGLECT BUT LOOKING AT
WHETHER THERE'S OTHER OF THAT
DEFINITION THAT THE TASK FORCE
MIGHT MAKE WANT TO MAKE A
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE LEGAL
DEFINITION AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
I KNOW WAS BROUGHT UP IS ONE OF
THOSE AREAS THAT THAT'S BEING
LOOKED AT WITHIN THAT THAT THAT
COMMITTEE IT'S ALSO LOOKING AT
TRAINING AND THE ROLE OF
TRAINING AND WHAT TRAINING
SHOULD LOOK LIKE FOR A MAN TO
REPORTERS. IT'S ALSO LOOKING AT
THE LIABILITY AS WE SHIFT TO A
LENS OF IDENTIFYING DIFFERENT
WAYS TO SUPPORT ALL OF THOSE
FAMILIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
REFERRED TO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THAT OFTEN ARE ARE NOT
OPENED UP. CASE AND UNFOUNDED,
MAKING SURE WE HAVE A PATHWAY
TOWARDS WHAT WE'RE CALLING A
COMMUNITY PATHWAY OTHER KINDS OF
SUPPORTS, BUT ALSO ADDRESSING
THE FACT THAT SO MANY OF THOSE
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE MANDATED
REPORTERS HAVE THOSE RISK
MANAGEMENT FOLKS THAT THAT HAVE
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS AND
EXPECTATIONS AROUND THAT SO
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE LAWS
AROUND LIABILITY DATA IS
CRITICAL TO THAT AND THEN OTHER
POLICY AND PRACTICE
CONSIDERATIONS ARE EMBEDDED
WITHIN THAT LARGER GOAL. SO
THERE ARE FIVE DIFFERENT ARMS TO
THE WORK. THE INTENT IS FOR THE
TASK FORCE TO BRING FORWARD SET
OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE JUNE
TROUBLE FOR COUNCIL MEETING. WE
EXPECT THAT THIS WILL BE AN
ONGOING PROCESS. THIS IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT REFORM THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT, AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEING TALKED ABOUT
NATIONALLY, SO WE DON'T EXPECT
THE WORK TO BE DONE THEN BUT BUT
THEY'RE DOING SOME GREAT WORK
AND EXCITED TO SEE WE'VE GOT A
DIVERSE GROUP OF FOLKS FROM
BROAD ARRAY OF SYSTEMS, A NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERTISE THAT ARE PART OF THE
GROUP. THANK YOU. FOR BOTH OF
YOU. YOU SHARED A DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT WORKED AND YOUR
DIFFERENT COUNTIES YOU JUST
SPOKE ABOUT. INTENSIVE. SERVICE
FOSTER CARE. CAN YOU SHARE SOME
OF THE MOST COMMON NEEDS THAT A
LOT OF OUR FAMILIES NEED WHEN
THEY GET A FOSTER KID PLACEMENT?
FOSTER KID PLACED GO FOR IT. I
THINK AND ESPECIALLY FOR I'LL
FOCUS ON KIN CARE AS AS IT WAS
INDICATED. THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
PEOPLE ARE EXPECTING TO DO OFTEN
, AND SO IT'S FIRST
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
OBLIGATION IS WHAT THE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE SYSTEM IS
. THE TROUBLE FOR SYSTEM IS
CONFUSING FOR US THAT HAVE
WORKED IN IT FOR 30 SOMETHING
YEARS AND SO FOR FAMILIES, IT IS
OFTEN UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING INTO AND EDUCATING THEM.
UM IT DEPENDS ON THE CHILD OR
YOUTH THAT'S COMING IN AS TO
WHAT THOSE SPECIFIC NEEDS ARE,
BUT IT'S HELPING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SERVICES PORTS, WHETHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND THE EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORTS THAT ARE NEEDED,
WHETHER IT'S HEALTH CARE RELATED
, WHETHER THOSE ARE IN PLACE.
SOMETIMES IT'S TANGIBLE. UM, IT
IT MIGHT BE THAT WE'VE HAD, UH,
KIN CAREGIVERS THAT HAVE HAD TO
MOVE INTO A LARGER PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT THAT YOUNG
PERSON, SO IT'S HELPING THEM
WITH TANGIBLE THINGS LIKE LIKE
DEPOSIT ON ON A ON A NEW
APARTMENT OR THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS, SO I THINK IT REALLY
RUNS THE GAMUT, UM OF BASIC
NEEDS. OF SERVICES OF HELPING TO
SUPPORT THE CONNECTION IS
CRITICAL TO THOSE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE IMPORTANT IN THEIR
LIVES TO PARENTS AND OTHERS. SO
I'LL STOP THERE AND KIND OF ADD
TO IT. SO I'M GONNA ADD. IT
REALLY DEPENDS ON THE AGE OF A
KIDDO. AND THE TIME UM, IN THE
CASE, SO UPFRONT FOR MY EMER FOR
EMERGENCY PLACEMENT AND FOR MY
RESOURCE FAMILY SO FAMILY CAN
ACCEPT PLACEMENT IMMEDIATELY
WITHOUT MEETING ALL OF THE
GUIDELINES. EVENTUALLY A FAMILY
NEEDS TO GO THROUGH THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL. THAT PROCESS IS
INTENSIVE. AND SO SUPPORT AND
THERE'S SOME REALLY KIND OF
TANGIBLE THINGS. ALARMS CRIPS,
UM, THINGS THAT WE DON'T REALLY
THINK ABOUT THAT THAT RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL WILL HAVE TO
KIND OF CHECK THE BOX MEDI. FOR
UM, MEDICATIONS, THE CABINETS
SPA, THE ACTUAL TANGIBLE THINGS
THAT FAMILY NEEDS THAT THEY DID
NOT ANTICIPATE SPENDING MONEY ON
THAT OUR ABILITY TO FUND IT IS
HUGE. SOME OF THE OTHER SUPPORTS
, REALLY, AS WE'RE WALKING
THROUGH THE SYSTEMS IN OUR WE
IMPROVED OUR R FA APPROVAL IN
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS BY LIKE
60% THE LENGTH OF TIME AND SOME
OF THAT WAS REALLY THINGS LIKE
OURS, OUR SOCIAL WORKERS AND
SUPPORT STAFF BEING AVAILABLE IN
THE EVENINGS AND ON THE WEEKENDS
FOR LIVE SCAN. FOR WALKING
FAMILY, NOT JUST SAYING, WELL,
THE TRAINING FOR THAT EIGHT HOUR
PRE-APPROVAL TRAINING IS
AVAILABLE ONLINE, ACTUALLY
WALKING THEM THROUGH IT,
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S SKIN AND
ESPECIALLY IF WE HAVE, UM,
LANGUAGE, UH, A DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE NEEDS BEING ABLE TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE FAMILY GOING LIKE
THIS IS THE PIECE TO GO THROUGH.
THIS IS THE PAPER BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO CONNECT WITH THE
FAMILIES OR WHY IS IT TAKING AS
LONG AS IT DOES THAT INDIVIDUAL
SOCIAL WORKER INTENTION WITH THE
ACTUAL TANGIBLE SUPPORTS IS TO
ME WHAT MADE THE MOST DIFFERENCE
ONCE, SO THAT'S OF THE UPFRONT
NEEDS ONCE THE FAMILY IS, UM
THERE ON AN ONGOING BASIS, THE
ONGOING SUPPORT, ESPECIALLY FOR
OUR KIDS THAT ARE MULTISYSTEM
INVOLVED. UM HELPING THEM
UNDERSTAND? WELL THIS IS WHAT
EDUCATION IS BRINGING THROUGH.
THIS IS THESE ARE THE
APPOINTMENTS THROUGH MENTAL
HEALTH AND WHAT IT REALLY MEANS
HELPING THE SOCIAL WORKER GUIDE,
UM THE FAMILY THROUGH IT BECAUSE
IT'S JUST HARD TO UNDERSTAND
FROM BOTH EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IF OUR KIDS
THAT ARE IN OUR èC VÆ R èC THE
Dð Dð R UM Dð Dð S¼ INVOLVED
KIDDOS. WHEN THERE'S A
DEVELOPMENTAL BLAZE, WE ALL HAVE
OUR OWN ALPHABET SOUP. WE ALL
OUR OWN REPORTS AND HELPING
FAMILY NAVIGATE THAT, UM, AND TO
ME, THAT'S AGAIN SOCIAL WORKER
TIME. AND THEN IF THERE'S
DISRUPTION IN PLACEMENT WHEN,
WHEN WE LOOKED AT WHEN THE
PLACEMENT DISRUPTION HAPPENS,
AND WE'RE GETTING 14 DAY NOTICES
AND WHAT WHAT SUPPORTS THE
FAMILY'S NEED FOR THAT NOT TO BE
A REALITY. IT ENDS UP BEING THE
THINGS LIKE RESPITE CARE. I
DON'T WANNA QUIT ON THE SKIN.
BUT THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
AND I NEED A BREAK AND I NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. RESPITE HAS
BEEN A HUGE SUPPORT TO OUR TO
OUR RESOURCE FAMILIES. UM, TO
SAY, I NEED SOMEBODY ELSE TO
WALK WITH ME TO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND? AND TO GIVE ME A
BREAK, AND WHEN I THINK OF IT
BEING A MOM, I'M LIKE WE ALL
NEED THAT. SO IT'S NOT REALLY
ANYTHING DIFFERENT FROM A FAMILY
OUR ABILITY TO FUND IT AND BE
THERE TIMELY IS REALLY I THINK
THE DIFFERENCE IN MY FINAL
QUESTION RELATED TO THAT, UM,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
YOU KNOW OUR OUR PREDECESSORS
BEFORE OUR TIME, UM, PASSED
LEGISLATION TO REMOVE THE
BARRIERS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THOSE FAMILIES WHO ACTUALLY KNOW
THEY WANT TO TAKE IN THEIR KIN,
RIGHT? WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THOSE THAT DIDN'T KNOW THIS WAS
GONNA LAND ON THEIR LAP, BUT
THOSE WERE ACTIVELY LOOKING TO
TAKE IN THEIR LOVED ONES. YOU
KNOW ABOUT NOT HAVING POVERTY BE
IMPACTED AGAINST THEM.
ANECDOTALLY I'M STILL HEARING
THAT IF THEY LIVE IF A FAMILY
LIVES IN A ONE BEDROOM, THEY
CAN'T TAKE ON THEIR KIN. AND FOR
ME THAT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE STILL
UTILIZING POVERTY AS AN ISSUE TO
PREVENT KIDS GOING INTO THEIR
FAMILY ONES. I MEAN, I'D RATHER
LIVE IN THE SOFA OF MY AUNT THAN
IN THE DESK OF A SOCIAL SOCIAL
WORKER BECAUSE THERE'S NÓ
PLACEMENT. TALK TO ME A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT OTHER BARRIERS
THAT WE CAN REMOVE, OR THAT
STILL EXISTS TO THAT PREVENT US
FROM PLACING THESE KIDS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. OH, I. I THINK
YOU ARTICULATED THAT VERY WELL.
AND I IT. IT DEFINITELY HAS GOT
IS FAR BETTER THAN IT THAN IT
WAS. AND I KNOW THERE'S ALSO
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THERE HAS
BEEN RECENT FEDERAL LAW THAT
ALLOWS STATES TO LOOK AT THAT
APPROVAL FOR RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
DIFFERENTLY, WHICH WHICH THE
STATE IS ENGAGING COUNTIES IN
DISCUSSION ON NOW TO LOOK AT
WHETHER THEY'RE IN TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND CLEARANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. IT DEFINITELY HAS GOTTEN
EASIER IN TERMS OF CLEARANCES
AND SOME OF THE LIKE ON THE LAW,
BUT THERE WAS, I KNOW A LOT THAT
HELPED TO ADDRESS THAT AND THE
SUPPORTS, ESPECIALLY WITH
ONGOING FUNDING. OFTEN TIMES.
IT'S NOT WE CAN'T PLACE BUT IT'S
THAT KIN CAREGIVER. WANTS TO
HAVE A LARGER SETTING FOR THAT
CHILD BECAUSE IT'S A BETTER
PLACE TO RAISE THAT CHILD IF
THEY THINK IT'S GOING TO BE HERE
FOR A LONGER TERM, AND SO THAT'S
WHERE SOME OF THESE THESE
SUPPORTS THAT RIGHT NOW ARE ONE
TIME HAVE BEEN BENEFICIAL IN
THAT WAY. UM TRYING TO THINK
WHAT ELSE? I REALLY I DO THINK I
THINK I HEARD SOMETHING LIKE IF
SOMEONE HAS A POOL. IT'S A
BARRIER TO GET PLACED THERE THAT
WE WILL NOW THROUGH FLEXIBLE
FAMILY SUPPORTS FUND THAT, LIKE
FUND THE OK, YOU CAN HAVE A
FENCE, YOU CAN HAVE ALARMS.
THOSE ARE KIND OF ONE TIME NEEDS
THAT, DEPENDING ON THE FAMILY,
DEPENDING ON THE ASSESSMENT,
REALLY ADDRESSING THAT, UM, NOT
ASKING FAMILIES TO GO JUMP
THROUGH A WHOLE BUNCH OF
COMMUNITY RESOURCES IN ORDER TO
FIGURE OUT THAT ON THEIR OWN.
SOME OF IT IS GUIDING THEM
THROUGH IT. PART OF IT IS WHEN
YOU'RE IN THAT IN THAT
SITUATION, TRYING TO ADDRESS IT
AND ADDRESS IT QUICKLY. SO WE
ARE NOT DELAYING THAT INITIAL
PLACEMENT. I THINK SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER AT THAT ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND YET, THOSE THOSE ARE REAL
COSTS. SO WE YEARS AGO WE HAD
PIPERS AND I COULDN'T TELL YOU
WHAT THAT STANDS FOR NOW AND
THEN IT DISAPPEARED FOR A WHILE,
AND WE REALLY SAW A DECLINE IN
MANY COUNTIES, JUST INABILITY TO
PAY FOR THAT SO FLEXIBLE FAMILY
SUPPORTS BRINGING THAT BACK.
WHICH IS WHAT YOU WERE HEARING
US BOTH ECHOED, LIKE, DON'T MAKE
THAT ONE TIME THAT JUST NEEDS TO
BE THE NORM. THE OTHER PIECE FOR
OUR FAMILIES IS REALLY THAT
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THEM NOT TO
FEEL WERE PULLING OUT. OK THINGS
ARE OK LIVING IN A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME WHEN YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE SIX MONTHS THAT
LOOKS DIFFERENT AT THE AT 12
MONTHS OR 13 MONTHS. SO WHAT DO
WE WHAT DO WE REALLY
MEANINGFULLY NEED ON AN ONGOING
BASIS? IF A KID IS GOING TO STAY
IN SCHOOL, AND IT'S AN ONGOING
TRANSPORTATION? WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE? SOMETIMES IT'S
REIMBURSEMENT FOR GAS, SOMETIMES
IN ACTUAL TEAM COMING UP AND
SAYING, LIKE WHO IS GOING TO DO
THAT TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE THE
JOBS AND IT'S WHATEVER AN
AVERAGE FAMILY NEEDS WE NEED TO
SAY THOSE KIND OF SUPPORTS NEED
TO BE THERE ON AN ONGOING BASIS
FOR US NOT TO LOOK AT IT AS AT
ONE TIME NEED. I DO THINK OUR
PROGRAMS ARE GOOD WHEN WE DESIGN
THEM, NOT LOOKING AT A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY IS I DO THINK
WHAT WHERE OUR CHALLENGES BEGIN.
BUT POTENTIALLY, YOU KNOW, THE
IT'S GREAT THAT THE PROGRAMS
EXIST FOR PERHAPS FUNDING THAT
FENCE. BUT IF A NEWBORN PARENT
IF A NEW IF A PARENT DOESN'T GET
A TEST TO BRING THEIR NEWBORN
HOME IF THEY HAVE A POOR OR NOT,
I JUST FEEL LIKE THIS IS AN
ADDED BARRIER THAT COULD PROLONG
THE PROCESS. UH, WHERE, WHERE,
IN FACT, WE COULD JUST REMOVE
YOU HAVE A POOL? YOU HAVE A
POOL? I MEAN, MAYBE I'M JUST,
YOU KNOW. I JUST I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S STILL SOME THAT WE'RE
FINDING WAYS TO ADDRESS A
BARRIER VERSUS REMOVING THE
BARRIER. IT'S REALLY HOW WE LOOK
AT SAFETY AND DEPENDING ON IT,
IT'S REALLY WORKING WITH OUR
EMERGENCY FOR ALL FAMILIES. YES,
AND SOME OF IT IS THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT LIABILITY AND
SAFETY. BUT HOW DO WE LOOK AT
SAFETY? AND HOW DO WE ADDRESS
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF SAFETY FOR
OUR KIDS, AND WE DO LOOK AT IT
DIFFERENTLY? RIGHT WHEN THE KID
IS REMOVED, AND IT'S A PLACEMENT
VERSUS SUPPORTING THE FAMILY UP
FRONT, AND, UM AND IT AND
INFUSING SUPPORT, SO KIDS STAYS
AT HOME. I DO THINK THAT WHEN WE
LOOK AT PREVENTION IF WE CAN DO
PREVENTION BEFORE FAMILIES AND
KIDS TOUCH OUR SYSTEM, I'M ALL
FOR IT. BUT THE REALITY IS WE,
UM, IMAGINING OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FOR THAT. YES WE'RE
INVESTIGATING A CALL AND ABUSE
AND NEGLECT AND YES, WE'RE WE
HAVE TO DO THE A PAPERWORK FOR
COURT AND TIMELINESS BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE IN FAMILIES LIVES,
BUT THAT WORKER SEEING
THEMSELVES AS ALSO HOW DO I KEEP
YOU AT HOME? HOW DO I ADDRESS
ANY SAFETY NEEDS? SO YOU ARE NOT
ENTERING OUR SYSTEM? THAT'S
REALLY WHERE OUR EFFORTS SHOULD
BE. AND THAT TAKES THAT REALLY
TAKES STAFF TIME THAT LOOK THAT
REALLY LOOKS AT STAFF BEING
TRAINED ENOUGH AND SUPPORTED
ENOUGH TO LOOK AT SAFETY
DIFFERENTLY, AND THAT MEANS
CONNECTING OUR FAMILIES UP FRONT
WITH ANY POSSIBLE SUPPORT. WE
CAN BECAUSE THEY'RE MUCH BETTER
OFF. UH, THEN ENTERING OUR
SYSTEM, AND THAT'S NOT THAT'S
NOT ANYTHING AGAINST OUR SYSTEMS
. BUT WE DO LOOK AT LIABILITY
AND SAFETY DIFFERENTLY WHEN A
KID IS OUT OF HOME CARE VERSUS
STAYING AT HOME. I WANT TO
CONTINUE ON THE THEME OF
RESOURCE FAMILIES BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT IS PART OF THE
EQUATION OF SUCCESS. EXCUSE ME
OUT OF PLACEMENT AS WELL. UM. I.
I WANTED TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT YOUR CONCERNS AND
SOME OF THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
YOU FOUND IN YOUR EXPERIENCE
SUPPORTING RESOURCE FAMILIES
TRAINING AND RECRUITING THEM
FOR, UH, MULTIPLE SIBLING CARE
FOR TRANSITIONING YOUTH FOR
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
YOUTH, UM NATIVE CHILDREN AS
WELL AS, UH, CHILDREN OF MIGRANT
FARM WORKER FAMILIES. SO SOME OF
THESE SUB SUBSETS THAT WE SEE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE,
UH, UNIQUE CULTURAL NEEDS. WHICH
NEEDS AND, UM UH, HIS
INTERPRETATIONS OF WHAT SUCCESS
LOOKS LIKE WITHIN THAT FAMILY.
SO UM SOME CONCERNS OR SOME BEST
PRACTICES. AND I THINK IT STARTS
WITH IS THE LENS WITHIN WHICH WE
ARE WORKING WITH THOSE FAMILIES
AND RECOGNIZING THAT THAT OFTEN
OUR SYSTEM COMES IN WITH A
DIFFERENT LENS THAN THE FAMILIES
WE WORK WITH. AND SO A LOT. WHAT
IS WORKED WITH US IS THIS IS
WHERE I THINK I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT CAN CULTURE AND ENGAGING
THOSE SUPPORTS AROUND. BUT ALSO
THOSE THOSE COMMUNITY ENTITIES
THAT MAY BE MORE CONNECTED WITH
THE COMMUNITIES WE'RE WORKING
WITH. IN OUR COUNTY. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF FAMILIES THAT COME
INTO OUR SYSTEM, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT ARE MIGRANT FARM WORKER
FAMILIES AND INDIGENOUS FAMILIES
FROM MEXICO AND WE STRENGTHENED
OUR WORK BY PARTNERING WITH
AGENCIES THAT ARE TRUSTED AND
THAT GOES WITH WORKING WITH KIN
CAREGIVERS OR ESPECIALLY NON
RELATED CAREGIVERS. THAT MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND THOSE FAMILIES. AND
SO IT'S EDUCATION. BUT IT'S ALSO
HELPING TO DEMYSTIFY AND TO AND
TO BRING IN POTENTIALLY OTHER
RESOURCES AND UNDERSTAND THE WAY
I KIND OF GOES TO SAFETY, BUT
ALSO UNDERSTAND WHAT WELL BEING
AND SAFETY AND CULTURE LOOKS
LIKE FOR THAT CHILD AS WELL AS
FOR THOSE PARENTS WANTING TO
MAINTAIN THAT CONNECTION THAT
HAS REALLY WORKED WORKED WELL
FOR US. UM IT'S BEEN A SHIFT
BECAUSE II I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THAT SHIFT OF THE LENS HAS BEEN
WITH CHILD WELFARE WHERE WHEN I
STARTED, IT WAS WE DO THINGS
KIND OF A ONE SIZE FITS ALL AND
HAVING TO REAL. WE'VE REALIZED
THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND REALIZE
THAT THEIR STRENGTHS AND
SUPPORTS WITHIN EACH COMMUNITY.
WE NEIGHBORHOOD OFTEN THAT WE
WORK IN THAT WE CAN HELP TO
PARTNER WITH AND IT'S A PROCESS
AS WELL BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT OF
DISPROPORTIONALITY AND
DISPARITIES HISTORICALLY IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO BUILD THAT
TRUST, BUT I THINK IT'S COMING
IN AND EN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES DIFFERENTLY. ALSO IT'S
GOING IN AND THIS IS A CORE
TENANT OF CO PARENTING, BUT ALSO
SOME OF THE OTHER CHANGES THAT
HAVE HAPPENED IN PRACTICE OF
RECOGNIZING THAT WE AS A SYSTEM
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS GOING
IN. AND SO IT'S UNDERSTANDING
THAT FAMILIES OFTEN GOING TO
KNOW WHAT WHAT WILL WORK BEST
FOR THEM, AND IT MAY BE WITHIN
CERTAIN PARAMETERS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY AND THE REGULATIONS THAT
WE WORK IN, BUT IT'S SHARING
THAT POWER OF HOW TO IDENTIFY
THE SOLUTIONS THAT WORK WITH
FAMILIES, SO THERE'S A FEW
EXAMPLES OF WHERE IT'S WORK. SO
UM, I ACTUALLY ASKED MY RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL STAFF. I'M LIKE
WHAT MAKES THE MOST DIFFERENCE,
AND THERE'S SOME REALLY KIND OF
TANGIBLE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
FLEXIBLE FAMILY SUPPORTS. SO THE
KIND OF THEIR LIST STARTED WITH
THINGS LIKE I MEAN, REALLY LIKE
SMOKE DETECTORS, AIR MATTRESSES,
SCRIBS BEDS, GAS REIMBURSEMENT.
UM WE REALLY STRUGGLE WITH
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL BACKLOG
, AND SOME OF THAT WAS
SUFFICIENT STAFF TIME. REALLY
SUFFICIENT STAFF TIME DID THAT
IF WE'RE GONNA WHEN WE WHEN
STAFF DECREASES. WE GO INTO A
CRISIS MODE AND COMING OUT OF
COVID, UM RE INFUSING OUR
RESOURCES INTO RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL TO NOT AND TRYING TO
TRYING TO DOUBLE OUR, UH, KIN.
FIRST PLACEMENT BUT ALSO, UM,
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL ACROSS
THE BOARD HAND HOLDING FAMILIES
THROUGH THE PROCESS. MY STAFF
GAVE ME AN EXAMPLE OF BUYING
IPADS BUT REALLY IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES LIKE KINGA AND HURON
THAT ARE 70 MILES FROM FRESNO
AND REALLY, REALLY SMALL WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICE SOCIAL
WORKER GOING OUT THERE AND
HELPING WALK THEM THROUGH THE
PAPERWORK AND THE US IN THE
TRAINING MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
TO FAMILIES. I OUR SYSTEMS NEED
TO BE DESIGNED IN SUCH A WAY
GIVEN 58 COUNTIES, GIVEN HOW
LARGE WE ARE THAT THERE IS A
GENERAL SYSTEM OF HOW IT WORKS,
AND THEN FLEXIBILITY TO REALLY,
UM, PIVOT BASED ON A COMMUNITY
PIVOT BASED ON THE FAMILY TO SAY
THIS IS WHAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
THAT'S WHERE THAT IS REALLY HUGE
THINGS SIMPLE THINGS LIKE HAVING
STAFF AVAILABLE ON AFTER A AFTER
5 P.M. AND ON SATURDAYS FOR
THINGS LIKE FAMILY APPROVAL WHEN
IT COMES TO LIVE SCANS BECAUSE
FAMILIES WORK 8 TO 5 AND WE ARE
USED TO EMERGENCY RESPONSE BEING
AVAILABLE, BUT ONLY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. 24 7. THE REST OF OUR
SYSTEMS ARE NOT AND MAKING THAT
CHANGE MADE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
IN OUR FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO
COMPLY AND NOD THAT ONLINE
RESOURCES AREN'T AVAILABLE. BUT
THAT ASSUMES THAT OUR KIN KNOWS
HOW TO DO THAT KNOWS EXACTLY
WHERE TO CLICK WHERE TO GO
THROUGH PICK. WHAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THAT INDIVIDUAL
GUIDANCE BY A SOCIAL WORKER GIRL
LIKE YOU CAN CALL ME YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT YOUR CHILD
SOCIAL WORKER. YOU CALL ME I'M
GONNA WALK YOU THROUGH THE
PAPERWORK. I'M GONNA STEP YOU
THROUGH THIS AND EXPLAIN WHAT IT
REALLY MEANS. UM REALLY MADE A
DIFFERENCE TO US THAT IN THE TWO
YEAR I MEAN OUR BACKLOG WENT
DOWN BY 64% AND THAT WAS
HAPPENING. AT THE SAME TIME. WE
WERE DOUBLING THE NUMBER OF BAD
ABOUT RESOURCE FAMILIES THAT ARE
ACTUAL KIN. ANOTHER ELEMENT OF
TO MENTION IN JENNIFER TALKED
ABOUT THIS IS AND YOU REFERENCE
THE FERS AND I CAN'T REMEMBER
WHAT FLIERS STANDS FOR, EITHER,
BUT BUT THOSE ARE DOLLARS THAT
THAT PRECEDED THE FLEXIBLE
FAMILY SUPPORTS AND THE P
MENTORS, THE FORMER CAREGIVERS
OR CURRENT CAREGIVERS. IN SOME
CASES THAT SUPPORT OUR OTHER
CAREGIVERS WERE SOMETHING WE
WERE ABLE TO FUND WITH THOSE FIP
DOLLARS AND THAT PROGRAM IS A
LITTLE BIT SMALLER NOW NOW THAT
MONEY IS WAS NOT ONGOING, BUT IT
WAS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HAVING
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
THROUGH THE SAME EXPERIENCE. UM,
SUPPORTING CAREGIVERS HAS BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL AS WELL, OK?
EXCUSE ME, SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
NOT HEARING IS COMING FROM A
CHILD'S PERSPECTIVE IF A CHILD
HAS BEEN RAISED WITHIN A CERTAIN
CULTURE OR LANGUAGE, RELIGION,
UM HOW ARE WE ENSURING THAT THE
OUT OF HOME PLACEMENT FOR THAT
CHILD? HAS MIRRORS WHAT THAT
CHILD'S SAFETY COMMUNITY IS LIKE
, HOW ARE WE ENSURING THAT THOSE
RESOURCE FAMILIES THAT TAKE IN,
FOR EXAMPLE, A TRANS CHILD OR
TAKE A CHILD FROM THE SIKH
COMMUNITY HAS THAT CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IS SAFE FOR THAT CHILD? UM YOU
KNOW, I UNDERSTAND KIND OF THE
TANGIBLE SUPPORTS, BUT OUR
CHILDREN ARE ARE ARE DEALING
WITH SOME VERY IMPORTANT
IDENTITY ISSUES AND WHEN THEY'RE
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME AND
PUTTING AND OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT. UM HOW ARE THE
COUNTIES ENSURING THAT THOSE
KIDS ARE TAKEN CARE OF, AND THAT
OUR RESOURCE PARENTS FEEL
COMPETENT IN WORKING WITH WITH
THE CHILD, SO WE ARE IN FRESNO
ACTUALLY HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED
CULTURAL BROKERS, AND WE'VE, UM
KIND OF DOUBLED UP OUR
INVESTMENT DURING THIS PAST YEAR
IN THE PROGRAM, AND SOME OF IT
IS REALLY HAVING, UM HAVING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE COMMUNITY GO OUT EVEN
AS EARLY AS OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FOR TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND HOW WE ENGAGE WITH
THE COMMUNITY. HOW WE EVEN
DEFINE WHAT SAFETY IS. AND THEN
IF THE KID IS GOING TO ENTER OUR
SYSTEM, HAVING A CULTURAL BROKER
AND A PARENT PARTNER CAN WALK
THROUGH AND THIS IS WHAT'S
NEEDED. THIS IS WHAT REALLY
THEY'RE SAYING WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING. THAT REALLY HELPING US
ALMOST TRANSLATE HOW WE SAY OUR
GOVERNMENT NEEDS VERSUS THE
CHILD IN THE COMMUNITY, I THINK
FOR BROKERS PROGRAM IS ONE THAT
HAS MADE THE MOST DIFFERENCE IN.
WITH SOME OF OUR SOME OF OUR
SUCCESSES. I DO THINK THAT THIS
IS THE AREA WHERE WE NEED TO
GROW AND EXPANDING, EXPANDING ON
THAT MODEL ACROSS THE BOARD AND
REALLY HEARING THE FAMILY AND
ENSURING THE EXPERIENCE. SOME OF
IT IS, UM TRAININGS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR BOTH OUR STAFF AND
FOR A RESOURCE FAMILY. UM, AND
HEARING OUR KIDS IN WHAT THE
TANGIBLE SUPPORTS LOOK LIKE TO
THEM, SO THEY'RE NOT MISSING THE
THINGS THAT ARE USED TO SIMPLY
BECAUSE THERE IS A DISRUPTION
THEIR HOME ENVIRONMENT. THANK
YOU. THAT'S THE FIRST TIME I
HEARD ABOUT THOSE CULTURAL
BROKERS. UM I'M I THINK I'M
THINKING OF LIKE THE PROMO TOAS
PROGRAM WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH
ACCESS. SO IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT'S UNIQUE TO COUNTY OF
FRESNO? SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE,
YOU'VE, UM SO I'M GLAD TO SAY A
DECADE OR SO AGO IN THE COUNTY
OF FRESNO STARTED IT. AND THEN,
UM, I SAW A PRESENTATION IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY, UH, BY OUR
PROGRAM, AND I'M LIKE, HEY, THAT
EXPANDED THAT WE REALLY, UH IT
EXISTS A NUMBER OF COUNTIES. IT
IS A KIND OF FUNDED PRACTICE AND
EXPANDED AND REALLY WHAT IT
MEANT A DECADE AGO VERSUS TODAY,
OVER TIME REALLY NEEDS TO CHANGE
. PART OF IT IS BOTH HOW WE
INVESTIGATE HOW WE TALK TO
FAMILIES, OUR CULTURAL BROKERS
SAID IN OUR CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM MEETINGS OF HELPING, UM AND
GO THROUGH, UM, THEY REALLY GO
THROUGH WITH OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
THROUGH A SAFETY, ORGANIZED
PRACTICE TRAINING IN DIVISION 31
TRAINING, SO THEY ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE SYSTEM, THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND THE
COURTS HELPING FAMILIES
UNDERSTAND THAT SO THEY
UNDERSTAND WHY WE ASK WHAT WE
ASK. SO WE'RE NOT BEING
INTENTIONALLY INTRUSIVE. WE
REALLY JUST NEED TO KNOW AND
ALSO HELPING OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
UNDERSTAND, OK, THE CULTURE AND
THE LANGUAGE AND CUSTOMS THAT WE
MAY NOT FULLY UNDERSTAND. WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN? WHAT'S MISSING
AND THEN HELPING NOT LOSE A KID
IN THIS PERSPECTIVE, RIGHT? SO I
DO THINK THERE'S GROWTH IN THAT
PROGRAM IS ACROSS THE BOARD. BUT
WE'VE IN FRESNO REALIZED THAT
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE HAD A PROGRAM
FOR A LONG TIME DURING COVID,
AND DURING PAST YEARS AND
FUNDING CHANGES THAT DISSIPATED
THAT WE'VE, UM I THINK BORN AND
DOUBLED OUR INVESTMENT IN THE
PAST YEAR AND GROWING IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I I'M I'M HAPPY
TO HEAR THAT BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
HOW CHILDREN HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THEIR ANCESTRAL HOMES WITH
THE INTENT OF BREAKING THEM FROM
WHAT IS THEIR CULTURE, THEIR
LANGUAGE, THEIR SELF I I'D LIKE
TO BELIEVE AND TRUST AND HOPE
THAT MOVING FORWARD, UM, THAT WE
CAN HONOR THAT INTEGRITY OF
IDENTITY. UM OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND MAKE THAT PART OF
THE INTEGRAL PROCESS OF HEALING
AND FAMILY REUNIFICATION AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. SO I WILL BE
ASKING MORE OF THAT OF OUR
COUNTIES AND TO GET SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON THOSE CULTURAL
BROKERS AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
FUNDED FROM THE STATE. LIKE THE
CASA PROGRAM. THAT KIND OF HELPS
TO FOLLOW THE CHILD IS ANOTHER
WAY FOR US TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILD HAS AN ADVOCATE HAS
SOMEBODY, UM, FROM THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT SEES THROUGH THE
LENS OF THAT CHILD? UM, AND I
KNOW THAT WITH, UH GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM. SOMETIMES WE ARE PUSHING
FORWARD WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WITHIN THE
LAW OF THE DECISIONS WE MAKE.
AND THAT IS LOST IN THE
FRAMEWORK IN THE LENS OF A
CHILD, SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE LEADING WITH THAT
LENS FIRST. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS, SENATOR BEJAR. OK
GREAT. UH, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. UM WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO OUR, UH TO THE ZOOM AGAIN.
UM, WE HAVE SOPHIA GEOFF, WHO
WAS ONE OF OUR LIVED EXPERTS WHO
WAS HERE JOINING US TODAY. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY. UH,
SOPHIA, I'M EXCITED ABOUT YOUR
PRESENTATION, UH, HIGHLIGHTING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION. UM
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR OUR FOSTER
YOUTH, SO PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
UM, FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY.
UM LIKE YOU SAID, MY NAME IS
SOPHIA AND I AM A YOUTH
AMBASSADOR FOR THE CHILD FAMILY
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY I AM THE FOSTER
YOUTH SERVICES COORDINATOR FOR U
, èC SANTA BARBARA AND HAVE
BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR THE CHILD
FOR CHILD WELFARE REFORM. UM,
SINCE MY ENTRY INTO THE SYSTEM
IN 2014 AND SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY JOURNEY AND MY TIME IN
FOSTER CARE WAS CHARACTERIZED BY
CONGREGATE AND SHELTER. CARE UM,
WHERE I FOUND MYSELF LIVING
AMONG 40 TO 50 OTHER FOSTER
YOUTH, LACKING THE FAMILIAL
CONNECTIONS AND RESOURCES THAT
COULD HAVE PROVIDED THE
STABILITY THAT I NEEDED DURING
MY FORMATIVE YEARS, GIVEN MY AGE
, HEALTH PROFILE AND A GENERAL
LACK OF COMPATIBLE RESOURCE
FAMILIES AVAILABLE IN MY COUNTY,
I SPENT 18 MONTHS LIVING IN AN
EMERGENCY CHILDREN. INTENDED FOR
30 DAYS OR LESS LIVING IN
CONGREGATE CARE MEANT FACING
INSTABILITY AND DISCONNECTION
FROM MY FORMER LIFE ON A DAILY
BASIS. WELL THE STAFF WERE WELL
INTENTIONED. THEY OFTEN STRUGGLE
TO MEET OUR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
AMIDST HIGH TURNOVER AND CHRONIC
UNDERSTAFFING. I REGULARLY MISS
SCHOOL MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS,
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM MEETINGS,
COURT APPOINTMENTS AND MORE DUE
TO INSUFFICIENT VEHICLES OR
STAFF TO ATTEND TO EVERY USE
NEEDS THAT DAY. SIMILARLY MY
HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE LACKED
NORMAL ENRICHMENT AND
SOCIALIZATION. PARTICIPATION IN
SCHOOL ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
FOOTBALL GAMES, SCHOOL DANCES,
TUTORING SESSIONS. CLUB MEETINGS
AND MORE REQUIRED EXPLICIT
PERMISSION FROM MY SOCIAL
WORKER, WHICH WAS OFTEN
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN. ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET AND TECHNOLOGY FOR
COMPLETING BASIC HOMEWORK
ASSIGNMENTS WAS SEVERELY LIMITED
. I HAD NÓ CONTROL OVER MY DIET,
MEALTIME OR ACCESS TO FOOD, WELL
, SEEMINGLY MINOR. INDIVIDUALLY
THESE EXPERIENCES WERE ABNORMAL
FOR A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED MY
ABILITY TO ADAPT AFTER BEING
REMOVED FROM MY HOME. AS A TYPE
ONE DIABETIC AND HEAVILY
INSTITUTIONALIZED ENVIRONMENT. I
WAS SHOCKED BY THE LACK OF STAFF
TRAINING IN MANAGING DAILY
HEALTHCARE NEEDS AFTER SEVERAL
MEDICAL MISHAPS IN MY
RESIDENTIAL COTTAGE, IT WAS
DECIDED BY THE CAMPUS DOCTOR
THAT I WOULD RECEIVE DAILY
MEDICAL CARE AT THE CENTER,
WHICH FURTHER DIMINISHED MY
SENSE OF AUTONOMY AND NORMALCY.
HELP. MANAGEMENT WAS JUST ONE
ASPECT OF MY LIFE IMPACTED BY
THE ABSENCE OF KI¾M. BEING
PLACED IN FOSTER CARE. JUST
BEFORE STARTING HIGH SCHOOL. I
LACKED THE RESOURCES AND
GUIDANCE NEEDED TO THRIVE
ACADEMICALLY, SOCIALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY. A STABLE HOUSEHOLD
WITH A SUPPORTIVE FAMILY MEMBER
WOULD HAVE BEEN INVALUABLE TO ME
DURING THIS TIME. AS MY FAMILIAL
NETWORK DWINDLED OVER THE YEARS,
SO DID MY PARENTS SUPPORT SYSTEM
. THE ABSENCE OF A LARGE SUPPORT
NETWORK HINDERED MY PARENTS'
ABILITY TO CARE FOR ME AND
LIMITED MY POTENTIAL KINSHIP
OPTIONS DESPITE HAVING A FEW
BIOLOGICAL RELATIVES IN VARIOUS
CALIFORNIA LOCATIONS THEY WERE
DEEMED UNSUITABLE DUE TO DCFS
HESITANCY TO RELOCATE ME FROM MY
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN, WHICH
ULTIMATELY OCCURRED REGARDLESS
DURING MY TIME IN CARE. THIS WAS
ESPECIALLY DISHEARTENING AS
NOBODY ASKED ME HOW I FELT ABOUT
MY KINSHIP PLACEMENTS. DESPITE
MY YOUNG AGE, I BELIEVE THAT MY
VOICE SHOULD HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF PLACEMENT
DISCUSSIONS. I THINK THAT
FACTORS SUCH AS STREAMLINING THE
APPROVAL AND LICENSING PROCESS,
PROVIDING LEGAL TRAINING AND
SUPPORT ON KINSHIP RIGHTS AND
OFFERING FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
ARE KEY COMPONENTS THAT COULD
HAVE EXPANDED MY KINSHIP
PLACEMENT OPTIONS, ADDITIONALLY,
PLACEMENT OPTIONS, ADDITIONALLY,ó-RECOGNIZING NONBIOLOGICAL KIN
AND FAMILY SUPPORT AS VIABLE
OPTIONS IN THE EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF KINSHIP,
CAREGIVERS COULD HAVE BROUGHT
FORTH. UH MANY MORE SUITABLE
PLACEMENT OPTIONS AND ULTIMATELY
SPARED ME THE EXPERIENCE OF
BEING IN AN INSTITUTIONAL
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE MAJORITY OF
HIGH SCHOOL. UM YOU KNOW, AS I,
UM REFLECT ON UM MY EXPERIENCE
AND I'M WORKING IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ADMISSIONS NOW, UM
, YOU KNOW, I SEE A LOT. HOW, UM
HOW EDUCATION AND, UM, JUST THE
PIPELINE TO COLLEGE BEGAN SO
EARLY, OFTENTIMES, AND YOUR
TRAJECTORY AND YOU KNOW, MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, UM
, IS INDICATIVE OF, UM. OF THE
KINDS OF, UM, STABILITY YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE EDUCATIONALLY IN HIGH
SCHOOL, AND I BELIEVE THAT, UM
YEAH, THAT MY ENVIRONMENT IN
CONGREGATE CARE REALLY? UM,
SERVED AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO ME
TRYING TO OBTAIN A DEGREE, UM,
AND WORK THROUGH THOSE HIGHER
EDUCATION CHALLENGES AS A FORM
OF PHILOSOPHY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO MAY I ASK WHERE WHERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS CONSIDERED HOME
FOR YOU. I LIVE IN SANTA BARBARA
. NOW UM, BUT I, UM, WAS PLACED
IN CARE IN VENTURA COUNTY. UM
BUT HAVE FLIPPED ALL OVER. YES I
CAN IMAGINE, I IMAGINE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR
JOURNEY AND FOR CONTINUING TO
GIVE BACK IN THE WORK THAT YOU
DO, UM, WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP TO
QUESTIONS AND THEN I'LL INVITE,
UM, OUR NEXT SPEAKER UP SENATOR
MEAR CORRECT, SOPHIA. I JUST
WANTED TO CHECK IN WITH YOU
BEFORE WE SAY GOODBYE AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US VIA
ZOOM. UM, YOU HAD MENTIONED
SEVERAL, UH. SEVERAL FACTORS IN
WHAT COULD HAVE WORKED BETTER
FOR YOU, UM AND THAT YOU WERE
NOT IN INCLUDED OR ASKED IN
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT WOULD HAVE
WORKED BETTER FOR YOU? UM DO YOU
THINK THAT THERE IS A MIDDLE
GROUND WHERE WE HAVE ADULTS?
THAT KIND OF MAKE DECISIONS FOR
OUR YOUTH, BUT ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR YOUTH TO
HAVE A VOICE IN, UH HOW THOSE
DECISIONS AFFECT THEM. AND WHAT
WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE? YEAH
DEFINITELY. UM I. I DO THINK, UM
, YOU KNOW, OFTENTIMES IN CARE,
UM OR AT LEAST FOR YOU KNOW,
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY DYNAMIC. UM
THERE WERE PROBABLY SOME THINGS
THAT, UM DIDN'T. SOME I GUESS
FAMILY FACTOR IS JUST, YOU KNOW,
SOCIO ECONOMIC FACTORS AND, YOU
KNOW, LIFESTYLE CHOICES. THINGS
LIKE THAT. THAT ONE I MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN PRIVY TO. AS YOU KNOW,
A 1314 YEAR OLD BEING, UM,
PLACED IN CARE. UM BUT I DO. I
DO THINK THAT THERE COULD HAVE
BEEN, UM I THINK IN GENERAL,
THERE CAN BE MORE OF A I GUESS
LIKE A AN ONGOING DISCUSSION. UM
JUST ABOUT, UH, YOU KNOW WHAT
THOSE KINSHIP PLACEMENTS WOULD
LOOK LIKE LIKE I KNOW. UM YEAH,
FOR MYSELF A BIG FACTOR IN, UM
YOU KNOW, MY REMOVAL FROM MY
HOME WAS, UM IT WAS A NEGLECT
CASE, AND A LOT OF THAT WAS
HEAVILY TIED. UM TO POVERTY, AND
, UM, THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT,
UM, WAS NOT LIMITED TO JUST YOU
KNOW, MY MOTHER AND ALSO IN FACT
, IN HER FAMILY AS WELL, AND I
DON'T KNOW IF, UM, RESOURCES
THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED BY THE
STATE WOULD BE, UM, EVEN YOU
KNOW, VIABLE ENOUGH TO, UM,
ACCOMMODATE THOSE, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF GAPS AND HOLES. UM SO I
DO THINK THAT YEAH. I. I AGREE
THAT AN ADULT SHOULD BE, UM AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THOSE
DISCUSSION OR SHOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, ULTIMATELY DELEGATED TO,
UM, KIND OF. STREAMLINE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. UM, BUT I DO
THINK THAT UM, YOU KNOW, JUST AS
YOU I THINK I HAD A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT MY FAMILY
CONTACTS THAT OTHER PEOPLE
DIDN'T. UM, I THINK THAT, UM
YEAH, I THINK THAT THERE WERE
JUST A LOT OF FACTORS. UM EVEN
AS SOMEONE YOU KNOW WHO WAS
REUNIFIED, AND I'M INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE BEEN REUNIFIED
WITH MY BIOLOGICAL FAMILY. I
THINK THAT, UM YOU KNOW, AS A
YOUTH AT THE TIME, THERE WERE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO WITHHOLD
SO THAT I COULD EXUDATE THE
PROCESS OF GETTING HOME AND YOU
KNOW, IN MY, UM ADULT YEARS, I'M
TOTALLY REGRETFUL OF THAT, JUST
LIKE KIND OF SWEEPING ISSUES
UNDER THE RUG AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, SO I DEFINITELY THINK, UM,
SORRY IF Tð VÆ QUESTION. UM BUT
I DEFINITELY THINK THAT, UM YEAH
, IT'S NOT JUST THE YOUTH VOICE.
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE MY
PRIORITIES WERE PROBABLY A
LITTLE SKEWED AT THE TIME, YOU
KNOW, NOT ALWAYS FOCUSED ON MY
WELL BEING, AND JUST KIND OF
ESCAPING THAT ENVIRONMENT THAT I
DIDN'T ENJOY. RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THAT HONESTY. UM THE OTHER
ASPECT OF WHAT? WHAT WE'VE DONE
HERE, UM THE LEGISLATURE AS
WE'VE PUT A LOT OF ENERGY, A LOT
OF RESOURCES TOWARDS ENSURING
THAT OUR FOSTER YOUTH IS
SUCCESSFUL IN IN ORDER TO ACCESS
HIGHER EDUCATION, UM, WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH THROUGH GRANTS,
SCHOLARSHIPS, OR, UM, THAT THAT
TRANSITIONAL BRIDGE SUPPORT. HOW
HOW HAS THAT EXPERIENCE FOR YOU
PLAYED OUT AND NOW THAT YOU ARE,
UH IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND
LOOKING AT AT COUNSELING AND
ADMISSIONS, WHERE CAN WE DO
MORE? AND WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN
THAT HAS IMPROVED? YEAH UM, I AM
GLAD THAT YOU ASKED THAT, UM SO
AS A UM FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHO
EXITED CARE JUST ABOUT TWO
MONTHS BEFORE, UM OR I BEGAN THE
FAMILY REUNIFICATION PROCESS.
UM, ABOUT TWO MONTHS BEFORE I
TURNED 15 IN MY CASE WAS CLOSED
ABOUT A WEEK BEFORE MY 16TH
BIRTHDAY. UM, I. UM DON'T I
DIDN'T RECEIVE A LOT OF THE, UM
SOME OF THE BENEFITS THAT ARE,
UM ASSOCIATED WITH, UM
PROSTITUTE IN HIGHER EDUCATION,
SUCH AS LIKE THE CHAFEE GRANT.
UM BUT ONE FINANCIAL RESOURCE
THAT WAS, UM INCREDIBLY HELPFUL
WAS, UM I MEAN, JUST FINANCIAL
AID AS A WHOLE BEING ABLE TO, UM
, REPORT MYSELF AS AN
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE THAT ALSO
WAS KIND OF, UM, MY REALITY IS I
MOVED OUT OF MY LIKE ACTUAL HOME
, UM, AT 16.5 AND MOVED INTO,
UH, MY FRIEND'S HOUSE FOR THE
REMAINDER OF HIGH SCHOOL. UM WAS
ABLE TO RECEIVE BENEFITS LIKE MY
OWN HEALTH INSURANCE. UM I WAS
ABLE, UM, YEAH, TO GET YOU KNOW,
STRONG BENEFITS IN TERMS OF CALL
FRESH THINGS LIKE THAT, UM, IN
MY FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE LOOKED
REALLY GOOD. UM ONCE I GOT INTO
THE U èC SYSTEM, UM, BUT MY
PATH WAS A LITTLE WONKY BECAUSE
I ATTEMPTED A UNIVERSITY. MY
FRESHMAN YEAR THAT I WANTED TO
BE A NURSE. THEN I WENT TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THAT YEAR,
UM, THAT I WAS IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. IT WAS INCREDIBLY HARD,
BECAUSE THE COST OF ATTENDANCE,
UM FOR FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES IN
GENERAL, UM, YOU KNOW IS, UM, IT
INCLUDES, UM, FACT IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE FACTORS SUCH AS HOUSING
WHEN YOU'RE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, AND SO, UM, YOU KNOW,
THERE WERE DEFINITELY TIMES
WHERE I REALLY, REALLY STRUGGLED
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. UM BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES. UM, YOU KNOW TO THE
BUDGET. 2022 THAT HAVE BEEN
AMAZING, UM, FOR OUR FOSTER USE
SERVICES PROGRAM, UM, ONE THING
THAT HAS MADE A HUGE IMPACT FOR
OUR STUDENTS IS, UM THE, UM. THE
REVISION TO THE, UM. SELF HELP,
UM, CONTRIBUTION. SO UM, PRIOR
TO THIS YEAR, THERE WAS, UM AN
EXPECTATION THAT FOSTER YOUTH
WOULD CONTRIBUTE. UM I BELIEVE
IT WAS 7000 OR $8000 ANNUALLY TO
THEIR TUITION. UM WHICH I CAN
SAY I HAD NÓ MEANS TO DO, UH, AS
A FOSTER YOU GOING THROUGH, UM,
COLLEGE AND SO IT DEFINITELY
IMPACTS YOUR AWARD AND THAT YOU
GET FOR FINANCIAL AID AND JUST
BEING ABLE TO, UM KIND OF
NAVIGATE THROUGH ALL OF THOSE
COSTS. UM I AM REALLY GRATEFUL
TO SEE PROGRAMS FUNDED, UM LIKE
BASIC NEEDS. AND UM GUARDIAN
SCHOLARS PROGRAMS. EVERYONE KIND
OF HAS A DIFFERENT NAME FOR IT.
BUT UM, WE HAVE BEEN REALLY
FORTUNATE, UM, WITH STATE
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO HELP
MITIGATE SOME OF THOSE IN
BETWEEN COSTS LIKE CHILDCARE, UM
, YOU KNOW, WISDOM, TEETH,
REMOVAL THINGS THAT JUST, UM
KIND OF COME UP IN BETWEEN. UM,
BUT I DO WISH THAT, UM WE WERE
ABLE TO DO A LITTLE BIT MORE FOR
SOME OF OUR STUDENTS THAT DON'T,
UM, FALL DO SOME OF THE AGE
REQUIREMENTS OR MAYBE HAD LESS
FORMAL INTRODUCTIONS OR, UH
INTO, YOU KNOW THE SYSTEM THINGS
LIKE THAT. THANK YOU AGAIN,
SOPHIA. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
. WE ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
REMAINDER OF OUR PANEL. WE ARE
EXPLORING PREVENTION AND LOOKING
FORWARD. WE HAVE FOUR MORE
SPEAKERS. I'D LIKE TO INVITE
ANNA GENNARI, DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGY AND OPERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION TO
COME FORWARD. LETICIA GALLO,
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM
SENECA FAMILY AGENCIES, LESLIE
HAMO. UM J, HE. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA, AND CINDY
KINE, PARENT SUPPORT COORDINATOR
FROM CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER. WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH MS JURI.
UM, I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE HERE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT, WE WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT PROMPTLY AT
1245. SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. UM AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
MRI WHEN YOU'RE READY. YES
EXCUSE ME, HØI. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ANNA SNARE. I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGY AND
OPERATIONS WITH CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION. AND FIRST I WANNA
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU TO THE
SENATORS AND THE AMAZING
PANELISTS BEFORE AND I KNOW SOME
COMING AFTER ME. UM IT IS
DEFINITELY AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
UH I ALSO WANNA SAY THAT I'M I'M
REALLY HERE, REPRESENTING
HUNDREDS OF èC Y èC MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FROM L A TO HUMBOLDT TO CENTRAL
VALLEY BAY AREA IN BETWEEN. WE
ARE STRONG AND REPRESENTED
ACROSS THE STATE. AND I ALSO
STAND WITH MY OWN LEGACY AND
EXPERIENCE AS SOMEONE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WHO AGED OUT OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WAS
GIVEN A SHOT AT 18 TO BE A PART
OF A YOUTH LED MOVEMENT. WHICH
IS REALLY TRULY SET THE
FOUNDATION AND MY ABILITY TO SIT
HERE AND SPEAK ON THE PANEL
TODAY. FOR OVER 30 YEARS,
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION HAS
BEEN THE LARGEST FOSTER USE LED
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY AND
CONTINUES TO BE A LEADER OF
GRASSROOTS AND STATEWIDE SYSTEMS
CHANGE, LED BY PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE THAT NÓ DIRECTLY THE
IMPACT OF THESE POLICIES. WE'VE
ALSO WORKED REALLY CLOSELY. WITH
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE ON A NUMBER OF KEY
CHANGES THAT, UM WE'RE SUPER
GRATEFUL FOR SO OVER TIME. WE
HAVE WORKED TO CREATE THE FIRST
FOSTER USE BILL OF RIGHTS,
MAINTAINING SIBLING CONNECTIONS
WITH THE SYSTEM. INCREASING
PLACEMENT STABILITY IN 2018 AND
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE REDUCTION OF CONGREGATE CARE
THROUGH èC, èC, R AND OTHER
RELATED CONVERSATIONS. IN RECENT
YEARS. UM èC Y èC S¼ FEEL THE
HEEL WHICH YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF
, AND OUR SYSTEMS.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL CAMPAIGNS
HAVE AMPLIFIED THE CONTINUED
NEED. EXCUSE ME FOR ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LIFELONG CONNECTIONS. SAFE AND
AFFIRMING PLACES TO CALL HOME.
ACCESS TO HOUSING, EDUCATION
QUALITY, HOLISTIC HEALTH CARE AS
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS. BECAUSE
EXPERTS HERE WE ALL KNOW RIGHT.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS CLEARLY THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE'S DEVELOPMENT IS
DEPENDENT. ON THESE PILLARS, NOT
EXTRA OR OUTSIDE OF WHAT IS
TRULY DEPENDENT UPON ALL OF
WHICH WE'RE WE'RE FIGHTING FOR.
WE KNOW THESE AS PROTECTIVE AND
PROMOTIVE FACTORS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE NOT ONLY TO SURVIVE BUT
TO THRIVE, HOWEVER, WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE REMOVED FROM THEIR
HOME, AS WAS SAID EARLIER THERE
ARE REMOVED FROM THEIR CULTURE.
THE COMMUNITY. THESE CONNECTIONS
ARE DISRUPTED, UM, AND ASSIST
THEM WELL INTENDED AND
RESPONSIBLE TO CARE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN OFTENTIMES CREATE
BARRIERS TO THESE VERY THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY PROTECT AND
DEVELOP THEM. SO UM, THIS IS WHY
HUNDREDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE AT èC
Y èC HAVE BEEN WORKING OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS ALONGSIDE GREAT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE YOUTH LAW
CENTER WHO YOU HEARD FROM BEFORE
, UM, ON A VISIONARY, FUTURE
FORWARD APPROACH TO TRANSFORMING
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. AND SO I'M
SURE THIS WAS TALKED ABOUT BUT
REALLY ELEVATING, MOVING BEYOND
TRADITIONAL SERVICES TO MORE OF
A GUARANTEED BASIC HOUSING THAT
SUPPORTS COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES
AND FAMILIES STAYING REPORTING
TOGETHER A NETWORKS OF MUTUAL
AID OF CARE AND CONNECTION. UM
THINGS THAT WE ALL NEED AND
DESERVE, YOU KNOW, AT AND AS A
PART OF OUR STATE WAY WORK. èC
èC MEMBERS HAVE ALSO BEEN
RALLYING AROUND INCREASING
ACCESS TO ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES,
SOMETHING THAT WAS JUST SHARED
BEFORE RIGHT ACCESS TO FOOTBALL
GAMES. DANCES UM, THESE
ACTIVITIES THAT ALL YOUNG PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO AND ARE
AGAIN NOT EXTRA, BUT FUNDAMENTAL
TO OUR IDENTITY WHO WE ARE AND
WHO WILL BECOME AND THERE REALLY
ARE A DIRECT PATHWAY TO YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. WE'VE BEEN GRATEFUL
TO PARTNER WITH èC Dð S¼ S¼ ON
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THE FOSTER
YOUTH ENRICHMENT PILOT PROGRAM
IN MANY COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE. IT'S A PROGRAM THAT
REMOVES BARRIERS BY PROVIDING
CRITICAL FUNDING THAT CAN BE
USED TO ENSURE EVEN GREATER
ACCESS TO THESE ACTIVITIES. UM
BUT THERE'S DEFINITELY STILL
WORK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
UNFOLDING IN THAT AREA. WE KNOW
THAT, UM ACCESS TO THESE
ACTIVITIES IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO DO. BUT WE FOUND THAT
THE BARRIER IS OFTENTIMES
FUNDING FINANCES, THINGS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION. BEING ABLE TO
ACTUALLY FULFILL THAT
OBLIGATION. AND OTHER THINGS
THAT. WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE AMPLIFY. WE KNOW THAT AS
WE'RE YOU'RE MAKING CRITICAL
DECISIONS. UH, WITH REGARDS TO
THE BUDGET, WE'RE REALLY ASKING
THAT YOU CONTINUE CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE THESE SUPPORTS AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SEE ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES NOT AS EXTRA BUT AS
CRITICAL. THEY ARE NOT
INCENTIVES FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR TO
BE TAKEN OR GIVEN AWAY AS
PUNISHMENT. BUT I BUT RATHER
FUNDAMENTAL DRIVERS TOWARDS OUR
SHARED MISSION FOR POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
DEFINITELY A WORTHWHILE
INVESTMENT. WE ALSO OUR MEMBERS
ARE ACROSS THE STATE FIGHTING
FOR AND WANTING TO MAINTAIN AND
KEEP THE SOAP. UH, THE HIGHER
SILK PAYMENT, UM, TO MAINTAIN
THE FIRST PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
THE HOUSING NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. HAS
CRITICAL RESOURCES, UM, THAT
SUPPORT THEIR EVERYDAY NEEDS. UH
SO YOU KNOW, I SAY THIS AND I
KNOW YOU'VE HEARD IT, BUT IT'S I
TALKED ABOUT MY OWN PERSONAL
LIVED EXPERIENCE THAT BEING A
PART OF THESE COMMUNITY
OPPORTUNITIES AGAIN WASN'T
EXTRA. IT IS STILL ON MY RESUME.
I HAVE A I HAVE ON MY RESUME AN
OPPORTUNITY FROM A YOUTH LED, OR
YOU KNOW THAT I GOT INVOLVED IN
18 STILL TO THIS DAY THAT THAT
SUPPORTS ME IN ALL OF THE THINGS
GOING FORWARD, AND I SEE THIS IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR èC Y
èC MEMBERS, UM FROM THE FIRST
MEETING THEY WALK INTO IN A èC
Y èC SPACE TO LEADING STATEWIDE
CAMPAIGNS TO FACILITATING
FACILITATING NATIONAL EVENTS.
WHICH IS WHY THEY'RE NOT HERE.
THEY'RE ACROSS THE STREET
LEADING PANELS AND LEADING THE
CHARGE FOR AN EVEN GREATER
FUTURE TO RUNNING FOR ASSEMBLY,
GRADUATING COLLEGE BUILDING
CAREERS AND FAMILIES AND EVEN
CONTINUOUS CONTINUING THEIR
LEGACY IN THIS ROOM RIGHT NOW.
SO WE ASK THAT YOU CAN YOU
CONTINUE TO HEAR, UM THE
PRIORITIES OF OUR MEMBERS AND
INVEST IN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. UM
WE KNOW INVESTING IN OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IS A DIRECT INVESTMENT IN
OUR COMMUNITY, AND WE'RE JUST
REALLY EXCITED TO CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH YOU ALL. UM AS
YOU'RE KIND OF IF YOU'RE MOVING
FORWARD IN CREATING CHANGE AND
WITH THE REST OF THE PALACE, SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
WILL CONTINUE WITH MS YANG.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
LETITIA GALLON. I'M THE èC E Ó
OF SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES TO
GIVE A LITTLE CONTEXT. SENECA IS
A LARGE HUMAN SERVICES AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVING CHILDREN,
YOUTH, YOUNG ADULTS AND FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IN 18
COUNTIES, AS WELL AS THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON. WE IMPACT OVER
40,000 INDIVIDUALS ANNUALLY
SERVING YOUTH INVOLVED IN CHILD
WELFARE, JUVENILE JUSTICE,
EDUCATION AND YOUTH AT RISK OF
ENTRY INTO CARE AS WELL. WERE
FOUNDED IN 1985 WITH A SINGULAR
VISION, AND THAT'S STILL DEFINES
OUR IDENTITY TO THIS DAY. WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE? WHAT SOLUTIONS
COULD EMERGE WHAT OUTCOMES AND
TRAJECTORIES COULD BE SHIFTED?
IF WE SIMPLY SAID THERE IS
NOTHING YOU COULD DO IN THIS
PLACEMENT IN THIS HOME IN THIS
RELATIONSHIP THAT WOULD LEAD YOU
TO BE DISCHARGED FROM OUR
SERVICES? AND THIS FOUNDING
COMMITMENT TO STAY WITH CHILDREN
THROUGH WHATEVER IT TAKES, AND
WHATEVER COMES THEIR WAY, BECAME
KNOWN AS OUR UNCONDITIONAL CARE
MODEL. AND AT THE HEART OF
UNCONDITIONAL CARE IS THAT IDEA
THAT WE WILL DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO HELP OUR YOUTH AND
FAMILIES THRIVE. AND THAT'S A
BOLD STATEMENT. BUT IT'S WHAT'S
NECESSARY AND IT'S WHAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE DESERVE. AND AS
WE'VE GROWN IT'S BEEN IMPORTANT
TO BUILD THAT SAME COMMITMENT
INTO THE SERVICES AND THE WORK
THAT WE DO ACROSS THE CONTINUUM
OF PROGRAMMING THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED. AND WE KNOW THAT TO
BE MOST EFFECTIVE. FOR THEIR
DYNAMIC, CHANGING AND COMPLEX
NEEDS OF OUR YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WE MU. WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE CONTINUUM MUST INCLUDE
AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PREVENTION, EARLY INTERVENTION,
STABILIZATION AND HIGH INTENSITY
SUPPORTS. NOT ONLY ARE EACH OF
THESE COMPONENTS NECESSARY, BUT
TO FULLY REALIZE THE VISION TO
MATCH NEEDS WITH AVAILABLE
SERVICES WE MUST CREATE AND
INVEST IN EXCESS. AND FLEXIBLE
CAPACITY SO THAT THE
CONVERSATION CAN SHIFT FROM WHAT
DO WE HAVE TO OFFER TO? WHAT DO
YOU NEED TO BEST SUPPORT YOU?
AND YET CHALLENGES PERSIST. TO
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL. SO, GIVEN OUR
EXPERIENCE AS A STATEWIDE CHILD
WELFARE PROVIDER, I'D LIKE TO
OFFER A FEW SOLUTIONS. FIRST AS
WAS THE INTENTION OF èC R
CONTINUUM CARE REFORM. WE MUST
FOCUS ON CENTERED, FAMILY
CENTERED CARE SPECIFICALLY, WE
NEED TO INVEST IN RELATIVE AND
KIN CAREGIVERS AS MUCH AS WE
INVEST IN NON-RELATIVE CARE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN AS WE'VE
ALL DISCUSSED ALREADY OUR BEST
WHEN THEY REMAIN WITH FAMILY
WITH EXTENDED FAMILY WITH KIN
AND OTHER PERMANENT CAREGIVERS
AND YET SUPPORTS AND RESOURCES
FOR KIN CARE GIVERS WHO OBTAIN
GUARDIANSHIP OF A CHILD. SIDE OF
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM ARE A
FRACTION OF THE SUPPORTS
EXTENDED TO NON-RELATIVE
RESOURCE FAMILIES. TO GIVE YOU A
REALLY CONCRETE EXAMPLE. WE HAVE
A SENECA EMPLOYEE IN ONE OF OUR
PROGRAMS. UH, WHO BECAME THE
PERMANENT CAREGIVER FOR THREE OF
HER GRANDCHILDREN AND THAT
PREVENTED THEM FROM ENTERING THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AND EVEN
THOUGH SHE WAS INCREDIBLY WELL
VERSED IN THE FOSTER CARE AND
ADOPTION SYSTEMS HERSELF, SHE
STILL FOUND THE PROCESS OF
GUARDIANSHIP, INCREDIBLY
CONFUSING AND OVERWHELMING. WHEN
SHE CONNECTED TO HER OWN FAMILY
TIES PROGRAM. SHE WAS ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THE GUARDIANSHIP
PROCESS AND WITH MORE EASE AND
ACCESS FINANCIAL SUPPORT. AND
WHILE THE ASSISTANT FROM CAL
WORKS WAS VALUABLE, IT WAS ONLY
$400 A MONTH. WHICH IS LESS THAN
ONE THIRD OF THE BENEFITS SHE
COULD HAVE RECEIVED IF HER
GRANDCHILDREN WERE IN FOSTER
CARE, WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN
AROUND $1225 A MONTH.
ADDITIONALLY THE SAME YOUTH ARE
NOT ENTITLED TO THE OTHER
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN IF THEY WERE
INFORMAL FOSTER CARE, INCLUDING
SERVICES LIKE ENHANCED CARE
MANAGEMENT AND SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. SO INDEED IF WE
WANT TO INCREASE KIN AND
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS AND REDUCE
ENTRIES INTO FORMAL FOSTER CARE,
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR KIN GAP
SHOULD BE DECOUPLED FROM FORMAL
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT, AND
WE MUST CAPITALIZE ON THE
FINANCIAL OPPORTUNITIES OF THE
FAMILY'S FIRST PREVENTION AND
SERVICES ACT TO HELP REDIRECT
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS. SECOND AS A SYSTEM
WE MUST COMMIT TO MITIGATING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT
SERVICE PROVIDERS FACE. WE FACE
NUMEROUS CHALLENGES THAT
COMPLICATE DELAY AND DISCOURAGE
FURTHER GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
OF INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING. FOR
EXAMPLE, GETTING LICENSED TO BE
A CARE PROVIDER, THEN GETTING
APPROVAL TO BILL FOR EARLY
PERIODIC SCREENING, DIAGNOSTIC
AND TREATMENT SERVICES AND THEN
HAVING TO CONTRACT WITH EACH OF
OUR COUNTIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO
DO THOSE THINGS IS VERY
CHALLENGING AND TIME CONSUMING
THE PROCESS WE'VE CREATED AS A
SYSTEM TO STAND UP CREATIVE,
INNOVATIVE AND CHILD SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA IS VERY
BURDENSOME AND CAN EASILY TAKE
OVER A YEAR. FOR EXAMPLE, WE
OPERATE BOTH STAFFED AND
CAREGIVING MODELS. BOTH HAVE
INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
YOUTH RECEIVES THE INTENSIVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HEALTH
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND THAT
WE CAN LEVERAGE AS MUCH FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION AS WE
CAN. AND YET THESE TWO
ACTIVITIES LICENSURE THROUGH èC
èC AND MEDICAL CERTIFICATION
THROUGH DHCS AND THEN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS IS
COMPLETELY SEPARATE. OFTEN ON
SEPARATE TIMELINES, BUT ALSO AT
CERTAIN POINTS DEPENDENT UPON
EACH OTHER. WE MUST MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PROVIDERS WHO WANT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THAT ONE
HALF OF 1% OF YOUTH WITH THE
MOST COMPLEX NEEDS TO DO SO. AND
THIS IS NOT TO SAY THAT WE
SHOULD, UH, YOU KNOW, CHANGE OUR
STANDARDS OR OR SHIFT OUR
QUALITY CONTROLS, BUT THAT THE
STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
MINIMIZE SELF IMPOSED
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS TO
LICENSING AND OPENING MUCH
NEEDED INTENSIVE PROGRAMS FOR
YOUTH WITH COMPLEX NEEDS. THIRD.
WE NEED EFFECTIVE SYSTEMS OF
CARE WITH MULTISYSTEM
INTEGRATION BY HIM AND SHARED
OWNERSHIP AND YOU'VE HEARD A BIT
ABOUT THIS ALREADY. BUT IT'S
CRITICAL THAT ALL KEY
STAKEHOLDERS ARE AT THE TABLE
AND WERE ALIGNED IN WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE. AND YET, SO
RARELY DO WE HAVE CHILD WELFARE,
JUVENILE JUSTICE, EDUCATION AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ALL AT
THE TABLE TOGETHER AND I HAVE
NOT EXPERIENCED 2083 TO CREATE
THIS INTEGRATION YET FOR US
THERE MUST ALSO BE FINANCIAL
SHARED RISK IN THIS AS WELL TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT A SYSTEM THAT
IS PREPARED TO RESPOND WITH
PREVENTION SERVICES AND THE
HIGHEST ACUITY INTERVENTIONS. IT
REQUIRES A SHIFT FROM A
FRAMEWORK OF SCARCITY AND
RESTRICTION TO OF TRUST AND
INVESTMENT. SENECA'S ONLY ABLE
TO BE EFFECTIVE IN REGIONS AND
IN PARTNERSHIPS THAT SEEK TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION. HERE'S WHAT
OUR COMMUNITIES NEED. AND HOW
CAN WE PARTNER TO MEET THIS NEED
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT CAN YOU DO
WITH THESE VERY FANS. AND WE
MUST CREATE THE CONTEXT FOR BEST
PRACTICES AND INNOVATION TO BE
REPLICATED. WE ARE RUNNING SOME
OF THE MOST INNOVATIVE AND
INTENSIVE PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY THROUGH
ENHANCED INTENSIVE SERVICES,
FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS AND
ENHANCED SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. BUT WE ARE
VERY LIMITED IN THE LOCATIONS
THAT WE CAN CREATE THOSE
PROGRAMS. REALLY HAMPERED BY
THOSE THINGS THAT I HAVE ALREADY
SHARED, UH AND WHEN WE HAVE A
COUNTY PARTNERSHIP SHARED RISK
ADEQUATE INVESTMENT IN AMPLE
CAPACITY WERE ABLE TO HAVE A
TRANSFORMATIVE IMPACT. AND
FINALLY WE NEED FLEXIBILITY IN
OUR CONTINUUM TO AVOID
BOTTLENECKS AND OR OVER
UTILIZATION OF THE SERVICES THAT
WE HAVE ALREADY NÓ SINGLE
PROGRAM OR SERVICE LEVEL CAN BE
EFFECTIVE AS A STAND ALONE
OPPORTUNITY, AND WHEN WE SEE
REGIONS THE LOWER CAPACITY WITH
LESS ROBUST CONTINUUM, WE OFTEN
SEE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
OVERSTAYS AND INAPPROPRIATE USE
OF UNLICENSED CARE. SO AS A
SYSTEM WE MUST BE WILLING TO
INVEST. AND DEVELOPING CAPACITY
ACROSS SEVERAL SERVICE TYPES AND
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORTS SO THAT NÓ
YOU WILL GET CAUGHT IN ANY ONE
PART OF THE SYSTEM. THIS SHOULD
INCLUDE MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES,
LIKE FIRST DIFFERENTIAL RESPONSE
AND SHORT TERM WRAPAROUND
INTERVENTIONS TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY PLACEMENT
DISRUPTIONS IN HOSPITALIZATIONS.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN FAMILY AND
KIN CAREGIVERS. WE NEED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SHORT TERM
INTENSIVE PLACEMENT OPTIONS TO
PREVENT THE USE OF A NECESSITY
OF UNLICENSED CARE. WE NEED
SUPPORT FOR CAPACITY BUILDING A
FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES. RESOURCE FAMILY
RECRUITMENT, S¼, Tð, R, Tð P
DEVELOPMENT AND ENHANCED MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION. WE NEED
INTENSIVE STEP DOWN SUPPORTS IN
EVERY COUNTY IN EVERY REGION
LIKE SERVICES LIKE WRAPAROUND.
SO IF YOU'VE HEARD ME SHARE
TODAY, THERE'S NOT ONE SOLUTION
THAT WILL HELP US ACHIEVE OUR
VISION IN CALIFORNIA. NOR IS
THERE ONE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE FOR. THIS IS
HIGHLY COMPLEX WITH A
CONSTELLATION OF FACTORS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR, AND
YET IT IS SOLVABLE. THERE ARE
CLEAR SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE. THE
SOLUTIONS NEED TO BE SUPPORTED
TO FLOURISH TO MOVE AWAY FROM
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM, WHERE IT IS
STILL TRUE THAT THE QUALITY AND
AVAILABILITY OF SUPPORTS YOU CAN
RECEIVE IS DEFINED BY YOUR ZIP
CODE AND COUNTY. TO THE SYSTEM.
I BELIEVE WE STRIVE TO CREATE
WHICH IS ONE WHERE NÓ CHILD IS
BROUGHT INTO CHILD WELFARE
UNNECESSARILY, AND WHEN THEY ARE
, THEY'RE MATCHED WITH FAMILIES
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORTS THAT ARE
TARGETED TO MEET THEIR
INDIVIDUALIZED NEEDS AND ARE
HELPED TO EXIT THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM AS QUICKLY AND
THERAPEUTICALLY AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
VERY ELOQUENT PRESENTATION. I'LL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU
AFTERWARDS, BUT WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD TO MS LESLIE HIGH.
DID I PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY?
YOU DID. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US. I'M
LESLIE HEMO, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA. WE
REPRESENT ALL OF THE CHILDREN
INVOLVED IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IN LOS ANGELES,
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTIES.
AND WE HAVE A MULTIDISCIPLINARY
MODEL, WHICH IS UNIQUE AMONGST
CHILD WELFARE OR CHILD WELFARE,
LEGAL SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND THE COUNTRY. BEFORE I
MOVE INTO THE REMARKS I PLANNED
I DO WANT TO TOUCH ON A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT CAME UP EARLIER
IN THE DAY. THE FIRST IS THE
DIRECTOR JOHNSON, UM, AND AGAIN
ON THIS PANEL SPOKE ABOUT
KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER
WHENEVER POSSIBLE, KEEPING
CHILDREN OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT OUR
DEFINITION OF WHENEVER POSSIBLE
IS IN IS TYPICALLY INACCURATE.
UM, WE HAVE HISTORICALLY THOUGHT
ABOUT WHENEVER POSSIBLE WITHIN
THE CURRENT FRAMEWORK, WHICH IS
A SAFETY FIRST FRAMEWORK INSTEAD
OF WHENEVER POSSIBLE, BEING
DEFINED AS WHAT CAN WE DO FOR
THIS FAMILY AND THEIR HOME, AND
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT WE
DON'T DO, UM, THAT WE COULD DO
AND THAT IF WE DID THEM SOONER
AND FASTER AND FROM A COMMUNITY
BASED PERSPECTIVE, WE WOULD
NEVER NEED TO MEET THESE
FAMILIES AND ONE OF THE BEST
SOLUTIONS TO REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN SERVED BY OUR SYSTEM
IS TO NEVER EVER BRING THEM IN.
UM BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT IF WE
KEEP THE SAME OLD RULES ABOUT
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. OTHER THING.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT CAME
UP A COUPLE OF TIMES. FOR ME IN
LISTENING IS THAT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT
SEEK TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THE
FOLKS PRESENTING TODAY HAVE SAID
, IS ASPIRATIONAL IF WE ACTUALLY
ENFORCE THOSE LAWS AND FOLLOW
THOSE LAWS, WE WOULDN'T HAVE
MANY OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE LAWS AUTHORED SOME THAT WE
SPONSORED, AUTHORED BY SOME OF
YOU BY THE SENATOR WHO HAD TO
EXCUSE HERSELF. UM AND YOU ASKED
ONE OF THE YOUTH WHO
PARTICIPATED ABOUT HOW TO FIND
THAT BALANCE BETWEEN YOUTH VOICE
AND ADULT SUPPORT AND ADULT
DECISION MAKING. ACCORDING TO
THE LAW. EVERY CHILD HAS AN
ATTORNEY WHO'S SUPPOSED TO SPEAK
WITH THEM ENOUGH TIMES TO
DEVELOP A TRUSTING RELATIONSHIP,
AND THAT CHILD IS ALSO TO BE
PRESENT AT EVERY SINGLE COURT
HEARING UNLESS THERE'S A REASON
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE THAT AS A
CHILD DRIVEN REASON THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE. THEY HAVE A BIG
TEST THAT DAY. UM, THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE IN COURT BE BE
BECAUSE THEY THEY ARE BARRIERS
TO THEM BEING IN COURT. WE DON'T
ENFORCE THOSE LAWS. UM THEY'RE
NOT ENFORCED BY THE JUDICIARY.
THEY'RE NOT ENFORCED BY
UNFORTUNATELY BY SOME OF THE
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AT CLC, WE TAKE THOSE LAWS VERY
SERIOUSLY, AND WE TRY VERY HARD
TO COMPLY WITH THEM. BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S UNFORTUNATELY
THE CASE ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THERE IS A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF A
NUMBER OF LAWS. WE ALSO HAVE WE
ARE VERY MUCH MINE WAS èC Ó. I
èC ON THEIR CURRENT FOCUS ON
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES. IT'S BEEN
THE LAW FOR 15 YEARS THAT
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES. IT IS NOT ENFORCED,
SO THERE'S A LOT WE COULD DO IF
WE LOOKED AT WHAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AND HELD OUR SYSTEMS, OUR
COURTS AND THE ADVOCACY
COMMUNITY RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
THEY ARE EXPECTED TO DO, AND NOW
I'LL TURN TO PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES AS AN EXAMPLE, UM,
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS PRE
FILING WORK. MEANING THAT
MULTIDISCIPLINARY LEGAL AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
TO A FAMILY WHO MAY BE AT RISK
OF CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT OR
SEPARATION. BEFORE THE CASE IS
FILED. CLC EMBRACED THIS MODEL
DECADES AGO AGO AND ACCORDINGLY
HAVE OFTEN INFORMALLY PROVIDED
OUR TEEN CLIENTS WHO ARE
EXPECTING OR WHO HAVE CHILDREN
WITH AN ARRAY OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. WE HAVE SEEN THE
BENEFIT AND THAT THEY ARE BETTER
PREPARED FOR PARENTING. AS WITH
MANY FIRST ANY FIRST TIME PARENT
, THE MORE WE CAN DO TO REDUCE
THE STRESS AND FEAR ASSOCIATED
WITH BOTH HAVING A BABY AND THEN
BRINGING THAT BABY HOME, THE
BETTER FOR THE PARENTS AND THE
BABY SIGNIFICANTLY WHEN THE
YOUNG PARENT IS ALSO A CURRENT
OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. ALL OF
THE TYPICAL WORRIES ARE
COMPOUNDED BY THE VERY REAL
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE WILL BE
SUBJECTED TO GREATER SCRUTINY
THAN OTHER PARENTS AND THAT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF FAMILY SEPARATION
IS HIGH. JUST OVER TWO YEARS AGO
. THANKS TO PRIVATE FUNDING, WE
WERE ABLE TO FORMALIZE THE FIRST
OF OUR PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO PREVENT FAMILY
SEPARATION AND REMOVAL AND
PREVENT CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT. OUR YOUNG PARENTS
SUPPORT AN ADVOCACY CENTER
STARTED TAKING REFERRALS IN LOS
ANGELES IN 2022. BASED ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM, AND
BECAUSE OF PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT
. WE WERE THEN ABLE TO ADD A
SECOND TEAM, PROVIDING THE SAME
SERVICES TO FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE NOW EXPECTED IN
PARENTING, AND THEY COULD BE ANY
AGE. THIS DECISION WAS MADE
BASED ON DATA SHOWING THAT AT
ANY GIVEN TIME IN L, A COUNTY
AND I IMAGINE THE NUMBERS ARE
SIMILAR THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CLOSE TO 20% OF THE PARENTS WITH
OPEN CHILD WELFARE CASES WERE
ONCE CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE.
FINALLY JUST UNDER A YEAR AGO,
WE OBTAINED GRANT FUNDING TO
BUILD A PARALLEL PROGRAM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. ALL THREE PROGRAMS
HAVE EXCEEDED EXPECTATIONS OF
THE 132 CLIENTS OF CURRENT
TEENAGERS AND YOUNG ADULTS WITH
OPEN FOSTER CARE CASES OF 132
CLIENTS SERVED IN THE FIRST TWO
YEARS, 89% AVOIDED FAMILY
SEPARATION AND OF THE 11%
INITIALLY SEPARATED ALL HAVE
EITHER REUNIFIED WITH THEIR BABY
OR THE BABY IS LIVING WITH THE
OTHER PARENT. SO THAT IS ZERO
BABIES IN FOSTER CARE. OUT OF
100 AND 32 TEEN PARENTS. OUR
GOAL IS 50% THIS PROGRAM HAS
SUCCEEDED EXPECTATIONS BEYOND
OUR WILDEST DREAMS. OUR PROGRAM
THAT SERVES ADULTS WHO ARE
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH HAS SERVED
45 CLIENTS SINCE LAUNCHING NÓ
PETITIONS HAVE BEEN FILED ON ANY
OF THE CLIENTS SUPPORTED BY THAT
PROGRAM. AGAIN THAT IS ZERO
CHILD WELFARE CASES. AND OUR
NEWEST PROGRAM, WHICH STARTED
SERVING CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH,
HERS, WHO ARE EXPECTANT OR
PARENTING LESS THAN A YEAR AGO,
HAS SERVED 40 THREE YOUNG PEOPLE
, 40 90% OF WHOM HAVE BEEN
SAFELY HAVE SAFELY MAINTAINED
CUSTODY OF THEIR CHILDREN, AND
OF THE THREE WERE REMOVAL
OCCURRED. ONE HAS ALREADY BEEN
REUNIFIED IN LESS THAN A YEAR.
AND THE NUMBERS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES. UM THESE PROGRAMS AS
I SAID, HAVE BEEN WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL. CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT DRAW DOWN FOR A FUNDING
THAT COULD PROVIDE FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS SPECIFICALLY FOR
PREVENTATIVE LEGAL SERVICES WERE
HOPEFUL THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND CDSS WILL EXPLORE
EXPANDING OUR CURRENT FOR E
PROGRAM TO ALLOW LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ACCESS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE EXPAND IT
AND HAVE IT BE AVAILABLE ACROSS
OUR STATE. AND NOW I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE WHO WILL
WALK YOU THROUGH WHAT THESE
SERVICES ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE FOR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU, LESLIE. AND
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. UM AND
WHILE NOT NECESSARILY DIRECTED
TO MY COMMENTS THIS AFTERNOON, I
DO COME TO YOU WITH SOME LIVED
EXPERIENCE AS A FORMER RESOURCE
PARENT. UM I TOOK IN CUSTODY OF
A BABY IN 2018. SHE WASN'T ABLE
TO REUNIFY AND SO OUR ADOPTION
FINALIZED, UM, IN THE SUMMER OF
20. 2020 UM, BUT WHEN WE BEGAN
THE PRE FILING WORK IN
SACRAMENTO, ONE OF THE EARLIEST
LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED WAS MANY
OF OUR YOUNG PARENTS, UM, WERE
UNAWARE OR DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY
DIDN'T KNOW. UM AND SO WHEN WE
WOULD ASK WHAT SUPPORTS OR HELP
THEY NEEDED MOST INITIALLY
SHARED THAT EVERYTHING WAS OK.
BUT BECAUSE WE HAD DEDICATED
STAFF TO SUPPORT OUR EXPECTED
AND PARENTING FAMILIES, WE WERE
ABLE TO DISCOVER THAT MANY OF
OUR CLIENTS WERE IN FACT, UM,
STRUGGLING WITH A MEETING JUST
BASIC NEEDS FOR THEIR CHILDREN
WITH DAYCARE AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES FOR THEIR CHILDREN
BEING ONE OF THE GREATEST
OVERLOOKED NEEDS OR MEETING
THEIR OWN PERSONAL NEEDS SO,
INCLUDING HOUSING AND MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS. TO US. THIS
HIGHLIGHTS HOW MANY, UM, OF THE
NEEDS OF OUR FAMILIES ARE OFTEN
OVERLOOKED, AND IT'S NOT UNTIL
THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT ABUSE
OR NEGLECT. THAT SUPPORT IS PUT
IN PLACE, WHICH IS OFTEN TOO
LATE. WALKING CLIENTS THROUGH
OBTAINING THEIR BENEFITS WHERE
THAT'S W I OR CHILD ACTION, UM,
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. AND
COACHING CLIENTS ON HOW TO
NAVIGATE EDUCATIONAL AND MEDICAL
SYSTEMS. UM IS SOME OF THE DAY
TO DAY SUPPORTS THAT THE PRE
FILING PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED UM
LESLIE SHARED THIS STATISTIC
THAT 20% OF THE PARENTS HAD
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT
THEMSELVES. UM THE CLIENTS THAT
ARE SERVED BY THIS TEAM ARE
RESOLUTE AND INTERRUPTING THAT
TREND AND WITH A DEDICATED TEAM
AT èC, L èC, UM, SUPPORTING
THEM ARE A BETTER EQUIPPED TO DO
SO. THE SACRAMENTO TEAM HAS
SUPPORTED CLIENTS THROUGH AGENCY
INVESTIGATIONS AND HELP THEM TO
CREATE, UM THEIR OWN PARENTING
PLANS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IN YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE
LIVED EXPERIENCES BECAUSE AGAIN,
YOU KNOW THAT TELLS US SO MUCH
ABOUT WHERE THE STORY IS, UM, I
DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS. AND
THEN IF WE HAVE NOT FINISHED THE
QUESTIONS, I WILL PAUSE AT 1145
JUST TO GIVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OPPORTUNITIES TO SHARE
THEIR, UM THEIR COMMENTS AS
WELL. SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT I WAS ABLE TO PULL
OUT OF. THIS IS WE KNOW WHAT
WORKS. AND THE QUESTION IS, DO
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT? WHAT WE KNOW? WORKS
IS OUR SYSTEM DESIGNED SO THAT
WE HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND CHECKS
AND BALANCES TO ENSURE THAT WHAT
WE KNOW WORKS IS NOT ONLY FUNDED
BUT ALSO ENFORCED. AND ARE WE
ABLE TO THEN? UM. J WHAT WORKS
AT THE LEVEL OF THE 100 PLUS
FAMILIES, UM THAT THAT YOU
MENTIONED MISS HèA TO THE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN THAT WE SEE IN
CALIFORNIA, SO I'M KIND OF
LOOKING AT THE AT THE LARGER
SCALE AND FUNNELING IT DOWN IS
WHERE WHERE IS THAT DISCONNECT?
WHERE IS WHERE ARE THE BROKEN
BRIDGES? THE BROKEN PIECES OF
COMMUNICATION BECAUSE THIS IS A
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE
HAD FOR GENERATIONS. YOU TALK
ABOUT THIS, BREAKING THE CYCLE
OF THE FOSTER CARE DEPENDENCY,
BUT THERE AMISS. THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DISCONNECTING
FROM THAT LONGEVITY, AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY ANY INSIGHTS THAT YOU HAVE.
OK? ARE YOU? WELL, YES. UM THE
FIRST THING THAT CAME TO MIND
AND YOU KNOW THIS MAY NOT BE AS
ARTICULATE BUT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS SAID EARLIER. UM UM BY
THE SENATOR WHO WHO HAD TO GO
AROUND. OFTENTIMES IT FEELS LIKE
WE ARE, UM YOU KNOW,
SUSTAINABILITY IS HARD WHEN
INVESTMENTS ARE OFTEN TIMES
DIRECTED TOWARDS FIXING A
PROBLEM THAT PERHAPS THE SYSTEM
SYSTEM HAS CREATED WELL INTENDED
OR NOT RIGHT AND THE NARRATIVE
AROUND SAFETY BEING THE FIRST
AND FOREMOST, UM, EVEN IN THAT
PARTICULAR EXCHANGE OF QUESTIONS
IS IF OUR VALUE IS CENTERED
AROUND, YOU KNOW, I THINK OUR
VALUES AND THE WAY WE LOOK AT
THINGS DRIVES WHERE THE MONEY
GOES, AND THEN HOW THINGS ARE
IMPLEMENTED. AND SO YOU KNOW
AGAIN, IT'S A BIGGER, BIGGER
ANSWER TO UNPACK. BUT I JUST
REALLY, UM, EMPHASIZE A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED
ON THE PANEL WITH REGARDS TO THE
WAY WE LOOK AT THE PROBLEM IS
GONNA BE HOW WE SOLVE IT AND
THAT SOMETIMES THE FIXES ARE
CAUSING PROBLEMS THAT CAN DRAIN
US BOTH CAPACITY AND FINANCIALLY
OVER TIME. YEAH, I. I AGREE WITH
THAT. AND I. I WILL ADD.
BUILDING ON THAT SAME THEME.
BECAUSE THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
INTERVENTIONS ARE FROM THAT LENS
OF UM HOW DO WE. THEORETICALLY
KEEP THIS CHILD SAFE FROM THEIR
PARENT RATHER THAN STRENGTHENING
THE FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY TO
KEEP THE CHILD SAFE. THE CURRENT
APPROACH IS FAR MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN A COMMUNITY DRIVEN APPROACH
. SO IN TERMS OF RESOURCES, IT'S
YOU KNOW, SHIFTING. UNTIL THE
PROBLEM IS 10 TIMES BIGGER PRE
FILING WOULD BE A PERFECT
EXAMPLE THE VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT IT WOULD CAUSE THAT
IT CAUSED TO KEEP FAMILIES OUT
DWARFS TO WHAT IT COSTS TO BRING
THEM IN. RIGHT UM, BUT WHAT WE
OFTEN SEE IN FUNDING SCHEMES IS,
AS THE POPULATION DECLINES, THE
SODA, THE RESOURCES AND IF YOU
IF THE BUDGETS GET CUT BECAUSE
WE'RE DOING OUR JOB WELL, WE
CAN'T KEEP DOING OUR JOB AND
THAT'S A HUGE AND WE SEE THAT
ALREADY IN THE WAY THAT LEGAL
SERVICES DOLLARS OR DISTRIBUTED
UM, FOR DEPENDENCY COUNCIL RIGHT
NOW, EVERY TIME YOUR CASELOAD
GOES DOWN, YOUR FUNDING GOES
DOWN, BUT WE'RE WORKING TO
SHRINK OUR CASELOAD SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE BETTER SERVICES TO
THE FAMILIES THAT WE DO NEED TO
SERVE TO HOPEFULLY SHORTEN THEIR
TIME AND CARE AND DO A BETTER
JOB OF ACTUALLY PROVIDING THEM
WITH EXCELLENT ADVOCACY WHILE
THEY'RE IN CARE, SO I THINK THAT
THE FUNDING PIECES CONNECTED TO
IT CERTAINLY CONNECTED TO
SOLVING THE PROBLEM. UM AND
STICKING WITH MY THEME OF
ENFORCING THE LAW. THE LAW SAYS
THAT THE GOVERNMENT, THE COUNTY
HAS TO PROVIDE REASONABLE
EFFORTS BEFORE THEY CAN REMOVE A
CHILD. WHAT REASONABLE EFFORTS
OFTEN LOOKS LIKE ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE COUNTRY IS THAT A
REPORT GETS FILED THAT SAYS
THERE'S A PROBLEM. A B, C AND D
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THE
CHILD IN THE HOME, BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THOSE THINGS SO WE'VE
REMOVED IT SHOULD BE. WE TRIED A
, M B AND C AND D AND E BEFORE
WE REMOVED WHICH AGAIN I THINK I
WOULD SUGGEST WOULD BE LESS
EXPENSIVE AND MORE COMMUNITY
FOCUSED AND CERTAINLY BETTER FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. UM SO
IT'S REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW
WE USE THE RESOURCES AND I CAN
GIVE YOU ANOTHER QUICK EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE HAD A LONG TWO YEAR
WORKGROUP GOING ON IN LOS
ANGELES RIGHT NOW, AROUND FAMILY
TIME, AND IN MOST CASES, THE
STANDARD REQUESTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE STANDARD
ORDER IS MONITORED VISITS IN A
NEUTRAL SETTING BY SOME APPROVED
MONITOR WHEN THERE'S BEEN A
SEPARATION, RIGHT? AND THAT'S
EXPENSIVE. COUNTY SAYS THEY, YOU
KNOW, SPENDS A MILLION HOURS,
SCHEDULING AN EQUAL NUMBER OF
VISITS, AND THAT'S ALL STUFF
TIME, ETCETERA. UM BUT THERE IS
NO DISTINCTION BETWEEN CHILD
SAFETY IN TERMS OF WHETHER THE
PARENT CAN ACTUALLY CARE FOR THE
CHILD. FULL TIME VERSUS, CAN THE
CHILD BE SAFE DURING A TWO OR
THREE HOUR VISIT WITH THAT SAME
EXACT PARENT, AND I WOULD EQUATE
IT TO IF I DECIDE TO LET MY 12
YEAR OLD NEIGHBOR CHILD WATCH MY
BABY FOR MY CHOP MY TODDLER FOR
AN HOUR WHILE I RUN TO THE
GROCERY STORE. THAT'S A SMART
PLAN. IF I CHOOSE TO HAVE MY 12
YEAR OLD NEIGHBOR RAISED MY
CHILD FOR THE NEXT 18 YEARS.
THAT'S A BAD PLAN, RIGHT SO
SIMILARLY, THE WAY WE LOOK AT
PARENTS AND FAMILIES AS IF IT'S
THIS ALL OR NOTHING. THERE WAS A
RISK THAT WE REMOVED AND SO NOW
THERE HAS TO BE MONITORED
VISITATION AND ALL SORTS OF
PROGRAMS AND YOU HAVE TO
COMPLETE YOUR CASE PLAN BEFORE
WE RETURN YOUR CHILD. THAT'S NOT
LOGICAL. THAT IS A RISK DRIVEN
RISK ANALYSIS, YOU KNOW, PROTECT
THE SYSTEM MORE THAN SERVE THE
FAMILY APPROACH AND IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE. SO I THINK THOSE ARE
SOME HIGH LEVEL WE COULD THINK
ABOUT. WE CAN THINK ABOUT MORE
CONCRETE LOWER, YOU KNOW, LOW
HANGING FRUIT, BUT I THINK
PHILOSOPHICALLY, THAT'S WHERE WE
SEE THE CHALLENGES. THANK YOU.
CAN I OFFER ONE MORE ELEMENT TO
ADD TO THAT ONE MORE AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. I CAN COME BACK. OKAY.
I CAN MAKE THIS QUICK. I THINK I
WOULD AGREE WITH BOTH OF THOSE
COMMENTS AND ANOTHER LAYER OF
COMPLEXITY TO THE QUESTION THAT
YOU'RE ASKING, I THINK SPEAKS TO
THE 58 COUNTIES ELEMENT THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN MANDATES THAT
EACH OF OUR COUNTY PARTNERS ARE
WORKING WITHIN AND THEN FUNDING
STRUCTURES IN ORDER TO HELP
SUPPORT THOSE MANDATES. AND YOU
ALSO HEARD ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
CULTURAL BROKERS. PROGRAM BEING
A BEST PRACTICE AND SOMETHING
BEING AFFECTIVE. AND YET, IF
THAT ISN'T TIED TO A CLEAR
FUNDING STREAM, A CLEAR
OPPORTUNITY FOR COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THAT AND THEN
BE ABLE TO REPORT ON THE IMPACT
OF IT, THEN IT'S REALLY UP TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL. COUNTY AND
LEADERSHIP TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY AND THEIR REGION ARE GOING
TO INVEST IN. SO THAT'S BOTH
BENEFICIAL TO HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. IT HAS ALLOWED US
AS AN ORGANIZATION TO HAVE MANY
DIFFERENT SORTS OF PILOTS AND
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING IN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. BUT WHAT IT
ALSO MEANS IS THAT THAT COULD
LOOK LIKE ONE THING IS HAPPENING
IN ONE COUNTY AND RIGHT NEXT
DOOR. THAT SAME OPPORTUNITY
DOESN'T EXIST BECAUSE THAT ISN'T
WHAT IS BEING INVESTED IN THERE.
I THINK ALSO TO THE POINT OF
SOFIA MADE THIS POINT IS THAT
WHEN WE LOOK ACROSS COUNTIES AND
YOU HAVE A YOUNG PERSON THAT IS
LOOKING FOR THEIR PLACEMENT IN
HER EXPERIENCE WAS KIN PLACEMENT
THAT THERE WAS A RELUCTANCE
ACROSS COUNTY LINES. UM AND
ULTIMATELY. HER SITUATION COULD
HAVE BEEN OUTCOMES COULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER IF THERE WAS MORE
INTEGRATION BETWEEN COUNTIES AND
THAT UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU KNOW
BEST BEST PRACTICES. BEST
SOLUTIONS. DON'T END AT COUNTY
LINES. YES. SO THANK YOU. OKAY I
MADE A PAUSE FROM Q AND A FOR
JUST A MOMENT AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS AND PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND ASK THAT YOU
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOU WILL HAVE
THE FULL TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT.
HMM. NICOLLE DAVID HANSON. I
LOVE MY FRIENDS. MY NAME IS
DAVID HANSON. I AM A CHEROKEE
CITIZEN. I'M A CREDENTIAL
EDUCATOR AS A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER AND SINGLE FATHER. I'VE
HAD BATTLE THIS CORRUPT CPS
SYSTEM FOR 13 YEARS IN ORDER TO
PROTECT MY DAUGHTER. I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED ITS
FAILINGS THROUGH THE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES AND THE EXPERIENCES
OF FAMILY FRIENDS, STUDENTS,
PARENTS OF STUDENTS. AND THAT OF
OTHER EDUCATORS THAT I WORK
WITH. THIS SYSTEM LACKS
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CORRUPT
CASEWORKERS AND JUDICIAL
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE PERSONAL
BIASES DUE TO PAST CASES IN
THEIR OWN PERSONAL FEELINGS, AND
ALSO LACKS THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES TO KEEP THOSE BIASES
OUT OF THE COURTROOM. THIS
SYSTEM ALSO LACKS THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES AS WELL AS A CALIBER
ACCOUNTABILITY TO KEEP FEUDING
PARENTS FROM MANIPULATING THE
SYSTEM. AND USING OUR CHILDREN
AS PAWNS. I DO HAPPEN TO HAVE
CREATED A SOLUTION TO ALL THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE SYSTEM,
CONSIDERING I HAVE BEEN AT
GROUND ZERO, WITNESSING WHAT'S
WRONG WITH THE SYSTEM FOR 13
YEARS, I HAVE WRITTEN A BILL
THAT I HAVE INTRODUCED TO ALL 40
SENATORS, AND I GAVE IT TO MAKE
SURE IF YOU'RE ALLEGEDLY
DIRECTOR. UNFORTUNATELY IT CAME
LATE. I CAME LATE TO THE GAME
AND SO I'LL TRY AGAIN. NO ONE
HAS YET BEEN ABLE TO FIND ANY
SUBSTANTIAL REASONS WHY THIS
BILL WILL NOT WORK. I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE CONSTRUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS
IN ORDER TO GET THIS BILL PASSED
IN THE FUTURE. SO ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LOVE TO DISCUSS
WITH ME I WOULD LOVE TO SHARE
IT. NONETHELESS THERE WERE 33.5
MILLION CASES OF CHILD ABUSE IN
THE U. S. AND IN 2022, AND 2.8
MILLION OF THEM WERE FOUND TO BE
NON VICTIMS. WITH MY EXPERIENCE.
CPS DOESN'T JUST COME TO YOUR
HOUSE. SEE THAT EVERYTHING IS
OKAY AND THEN WALK AWAY. NO,
THEY DO. INVESTIGATIONS RAN YOU
THROUGH THE COURT SEPARATE
FAMILIES OVER ISSUES THAT ARE
MERELY SPECULATIVE AND ALL OF
THIS TRAUMATIZES THE ENTIRE
FAMILY, CHILDREN, PARENTS,
SIBLINGS ELDERS. IT'S A HORRID
ABUSE BECAUSE THE COURTS ARE IN
FEAR OF THE BACKLASH FROM
LAWSUITS. IF THEY MAKE THE WRONG
DECISIONS, THERE'S IF YOU
PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY AND YOU
PROVIDE DISCIPLINE AND YOU
PROVIDE CHECKS AND BALANCES
KEEPS OUT THE LOT THAT YOU DON'T
SEE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
AMBIGUITY AND LANGUAGE, AND
THEREFORE THERE IS AMBIGUITY AND
LAW AND THEREFORE PEOPLE
MANIPULATED PARENTS MANIPULATED.
THE COURT OFFICIALS EVERYBODY
ELSE IN PLACE BECAUSE THEY ALL
HAVE THEIR PERSONAL BIASES. AND
THEN I ALSO HAPPEN TO KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CASES THAT
THEY'RE AFRAID IT'S GOING TO
BACKFIRE ON THEM, AND THEY'RE
GOING TO PUT THE CHILD BACK INTO
A FAMILY. THEY SHOULDN'T OR
WHATEVER OR FATHER THAT THEY
THINK ABUSIVE, SO THEY'RE GOING
TO SIT THERE AND THEY'RE GOING
TO SIDE. WITH ONE PERSON BECAUSE
THEY JUST DON'T WANT THE
BACKLASH. THAT'S NOT FAIR, AND
I'VE EXPERIENCED SEX. IT'S LIKE
A DOUBLE STANDARD FOR US. A LOT
OF US MEANT WE'RE AUTOMATICALLY
LOOKED AT AS BAD AND THE THINGS,
OF COURSE, HAS DONE TO ME AND MY
FAMILY. WOULD SICKEN YOU AND
WHAT THE JUDGE HAS DONE WAS
SECOND. YOU IT'S ILLEGAL IN
WHICH IS WHY I'M GOING BACK FOR
AN APPEAL TO IT. BUT NONETHELESS
, IT'S JUST ANOTHER ASPECT OF
ALL THIS THAT HASN'T BEEN
BROUGHT UP AND IT'S BEEN TOUCHED
ON. ESPECIALLY ABOUT YOU GUYS.
HERE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY? NAME AFFILIATION AND HIP.
TWO MINUTES FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, AMATEUR ALVARADO GILL
AND MEMBERS WENDY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES,
REPRESENTING OVER 165 DIFFERENT
NONPROFIT, COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE,
SERVING IN CHILD WELFARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I'D LIKE TO
UPLIFT THE REMARKS OF OUR MEMBER
SENECA TODAY ON THE NEED TO
COMMIT TO INVEST IN KIN CARE.
MITIGATE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
AND ENSURE CROSS SECTOR
COLLABORATION ACROSS SYSTEM
PARTNERS WITH THE CHILD'S NEEDS
AT THE FOREFRONT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR FOR UPLIFTING THE
NEEDS OF LGBTQ AND PAST FOSTER
YOUTH. TODAY WE WERE ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS ON SB 47 BY SENATOR
WIENER LAST YEAR. TO STRENGTHEN
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS AND PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION OCCURRING FOR
LGBTQ, FOSTER YOUTH. AND ALSO
SENATOR MENDOZA HAD TO LEAVE.
BUT THANK YOU TO SENATOR FOR
UPLIFTING THE OP ED BY OUR CEO
LAST YEAR IN CALMATTERS. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO SHARE AROUND THE
DIRE NOUS OF THE NONPROFITS IN
THE FIELD TODAY. WE HAVE LOST
OVER 1000 SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC BEDS SINCE JULY OF
2022 WHILE WE HAVE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND UNLICENSED CARE EVERY
SINGLE DAY, UM FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY RATES WILL DECREASE
WITHOUT A SUPPLEMENT FROM THE
STATE THIS YEAR. UM IN JULY, UM,
WITH 36% OF OUR FF AZAT RISK OF
CLOSING THEIR DOORS. AND 67% AT
RISK OF DOWNSIZING. UM AND
BEHAVIOR HAVE PAYMENT REFORM. UM
AND YOU KNOW IN OUR INTEGRATED
PROGRAMS HAS RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT SHORTFALLS FOR
NONPROFITS AND DISINCENTIVIZE IS
FIELD BASED SERVICES WITH A
PREFERENCE FOR OFFICE BASED
SERVICES, WHICH WE KNOW DOES NOT
WORK FOR OUR FAMILIES AND CHILD
WELFARE. UM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DETAILS AND DISCUSSIONS ON
THE FOSTER CARE RATE REFORM
PROPOSAL BY THE STATE AND
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU ALL
. AND THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO ADDRESS OKAY.
HERE IN CNN WILL MOVE BACK TO
THE Q AND A WITH THE PANEL. MHM
I MADE A NOTE HERE. UM. MISS
KANE. I THINK MAYBE THIS MIGHT
GO TO YOU. I AM A BIG PROPONENT
OF PEER TO PEER SUPPORT AND
HELPING TO MENTOR AND GUIDE AND
JUST BE THAT THAT SUPPORTIVE
VOICE OF BEEN THERE. DONE THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS WAS MY EXPERIENCE.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT? THOSE PEER
SUPPORT GROUPS ARE FILLING GAPS
TO EXISTING SYSTEMS. WHAT CAN WE
DO MORE OF AND THEN THE LINKAGE
TO FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
BECAUSE I THINK THE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS REALLY GIVE US
THAT PLACE WHERE FAMILIES CAN GO
AND BE SEEN AND HEARD IN IN THE
SPACE THAT THEY OWN IN THE
PERSONA THAT THEY OWN WITHOUT
THAT PUNITIVE EMBLEM OF
GOVERNMENT SEAL OR OR RIGHT, SO
I FEEL LIKE THERE'S THESE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE TO FILL
THOSE GAPS, BUT I'M CURIOUS TO
HEAR FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
ABSOLUTELY I'LL START WITH
SAYING I THINK THAT CLC AGREE.
IS WITH YOU OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
UTILIZING STAFF WITH LIVED AND
SHARED EXPERIENCES AND SO
LOOKING AT THE TEAM THAT WE HAVE
. I KNOW IN L A, BUT DEFINITELY
IN SACRAMENTO. A HUGE PORTION OF
THAT OUR OUR PEER ADVOCATES, AND
SO IT IS MAKING, YOU KNOW, YOU
KNOW, DOING THAT LINKAGE AND
CONNECTING OUR YOUNG FAMILIES
WITH, UM, STAFF WHO CANCER CAN
HELP, YOU KNOW, MENTOR AND GUIDE
HAVING HAD THAT SAME EXPERIENCE.
BEING YOUNG PARENTS THEMSELVES
AND ALSO COMING WITH THAT
EXPERIENCE OF BEING IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND TO TIE
THAT INTO YOUR SECOND POINT
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
CREDIBILITY. TO YOU KNOW,
REFERRING OUR OUR CLIENTS TO THE
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS. THAT'S
ONE OF OUR FIRST COMMUNITY BASED
RESOURCES THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE
ALL OF OUR FAMILIES. BUT
ESPECIALLY OUR YOUNG FAMILIES
ARE TIED TO, BUT AS YOU POINT
OUT, I THINK THEY'RE JUST
INHERENT FEAR OF ANOTHER AGENCY,
ANOTHER SET OF EYES AND SO
HAVING PEER ADVOCATES WHO SAID
NO, NO, I WENT THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM TO OR EXCUSE ME OR I'LL
GO WITH YOU. AH HERE'S WHAT THEY
DO. THIS IS WHAT THEY SAY.
THEY'RE NOT A PART OF. YOU KNOW,
THE AGENCY IN THAT REGARD HAS
REALLY BEEN CRUCIAL, BECAUSE I
AGREE. I THINK OUR FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS I WORRY. THERE
ARE UNDERUTILIZED RESOURCES
THERE ARE YOU KNOW, CAN BE THAT
ONE STOP SHOP RIGHT WHERE YOU
CAN GET ALL THAT SUPPORT, AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES. UM BUT I THINK YOU
KNOW. EARLIER IT WAS MENTIONED
KIND OF THE ROLE OF THE CULTURAL
BROKERS. I KNOW FOR LIKE OUR, UM
ADULT FAMILIES, OUR PARENTS, OUR
CULTURAL BROKERS, ASSIST WITH,
YOU KNOW, ENSURING THAT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY AND THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES. I THINK OUR PEER
ADVOCATES DO THAT SAME TYPE OF
BROKERING FOR OUR YOUNG
FAMILIES. I'M HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT. YES AND I HAVE ALSO SEEN
THAT THE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
THAT IN ADDITION TO YOU KNOW,
MAKING IT A WELCOME WELCOMING
WELL RESOURCED PLACE. THERE IS
THE LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL
BARRIERS THAT TEND TO BE BROKEN
DOWN. UM, AND YOU KNOW, THERE'S
SIMPLICITY IN TERMS OF ACCESS
THAT, I THINK REALLY ADDS A
LAYER OF TRUST WITH OUR WITH OUR
COMMUNITY, SO I ALSO WANTED TO
FOCUS ON THE 58 COUNTIES AND THE
BOUNDARIES BETWEEN THE 58
COUNTIES. AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SOME PROGRAMS THAT ARE
WORKING VERY WELL. WHAT IS
MISSING OR WHAT ARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO BUILD
THE THOSE BRIDGES HAVE
ENGAGEMENT AROUND BEST
PRACTICES. I MEAN, IS IT GOING
TO TAKE A LEGISLATIVE ACT TO SAY
ALL COUNTIES ARE GOING TO DO IT
THIS WAY? WHEN UM YOU KNOW, WE
THINK OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IMPLEMENTATION. UM BEING A
SUPPORTER OF LOCAL CONTROL, I
FEEL THAT OUR COUNTY IS KIND OF
KNOW THEIR COMMUNITIES BEST. BUT
WE'RE STILL MISSING. WE'RE STILL
LACKING IN CERTAIN AREAS. SO IN
YOUR OPINION, WHAT IS IT GOING
TO TAKE FOR US TO INTEGRATE
ACROSS THE 58 COUNTIES? BEST
PRACTICES. WELL, I CAN SAY AT
LEAST FROM THE LEGAL SERVICES
PERSPECTIVE. ALL OF THE PEER TO
PEER LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES ARE
GENERALLY DRIVEN BY THE ADVOCACY
GROUPS AND WE'RE NOT FUNDED TO
DO THAT. WE JUST DO IT BECAUSE
WE WANT TO HELP EACH OTHER
SUCCEED. FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE A
MONTHLY WEDNESDAY MORNING AT
EIGHT O'CLOCK CALL. IT'S TOTALLY
VOLUNTARY, OF COURSE, AND IT'S
ORGANIZED BY THE CHILDREN'S AND
PARENTS' LAWYERS TOGETHER. AND
WE GET TOGETHER AND WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTY'S WHAT NEW IDEAS? WHAT'S
WORKING? WHAT'S NOT PEOPLE ASK
QUESTIONS AND THEY HELP EACH
OTHER. BUT THAT'S NOT FORMALIZED
. THERE'S NO STRUCTURE TO THAT.
THERE'S NO GOVERNMENTAL SUPPORT
FOR IT. UM AND IT IS IT'S CBO
DRIVEN, WHICH IS GREAT, BUT WE
DON'T HIT EVERYBODY. UM AND WE
HAVE. IT'S ONLY THOSE THAT ARE
SORT OF THE BEST RESOURCED THAT
ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. UM SO I
THINK THERE COULD BE SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
PROMOTE THOSE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES WITHOUT
NECESSARILY MANDATING A
PARTICULAR PROGRAM OR A
PARTICULAR UM, INITIATIVE OR
PROJECT. I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THAT THOSE OF US THAT ARE DOING
THIS WORK ONE TO SUCCEED AT IT
AND WANTED, YOU KNOW, AND WHEN
WE WHEN WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND WE HAVE THE INFORMATION AND
THE STRUCTURE, PEOPLE JUMP AT
THE OPPORTUNITY, BUT ESPECIALLY
THE SMALLER COUNTIES, AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT CLC BECAUSE OF
OUR SIZE, WE HAVE A LOT OF
ABILITY TO TRY EXPERIMENTAL
THINGS TO BRING IN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
A PERSON WHOSE FULL TIME JOB IS
TO WRITE GRANTS. MOST OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS DO NOT HAVE THAT
LUXURY. I'LL CALL IT A LUXURY.
IT SHOULDN'T BE A LUXURY. JUST
LIKE ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES
SHOULDN'T BE A LUXURY, RIGHT? IT
SHOULDN'T BE A LUXURY, BUT IT IS
FOR US, SO MAKING IT EASIER FOR
THE SMALLER FOR OTHER COUNTIES
AND NEW ORGANIZATIONS, MAYBE
LESS ESTABLISHED. WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF KIDS AND PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE REPRESENTED
BY A PANEL LAWYERS. AND THEY GET
PAID BY THE CASE. THEY GET PAID
BY THE HOUR. UM THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THAT THE
ORGANIZATIONAL PROVIDERS HAVE,
AND I BELIEVE THERE ARE WAYS TO
GIVE THEM ACCESS TO THOSE
RESOURCES AND TO PROVIDE MORE
STRUCTURE WITHOUT NECESSARILY
DISRUPTING THE WAY THAT THEY,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE THEY'RE
COUNTIES CHOICE TO HAVE A PANEL,
BUT THERE COULD BE SOME THINGS
THAT COULD BE BROUGHT IN TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AS
WELL. AYE. I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO OFFER ANY HUGE SOLUTIONS FOR
YOU. BUT I DID WANT TO SHARE A
PERSPECTIVE FROM A PROVIDERS
EXPERIENCE, WHICH IS THAT I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE ARE WAYS IN
WHICH WE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THAT FLEXIBILITY ACROSS
COUNTY LINES AND THAT THE ARAB
BILITY TO BE ABLE TO SERVE YOUTH
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE,
BUT BASED ON WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE IS FOR US TRULY ONLY
HAMPERED BY THE PIECE THAT I WAS
SPEAKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT IF
WE DON'T HAVE A CONTRACT WITH A
PARTICULAR COUNTY TO DO A
PARTICULAR THING, AND THAT YOUTH
MOVES OUT OF THAT COUNTY, WE
STILL MIGHT BE ABLE TO SERVE
THEM. OUR OUR PHILOSOPHY IS THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SURVEY
YOUTH WITHIN 90 MILES OF THEIR
COUNTY OF ORIGIN OR AN OFFICE
THAT SONIKA HAS SO THAT COULD BE
LARGELY ACROSS THE STATE. AND IF
WE'RE NOT THE BEST PROVIDER TO
DO IT, THERE SHOULD BE A
DIFFERENT PROVIDER THAT WE'RE
HELPING TO REFER TO. Tð HOWEVER,
IF A YOUTH CROSSES COUNTY
BOUNDARIES AND WE DON'T HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THAT COUNTY TO DO
THE SAME THING, AND WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO LEVERAGE. FOR EXAMPLE,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FUNDING AGAIN
UTILIZING FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION IN COMBINATION
WHICH SOCIAL SERVICES FUNDING.
GREAT EXAMPLE OF THIS, FOR
EXAMPLE, IS WRAPAROUND SERVICES
IF THAT ISN'T POSSIBLE, OR WERE
NOT ABLE TO FUND IT THROUGH THE
COUNTY OF ORIGIN. BUT IT DOES
CREATE AN UNTENABLE SITUATION
FOR THE SERVICE PROVIDER THAT
THEN PREVENTS THE INDIVIDUAL
FROM CONTINUING TO RECEIVE THAT
SERVICE AND LOOKS LIKE THAT
YOUTH NOW GETS DISCHARGED FROM A
CURRENT SERVICE PROVIDER IS
REFERRED TO A NEW SERVICE
PROVIDER AND ASSUMING THAT THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SERVE THAT
YOUTH IMMEDIATELY. THEY THEN GO
THROUGH ALL OF THE SAME
DOCUMENTATION PROCESS. THAT
YOUTH IS THEN TELLING THEIR
STORY ONE MORE TIME TO YET
ANOTHER PERSON ABOUT WHAT IT IS
THAT'S GOING ON FOR THEM JUST TO
OPEN UP SERVICES. IS THAT WE'RE
ALREADY HAPPENING. WHAT IF WE
COULD HAVE THAT BRIDGE BETWEEN
THOSE TWO SYSTEMS? WE MIGHT NOT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH ALL OF THAT
PROCESS WHERE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT, OR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INTERNALLY TO
MANAGE DOES ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES WERE ABLE TO DO THAT,
BUT THAT ISN'T ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND THAT CERTAINLY IS NOT. YOU
KNOW, EVERY SERVICE PROVIDER IN
CALIFORNIA. UM AND I'LL JUST
SHORT QUICKLY ADD, UM AGAIN.
MAYBE NOT AS THIS SOLUTION, BUT
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
ALREADY POINTED OUT. THERE ARE
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS THAT
DICTATE WHAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING
IN THE COUNTIES. I THINK THAT
WHAT WE HEAR IN OFTEN FIND IS
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY. ISN'T CAN
CAN NO LONGER JUST BE AT. UM
OKAY. WE MADE A LAW. SOMEONE
SHOULD BE DOING THEIR JOB. YOU
KNOW, IT'S LIKE, UM, WHAT IT IS,
IS WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR WHEN,
UH, YOU KNOW, A YOUNG PERSON'S
RIGHTS ARE BROKEN OR A COUNTY
ISN'T DOING ISN'T FOLLOWING THE
LAW. WHAT IS THE PROCESS THAT
CAN BE IN PLACE TO ENSURE WHAT
IS THAT ACCOUNTABILITY LOOKED
LIKE AND THAT FULL SCOPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. SO UM, I WOULD
SAY, YOU KNOW, I DON'T I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DETAIL INTO SORT
OF SORT OF RESOURCING, BUT I
ALSO JUST WANT TO AMPLIFY THAT.
YOU KNOW, COUNTIES DO HAVE A
MANDATE TO DO MANY THINGS, AND
IT IS INEQUITABLE ACROSS THE
STATE, AND YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
WAYS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE CAN HOLD
THEIR COUNTY ACCOUNTABLE IN
THAT? CAN I ADD ONE QUICK THING
THAN THE FIRST PANEL, DR WEBSTER
TALKED ABOUT DATA IF WE KEPT
TRACK OF, FOR EXAMPLE, HOW MANY
YOUTH OVER THE AGE OF FOUR AND
OVER THE AGE OF 10 COME TO COURT
AT THEIR COURT HEARING, AND WE
REPORTED THAT DATA THAT WOULD BE
A VERY CONCRETE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURE ABOUT YOUTH VOICE. THE
LAW SAYS. IF THEY'RE 10 YEARS
OLDER, THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
THERE. AND IF THEY'RE 4 TO 10,
THEY HAVE A RIGHT AN OPTION TO
BE THERE. NOBODY COUNTS THAT IT
IS NOT MEASURED AS FAR AS I KNOW
ANYWHERE ANYWAY, BUT IT COULD BE
BECAUSE THE COURT RECORDS WHO IS
PRESENT IN THE COURTROOM, AND IF
WE HAD THAT DATA, IT WOULD GIVE
YOU THE ABILITY TO LOOK BACK AND
SAY. LESLIE, WHY DIDN'T YOUR
CHILDREN IN PLASTER COME TO
COURT ONLY 20% CAME TO COURT IN
2023. LUCKILY THAT WON'T BE THE
ANSWER, BUT BUT YOU, YOU KNOW,
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE, AND I
NEED TO STEP UP MY GAME OR WE
NEED TO LOSE OUR CONTRACT
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DOING OUR JOB,
SO I THINK THEIR DATA BRING US
BACK FULL CIRCLE TO DATA AND HOW
THAT COULD BE HELPFUL. THANKS.
THANK YOU. SO I AM. WE ARE GOING
TO BE WRAPPING UP HERE. MY LAST
QUESTION IS REALLY WHAT
INVESTMENTS DO YOU SEE THAT ARE
LACKING? AND HOW CAN WE AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA BE
GOOD STEWARDS OF OUR CHILDREN?
I'LL JUST JUMP IN AND REPEAT. UM
OUR MEMBERS WANT ME TO MAKE SURE
TO SAY AND REPEAT AGAIN THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP THE SILK INCREASE.
AH! YOUNG PEOPLE NEED ACCESS TO
HOUSING AND THE HOUSING MARKET.
AS WE ALL KNOW IS OUT OF CONTROL
AND INACCESSIBLE AND SO WE DON'T
WANT TO PROVIDE A RESOURCE THAT
THEY CAN'T ATTAIN, RIGHT. WANT
TO MAINTAIN FURS? MANY OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE USE THIS PROGRAM IT
IS BEING IT IS ON LOOKING TO GET
CUT COMPLETELY. THEY UTILIZE IT.
THEY WANT IT. KEEP IT IN PLACE,
AS WELL AS THE HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. I'M SURE
THERE'S MORE BUT. YEAH I'LL JUST
SHARE THAT. I THINK YOU KNOW
THIS WAS HINTED AT BEFORE, AS
WELL BUT SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR
THOSE INNOVATION PROJECTS. SO
YOU KNOW IT WAS, UM AH,
TRANSFORMATIVE TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS CRISIS CONTINUE ON
FUNDING. UM THROUGH A B 808 THAT
WAS APPROVED THROUGH 153. AND
THAT IS, YOU KNOW ONE TIME
FUNDING IMPLEMENTED OVER SEVERAL
YEARS, BUT THAT'S GOING TO
CREATE ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S NECESSARY. AND MANY
COUNTIES ARE NOW STRUGGLING WITH
SO WHAT, THEN IS GOING TO BE THE
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN FOR THAT,
AND A SECOND PIECES, JUSTIN
INVESTMENT IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
, YOU KNOW, AS YOU HEARD FROM
TYLER AND THE YOU KNOW HIS
ADVOCACY THERE WAS DOING AROUND
RATES THE RATES FOR FOSTER CARE
PROVIDERS FOR CAREGIVERS FOR
KING CAREGIVERS IS WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE AND HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH INFLATION. AND IT IS REALLY
PUTTING OUR SYSTEM AT RISK THE
SAFETY NET THAT'S GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO HELP ENSURE THAT
YOUTH DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO
HIGHER LEVELS OF CARE. THANK
YOU. AGREE ON THE ITEMS FROM THE
BUDGET, AND WE'LL ADD. AS I SAID
AT THE BEGINNING, UM HMM. TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE FOURIE FEDERAL
DOLLARS AND MATCHING DOLLARS FOR
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES TO KEEP
FAMILIES OUT OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND SECOND THE
RATE FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PARENTS AND CHILDREN HASN'T BEEN
ADJUSTED IN OVER 15 YEARS, WERE
EXPECTED TO CARRY A CASELOAD OF
140 FUNDING FORMULA IS BASED ON
AN ASSUMPTION THAT EVERY
ATTORNEY WILL HAVE 141 CLIENTS.
WE DON'T. THAT'S ABSURD. STILL
RIGHT? IT WAS. IT WAS 350 20
YEARS AGO, WHICH WAS
UNIMAGINABLE. BUT 141 CLIENTS
FOR ONE ATTORNEY IS NOT, AS IS
DOES NOT ALLOW BEST PRACTICES
AND DOES NOT ALLOW ADEQUATE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES TO THE
CHILDREN OR THE PARENTS. SO THAT
WOULD BE THOSE WOULD BE MY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DEFINITELY
ECHOING THE PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES IF WE CAN, UM HAVE YOU
KNOW, I THINK WE'RE FORTUNATE
FOR WHAT WE HAVE AT CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER. BUT A LOT OF THAT IS
DEPENDENT UPON YOU KNOW GRANTS.
UM AND SO IF WE COULD HAVE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR OUR
PREVENTIVE SERVICES TO ENSURE
THAT LESLIE MENTIONED, YOU KNOW
THAT OUR SYSTEMS AREN'T EVEN
MEETING THESE FAMILIES BECAUSE
WE'RE ABLE TO YOU KNOW, BOLSTER
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO THAT KIDS
CAN STAY WITH THOSE FAMILIES
SAFELY. SO MUCH, UM, BEEN TAKING
NOTES. I'VE GOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS IN HERE. SO
THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH. I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
ATTENDING TODAY, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S PERIOD AND GAVE THEIR
TESTIMONY. THIS HAS BEEN VERY
INFORMATIVE, AND WE'VE HEARD
SOME WONDERFUL INSIGHTS THAT
WILL BE PRODUCING AS A FOLLOW UP
TO TODAY'S HEARING IN OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR OUR BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS IN THE SENATE AND IN
OUR POLICY DECISIONS FOR THIS
YEAR. UM I DID WRITE DOWN ONE
THING. I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
HERE. UM THERE WAS QUITE A FEW
THINGS THAT REALLY STUCK WITH
ME. BUT OVERALL WHEN WE DO RIGHT
BY A CHILD, PROVIDING THAT LOVE
AND RELATIONSHIPS TO HELP THAT
FAMILY GROW AND MAINTAIN THAT
FAMILY STRUCTURE WE DON'T ONLY
HAVE TO SPEND YEARS TRYING TO
FIX THE REPAIR AND ADULT, BUT WE
INTERRUPT THE CYCLE OF FOSTER
CARE DEPENDENCY, AND I JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR BEING
PART OF THAT SOLUTION. WE NOW
WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.